hello everyone
welcome to day 4 of learning data
science by simply loan on D3 we looked
at SQL today we are going to learn about
another important skill that is
visual data visual helps you perform
exploratory to data analysis and find
hidden patterns in the data it lets you
analyze Trends in the data and draw
meaningful conclusions today we will
learn how to visualize data using
Tableau power bi and Excel and create
interesting charts and graphs reports as
well as dashboards using leading bi
tools so let's dive in and learn data
visualization for data science hello and
welcome to Tableau training for
beginners my name is Michelle covine and
I'm with the simply learned team so what
is business intelligence companies use
business intelligence Technologies to
collect analyze and present data in
order to create actionable information
today's businesses are always seeking
insights about their customers products
and services so businesses are faced
with many questions such as how do I
know my customers are happy what would
make my customers stay and how can I
increase awareness of my products and
services
business intelligence can help you
answer those questions when you have a
question about what your customers are
feeling what your customers are doing
who the customers are and what's the
best channel to Target them business
intelligence is a method of transforming
your data into these insights and
measurable metrics business intelligence
tools are designed to make the data flow
manageable in the age of information
Tableau is one of many tools to help
manage the data flow and turn data into
actionable information but we also have
click and sap and Oracle you may have
heard of some of these let's take a look
at some of the benefits of Tableau as
your business intelligence tool so why
would we use Tableau it can be connected
to 40 different data sources the more
data sources it can connect to it means
that you are more likely to get direct
access to your data it can build
interactive dashboards with just a few
clicks which can help you quickly
understand your data and it lets you see
your outliers there's also simple
analytics build right into Tableau such
as Trends and forecasting that can help
you understand your data on a deeper
level Tableau has been a leader in the
Gartner magic quadrant for the last six
years and that includes 2018. here we
will take a look at an overview of the
products offered by Tableau so we have
Tableau desktop which is where you do
all of your development this is where
you connect to and build visualizations
and dashboards today we'll be using
Tableau public which is a free version
of Tableau desktop but with some
limitations such as having no R
integration and it can only support up
to a million rows of data also any data
published here is made public so you
can't use this for private company
information then there's a new tool
called Tableau prep where you can
prepare your data by seeing it visually
before you connect and build reports
there's also Tableau online which is a
cloud hosted version of Tableau server a
place where you can publish your
dashboards and it enables you to share
your dashboards in a secure way Tableau
server has as an option to be on
premises so let's just do a quick
comparison between building a
visualization in Excel and building one
in Tableau okay so here we have an Excel
file full of data that we will soon
connect to and use for some of our
demonstration purposes and you can see
that we have information about orders if
we wanted to find out the quantity sold
and the sum of sales for each region we
could do that by creating a pivot table
so we'll make it I selected my cells
we'll make it in the new worksheet and
here we have the beginnings of a pivot
chart and we can grab region and pull it
into our columns and then we'll grab
sales and put it into values and then we
also want to look at quantity and put
that into values and it's automatically
summing up sales and quantity but you
can choose if you want it to be some or
not and then we'll take our values and
put it on rows so that we can see sales
and quantity one on top of the other and
that's the basics of a pivot chart now
let's do a similar thing in tableau
okay so we have our connection to the
data and Tableau automatically splits
out the dimensions from the measures
we'll go into more depth on that later
but we can come and grab a region and
put it onto columns and we get a similar
thing maybe a little nicer formatted and
then we can come and put quantity there
now if we want to add sales to it we can
double click on sales and we'll have
quantity and sales one on top of the
other we could put sales on top by
dragging quantity down in that box we
also have this show me dialog box which
allows you to see what visualizations
you could build using what's already on
the screen or the things that you have
selected so right now we could quickly
switch it to bar charts and now we can
see quantity and sales across our region
with bar charts or we could switch it to
Stacked bars and we can see our quantity
across the regions if you close that we
can see our Legend over here and then
our sales across the region so in
Tableau we have a lot of really quick
flexibility to turn just text into a
visualization so in summary we can see a
side by side of what we made using pivot
tables in Excel and what we made in a
similar amount of time in Tableau let's
get started with the Tableau
installation as for requirements you
need Windows 7 or later or you need your
Mac operating system to be 10.11 or
later here are some of the browsers you
can use to install Tableau we will be
installing Tableau public today and to
do that you just Google Tableau public
download and click on that first link
and then you put in your email address
and click download the app so
let's just look up Tableau public
download
and it's this first one you can click
download now it takes you to the Tableau
public page where you can click sign in
and create an account free
this gives you a place to save the
visualizations you make but keep in mind
anything you save on Tableau public is
public and then you come here and you
enter your email address and click
download the app and it should give you
executable file that you will download
and once it's downloaded you should be
able to open Tableau public so let's go
take a look at the Tableau public
opening page
so this is what Tableau public looks
like when you first open it on your left
you have the different things you can
connect to this is more limited in
Tableau public than it is in Tableau
desktop so if you invest in Tableau
desktop you have many many things you
can connect to you can also connect to
data by clicking this drop down connect
data piece that's especially useful when
you've already started your
visualization then we have the central
portion called open this is where
anything that you have opened up
previously will show up you can also
click open from Tableau public and when
you have my connections timed out so I
need to log in but when you log in it
says no workbook found try publishing
first this is where you'll see all of
your published Tableau public dashboards
over here we have discover and it has
some how-to videos
visualization of the day which is where
people who have made Tableau public
visualizations get recognized for their
skill and you get some pretty cool ideas
when you look there so let's get started
by connecting to a data source we'll
click Microsoft Excel and we'll choose
our Excel file and open it up and this
is our data source page this shows you
the sheets on the Excel file and allows
you to drag them in so that you can see
the data show up this gives you a
preview of what your data will look like
you can see the Tableau is starting to
classify our Fields so anything that has
ABC on it shows that that's a column
that has strings in it we also have a
globe which was where Tableau has
recognized these values to be
geographical
so we have
um State and it's recognized that it
contains States it bases it on the
keywords that it stores to identify if
it's geographical and so it takes a look
and you've named it City and it knows
that city is geographical we also have
the calendar symbol where it's
recognized that it's a date field and we
also have row ID that shows up with the
hashtag and I recognize that's the
number so now that we have our data
source pulled in we can come here and
hit sheet which is where you start to
build your visualization let's take a
look at all the different pieces of this
before we go any further we have the
data that we're connected to up here is
our orders sheet from the sample
Superstore Excel sheet we have
dimensions on top and measures on bottom
these are where we're going to get the
fields to drag and drop here we have our
cards we'll look more in depth at our
cards in a moment and these are our
shelves the column shelf and the row
shelf where you can drag things in to
make changes happen in the visualization
Center we have our show me tabs where
you can see we took a brief look at this
earlier but you can see all the
different visualizations you can build
here a neat thing about show me is that
when you hover it'll tell you what types
of fields you need to build it so for a
symbol map try one geographical field
zero or more Dimensions or zero to two
measures and that's how you can build a
geographical symbol map and when you're
done with show me you just close it
let's take a look here at our sheets so
we have sheet 1 and Sheet two a sheet is
basically just one visualization at a
time
get rid of the extra sheet we have a
dashboard which is where you can pull
multiple sheets on to show multiple
visualizations at one time
and then we have What's called the story
which allows you to show a sequence of
visualizations so that you can tell a
story
perfect okay so we saw that Tableau is
categorizing are different fields and it
is also giving it a role so we have
dimensions on top and measures on bottom
Dimensions contain descriptive values
such as names dates and geographical
data you can use Dimensions to reveal
details in your data that is qualitative
details we also have measures which
contain numeric quantitative values that
you can measure measures can be
aggregated and when you drag a measure
onto the view Tableau will apply an
aggregation to that measure it's some by
default
so let's show this by building what we
built before we'll grab region and we'll
see its four distinct values as a
dimension and then we'll double click on
quantity and we can see the numbers here
the measures and you can see here that
it is the sum of quantity and now we can
also double click on sales and we can
see quantity and sales to discuss a
little bit more about dimensions and
measures you can see that in general
measures or numbers and dimensions are
not but sometimes like row ID it is a
number now why would we have a number up
here instead of in the measures so you
can tell the difference between number
whether it should be in measures or it
should be in Dimensions based on whether
you'll need to do any calculations on it
or if you would want to be able to
aggregate it at some time so for sales
if you have
several orders in a day you might want
to know what the sum of those sales are
but if you have several orders in the
day and they are on rows two three four
and five you might not want to know the
sum of the rows so Tableau is smart
enough that when it sees ID it knows
that it belongs up in the dimensions now
you can switch so if row ID was actually
something you would want to aggregate
for some reason you can drag it down to
the measures and add it down there
but in our case row ID isn't something
that you want to sum or average can you
think of any other numbers that might
not show up as a measure that should be
a dimension comment below with your
answers as we discussed before
dimensions are on top measures are on
bottom and you can see the blue is
associated with dimensions and green is
associated with measures but it's a
little bit more complicated than that so
dimensions are qualitative and measures
are quantitative but blue means we want
our label to be discrete and green means
we want our label to be continuous let's
make a new sheet and make a
visualization to kind of show this so we
can bring on quantity and we're going to
use it as a dimension but you can see
even when it's Dimension you can choose
continuous or discrete so right now it's
a dimension but it's green it's a little
bit different than what you might expect
and then we'll do sales so now we can
see over the different quantities what
our sales was yeah has been for this
last this period of time that we're
looking at I believe it's four years so
for when people bought three items the
total sales was that number and you can
see that this is an axis so it's from 1
to 15. now if we change it from
continuous to discrete you can see that
one is a label two is a label and it's
not an axis ranging from one to it
doesn't even have 15 because there are
no values under 15. these are just
individual labels so we go back it's
green again and you can see that it's an
axis so we have two greens on here so we
have two axes and change it back to
discrete and now we have one axes and
one set of individual labels so let's go
back to our sheet three we have all of
these different sales by the different
quantity numbers and up here we have our
sorting when you hover it tells you what
kind of sorting is going to happen so we
could sort quantity descending by sales
so we can see that when they buy three
things we add the highest sales
you can do the opposite
where it's the lowest
to the highest
number of sales you can also do sorting
more in depth by clicking on the
quantity and right-clicking sort so we
could just sort
by descending or ascending or by sales
or
alphabetic which is not what we want you
can choose the field or you can manually
change your sorting here
and now we're back to what we had at the
beginning now that we've had an overview
of how Tableau Works let's go into a
little more detail Tableau is very much
built on the premise of drag and drop
so let's build a simple visualization
and talk about what each of these shells
and marks cards specifically do so we're
going to make a simple chart which is
average sales by region so we know we
want sales
on
let's do sales on rows now for rows and
for metrics since this is continuous
like we talked about before it's making
an axes
for our sales we also can drag region
onto columns and it makes one column per
region so that's how it works with
Dimensions if you
um pull a dimension onto columns you're
saying I want one blank per column I
want one region per column so if you
wanted to do it by instead of region if
you want to remove something from a
visualization you just pull it back off
or you can hit undo or Ctrl Z Tableau
has the benefit of having unlimited
undos so let's say we wanted to bring on
City let's say we want one column per
City and that's what you get and there's
a lot of cities
so that's what it looks like let's take
City back off I want one column per
region and for sales
I want my rose axes
to show me where sales are great now
let's say we want to adjust the color of
These Bars you can click on color and
you can select any of them so let's pick
this nice blue or we can pick an orange
and that's how you can determine the
color but if you want something else to
determine the color you can take region
and drag it onto color and now we have
one color per region
now with measures again since they're
continuous it's going to be more like a
scale so if I want them to be
a different color based on sales and I
pull sales onto color it's going to be
darker where there's higher sales and
lighter where there's lower sales so
it's continuous from light to dark but
for region
it is one color per region so they're
distinct colors it's not continuous
great
um let's say we want to sort this
biggest to smallest and we can look at
size here so if we want to adjust the
size manually we can click on it and
drag it
but if we want the size to be based on
something else
you choose a measure for the size so if
we want it to be
wider
based on sales we will drag sales onto
size and we can see that it gets bigger
with bigger sales you do the same thing
and replace the sales with profit and
now it's bigger if there is bigger
profit and drag that back off so you can
determine manually or you can do it with
your measures for label let's say we
want the sales onto label now we can see
the exact sales number for each region
um what if we wanted the name of the
region there as well we can drag region
onto labels and we can see sales for the
west region you can adjust which one
goes on top
see how we have two T's here those are
both labels great uh tool tip when we
click on tooltip it'll show us what's
going to happen when we hover so as I
hover here on East it says region East
sales and that shows the sales amount
now we talked about
I'll take my labels back off wanting to
make this visualization not for the sum
of sales but for the average of sales
so we will right click on our sum of
sales here in the rows hover over
measure
um which right now is sum and change it
to average and we have a different
result here so let's sort again and we
can see that the South Region actually
has the highest average of sales which
was not the case for the sum now let's
say we want our sum I mean our sales to
be on the label but look it's giving us
the sum of sales label so we just do the
same thing
and change it to average now we can see
our average on the label
the label has some interesting options
like you can format this and we could
say maybe we want it to be
all of them to be blue and that happens
right there you can also choose to only
show the minimum and the maximum this
becomes handy on a line chart where you
don't want all marks labeled because it
gets very messy but you want the tallest
and the shortest part to be labeled and
maybe you just want the tallest so we'll
click label minimum value and remove
that checkbox and now we just have the
tallest value there
and one card that we haven't used yet is
the filters card so we could allow
people to look at this but only certain
regions so what we can do is we can come
over to region and right click on it and
click show filter and it will add it to
that filters card and now we can remove
Central from the mix and just look at
those ones you see if we remove South
the new highest East now has the label
but if we put it back in South we'll
have the label again if we don't want to
have these filters we can pull it off
there or if we wanted to filter out
by country oh we just have United States
so let's not filter by country
um but we could pull in category
and we have these filters by category if
we select them all they'll all be there
and we click show filter and it will
bring it over here and we can remove our
technology and the South still has the
highest for the other two but if we only
include technology you can see the
difference there
so that's the basics of filters
one another thing that I can mention
here is that you can change the type of
Mark manually so you saw when we pulled
on region and we pulled on sales it
automatically made us a bar chart but we
could change this to be a line chart and
you can see that the color changes
because we told it to based on region if
we pull that off
then it would be a line chart there you
can change it to be a lot of different
type of visualizations here
so when you're not using show me to help
determine your graphs you can choose it
manually right here
okay now let's look at building a
scatter plot so scatter plot is when you
have a bunch of shapes and points on a
visualization with two axes that are
both measures
so if we take
sales
and put it on the y-axis and we take
discount and put it on the x-axis we can
see our point that represents all of our
data with the sum of sales and the sum
of discount and if we wanted to see this
per order we'll take order ID and put it
onto detail now what detail does is it
determines the level that we are
building our visualization at so
grabbing order ID and putting on to
detail gives us all of these little
points so for each order what was our
sales and what was our discount so we
have
out here some outliers that you can find
very quickly let's actually do product
ID instead so I'll put it right over top
of order ID and it will replace it
now we see all of our products anything
that has high sales is up here anything
that has high discount is over here you
can see that it sort of has a trend
where things with high sales do not have
high discounts which makes sense if we
wanted to know what category these
products I'll show up in we could take
category
and put it onto shape
and now we have three different shapes
that tell us the categories Tableau has
a cool new highlight feature which
allows you to show just the dimension
that you want to see but it leaves the
other ones in place so for example if we
click on furniture
first we have to turn on the Highlight
feature and then click on furniture
and now you can see all of the furniture
items popping up in our visualization I
know how they're kind of clustered in
this area and the pattern for them when
we click on technology we can see their
pattern which is a little bit different
so we have them by shape with category
let's drag category onto color as well
if you remember category will determine
the color
and the shape at this point and so we
can kind of see the patterns happening
there
so if we want to see our high discounted
items they're all over here and most of
the things that are getting
High discounts are office supplies which
is interesting
and then our highest sales product up
here now we could take that product ID
and find out what that product actually
is out of our oh look we have product
name let's replace product ID with
product name
and we see that that is a Canon Image
class Advanced copier so this copier is
our big sales person and office supplies
binders do not give us very many sales
and we're highly discounting them
so now you know a little bit more about
the details card and the shapes card and
about using highlighting
in tableau
so let's say we wanted to know by
subcategory what our profit is like we
could grab subcategory and pull it onto
columns and we would say we want one
column per subcategory
and then let's grab profit and pull it
onto rows and you can quickly see
which categories are profitable and
which ones are not so we can also take
profit and put it on the color
so that you can see that even more
clearly right now it is going from
Orange to Blue which is Tableau default
if we wanted to change from what color
to what color it was going we have a lot
of options in here when you go to edit
colors it breaks it up by sub category
so Furniture's all here and then there's
our subcategories under Furniture if we
were to move subcategory to the front
it really doesn't group it appropriately
because first it's breaking it up by
subcategory and then by category and
that's not effective we end up with
furniture furniture furniture furniture
spread out across our visualization so
again let's put category to the front
and now we have our profit by category
by sub category and we can click sort
subcategory descending by profit and now
what it does is within the highest group
within each group
it then sorts it by profit so you can
tell it's not going to break this group
apart to move tables to the very end
it's going to keep tables inside of
furniture and then it doesn't move
furniture to the very end either
so what we have here is a quick view by
category by subcategory how we're doing
on profit we can see that tables is our
biggest drain on profit and so if we
wanted to improve the profitability of
furniture maybe we would not sell tables
anymore it's just not working out for us
another thing about this visualization
that we could do to improve it is you
can see that there's some of these words
are getting cut off so we could right
click on this axes and click rotate
label
and now you can read the whole word and
so that's helpful also up here we have
our title which right now is the same
name as our sheet
so if we rename the sheet to profit by
sub category then it names the title up
here so this is making it look a little
bit better and then here we have profit
and it shows it but without any like
dollar signs so let's come up here to
profit and click format and you can see
that we can format the sum of profit
to be currency
and we can do it currency by the
thousands and we can get rid of these
decimal places and now you can see it's
just a little bit nicer a little bit
more clear so that you can build along
with me just make a comment in the
comments below and this is a simply
learned team will send you this data set
now we're going to take a look at
creating a hierarchy in tableau
so I'll make a new tab and we're going
to make a sheet called
sales
by product
and so we will be looking at sales as a
number
and let's bring on product name
now there are a lot of products names so
it's going to make sure that you really
want to do this then I click add all
members and now we can see all of our
products and their sales overall time so
if we sort this we can see our highest
selling item which we discovered earlier
as the advanced copier and we scroll
down to the bottom our lowest selling
items
so we have our products and we can group
that by subcategory and you can see I
need to put it in the front again
and by category
all right I'm going to take product name
back off and we're going to talk about
hierarchies so a product rolls up into a
subcategory which rolls up into a
category you can create a hierarchy by
let's start with subcategory and
dragging it on the category and it's
going to create a hierarchy we'll call
it our product
hierarchy
and now it knows that category is the
parent to subcategory let's do the same
thing by grabbing the product name and
putting it underneath subcategory so now
in those categories the parent then
their subcategory and then there's
product name this allows you to instead
of pulling this off or putting it back
on
you can bring category on and then you
can expand it by pressing this plus
button and now we see but here's our
sales by category by sub category
and then here's our sales by category by
subcategory by product name this is
really useful when you're creating a
detail section for your users and so
when somebody wants to know let's say
you have
show filter for category and a filter
for subcategory
which will filter for subcategory and
they're looking at category here and
they're just like I see technology has
the highest sales and I just want to see
technology so I'm going to unclick
furniture and office supplies
let's put category on top and then so I
just have technology well I want to see
what has the highest sales inside of
technology and let's sort it oh phones
phones does so I just actually want to
look at phones so I'm going to remove
accessories copiers and machines and
what has the highest sales inside of
phones
and sort it and now I can see quickly
the detailed information
without having to change my
visualization let's give this
visualization a little more depth
first I'll add back in all of our
categories and subcategories
by showing across region
so we know technology had the highest
but how does it look across region now
part of the point of Tableau is to allow
the users to read the visualizations
very quickly and when you have big
blocks of text like this it's kind of
hard to see which one has the highest
because it doesn't quite stand out very
quickly so what we can do is take sales
and drag it onto color let's change our
marks to a square and now it's going to
color each of these it colors every one
of these cells based on its Darkness for
sales this is a little bit heavy of a
color you can click color here and
change the opacity to give it a little
bit of a lighter look
just makes it a little bit see-through
great so now it's a lot easier to see
that the West seems to have the highest
sails and that technology in the East is
the very highest so now when we drill
into subcategory it keeps that coloring
and we can see more in depth and quicker
that phones has the highest across most
of them it's not quite the highest in
the west because chairs is the highest
in the west there's one place in Tableau
where hierarchies are built in and
that's in dates so dates in Tableau can
be very complex because they allow very
complex visualizations so we will not go
into depth about dates at this time but
let's take a look at how they work for
hierarchies so we have order date that
we can pull onto columns here and you
can see that it's blue meaning that it's
discrete so each one of these is a
header instead of it being an axis
across the top
now let's drag profit onto rows so now
we can see our profit over time for each
of these years
and Tableau has some hierarchies built
into dates already so when I click this
Plus on columns it'll split it out into
quarters so this is a header and these
are all subheaders underneath that
header because it is distinct
um and discrete right now instead of
continuous so it's split out year year
year and quarters quarters quarters
quarters this allows you to quickly
compare quarter one across all of the
years and Quarter Two across all the
years and quarter four across all the
years
another way you could add some more
detail to this is by taking maybe
category and pulling out to color and
now we have one line for each category
and we can see that uh drop in
technology is a big part of the
responsibility for that drop we were
seeing in quarter two of 2016. so let's
take that back off and let's take
quarter back off
and let's explore continuous dates so
here in dates we have our top section of
dates and then you see it repeats and we
have the bottom section of dates so
we've got year but we also have year
here quarter and quarter now the top
ones are all discrete and when I change
it to a bottom one year same thing same
year it changes it to be green and now
it's continuous
so now instead of this being a header
for 2013 and a header for 2014 it's an
axis so the difference here is when I
press the plus and it changes it to
quarter instead of adding quarter to
year now it's doing quarter four each
year and making one continuous line and
we can keep going and drill down to
month
you can go pretty far now when we add
category as color we get our three lines
for the three categories and we also
have highlighting turned on here still
so when we click on technology we can
highlight technology with the others in
the background so we don't lose the
context of the other categories
take that back
next let us talk about calculated Fields
so we'll make a new sheet and we're
going to create our first calculated
field we can create a calculated field
by clicking this Arrow which gives us
some options and clicking create
calculated field or we can come and
click in the white space below
Dimensions or below measures and we
right click and click create calculated
Fields let's name it
profit ratio so this is for if we wanted
to create a visualization that showed
the profit ratio but we don't have that
measure readily available to us to bring
in fields for our calculation you can do
it in one of two ways one is to start
typing it
and it will start Auto prompting you for
the different measures or for different
calculations or values you can use or
you can come and drag it in so if we
want profit and we want sales if we do
profit divided by sales that is a profit
ratio
unaggregated
okay and let's make a second calculated
field we could come here and click
duplicate and that will duplicate our
field but I just want to start over
again so I'll click create calculated
field
and I will call it profit
ratio aggregated
and in this one we're going to do sum
click of profit
click divided by sum of sales
okay so now what's the difference
between profit ratio aggregated and
profit ratio unaggregated how will those
behave differently in Tableau let's look
at this by looking at a single order so
first let's bring on all the orders and
all the products under that order and
let's look at this order so I want to
filter this whole dashboard to only this
order so I can right click on it and
click keep only that creates a filter up
here
that only has that box checked
and if I want to get rid of this later I
can just pull it right off of filters
and everything will come back but I want
it so keep only
and now let's take a look at profit
ratio aggregated I double clicked on it
and I added it here and profit ratio
unaggregated again double clicking
another side by side let's give us a
little bit more room
so when I dragged that out it gave us
more room so we could see them side by
side in the entire titles okay so I
chose to look at one order and these
product names because the combination of
order and product name is unique one per
row we know that Tableau will aggregate
the data up to the lowest level in the
visualization and I brought it all the
way down to the lowest level of the data
source so we have no aggregation right
now so when we're looking at it without
any aggregation these two calculations
are the same profit ratio aggregated
let's look at that again we'll click
edit and that's the one where we sum
profit and some sales before we divide
and then we've got profit ratio
unaggregated so let's also look at
profit and look at sales this is a
technique that I use when I'm trying to
understand how my calculated fields are
working try to break it down to the
lowest level possible and see if it's
doing what I expect
so we've got profit and we've got sales
now both of them are at 0.5 or 50 and
that's because profit is eight and sales
is 16. for Adam's telephone messaging
now let's take off project name when we
take off product name we can see that
they start to vary they've got profit
ratio aggregated and profit ratio
unaggregated so here we have profit and
sales the profit ratio should be profit
divided by sales so let's open up a
calculator
and make it a little smaller so if we
take profit at
219.1 and divide it by sales at
508.6 we get 0.4 not 1.8 so where does
this 1.8 come from well let's put a
product name back on here
what happens is with profit ratio
aggregated it sums up the profit and
then divides it by the sum of sales so
that's what we did when we took off
profit ratio and aggregated we had the
sum of profit and divided it by the sum
of sales which is what we want profit
ratio unaggregated however does the
calculation profit divided by sales and
then sums it afterwards you can see it
right here it's the sum of profit ratio
on aggregated so it makes this
calculation and then
it adds up 0.5 plus 0.5 plus 0.3 plus
0.5 and that's where we get our 1.8
which is what we see when we pull off
product name 1.8 so for most
calculations you want to do profit ratio
aggregated
where you determine how it's aggregated
before you do the calculation so let's
remove profit ratio on aggregated
and delete it let's go to profit ratio
aggregated
and just call it profit ratio
perfect now we no longer need anything
that we have on our visualization right
now so let me show you a quick trick to
clear the board Tableau has this button
up here which is called clear sheet you
can also do on Windows alt shift
backspace and you just click clear sheet
and it will start to chew over with that
sheet and that really helps when you've
dragged a bunch of things on and really
made a mess when you're trying things
out okay so we're going to build
visualization and we're going to look at
Region and we're going to look at it by
profit ratio and so now we have this bar
chart by profit ratio let's color this
by region we can also pull on profit and
sales and we can see all three of them
side by side split out by region now
let's say we also wanted to see each
region by sales per customer so let's
create some calculated fields that will
help us do that let's create our first
calculated field that's going to get us
a count of customers
call it total number of customers
customers and so we have customer name
and customer ID let's do count distinct
of customer ID and that gives us the
total number of customers
why so right now we could take total
number of customers and see which
categories have the highest number of
customers perfect but that's just one
part of our calculation we want to see
total sales divided by a total number of
customers so let's make our second
calculated field and we're going to call
it sales per customer
so we're going to do our sum of sales
which we can drag in and divide that by
total number of customers now you see
that calculated field we just made pops
up inside of our calculation dialog box
and we hit apply and it shows up so we
hit OK and let's replace total number of
customers with sales per customer and
now we can see our sales per customer
ratio and which ones have the highest or
for this next part I'm going to make a
couple of visualizations in a row that
I'll apply to the same information using
a couple of different tactics so first
let's use show me so I want to look at
Region and sales for this visualization
so I'm going to control click region
after I clicked sales so one more time
I'm going to click on sales and I'm
going to control click region and I'm
going to click show me and it's going to
give me all of the different
visualizations I could make with region
and sales let's pick
3 map
great so now we have a tree map that
shows us our sales by region and we have
the size and the color of the box is
both sales so let's say we wanted the
size to be sales but the color to be
profit so let's grab profit and drag
that on to sales so now we can see our
most profitable to our least profitable
let's
edit our colors and we're going to
change it from red to blue diverging red
to blue but let's go to Advanced and
make the center number
zero this means that it will never be
red unless it's less than zero so let's
hit apply so it's all blue and if
anything ever goes negative then it will
be red
okay let's call this sheet
sales profit by region
perfect now we're going to start using
our geographical Fields so we have state
city country and postal code let's
double click on State and see what
happens
so it is generated these two Fields
Tableau has generated longitude and
latitude for us and it's been able to
recognize the states in the United
States and where they're located and
given it a longitude and latitude so
next we will look at sales by state by
double clicking on sales and what it's
done was change the size of the dot
based on sales now I think I'm going to
move sales from size to color and it has
automatically changed it to a filled map
instead of dots on a map perfect so now
we can see the states
with the biggest amount of sales let's
put it back onto size and we have our
circles again
let's put sales on the size not stayed
onto size and we have our circles again
but let's make them a little bit bigger
these two marks on the Tableau size line
are to give you an idea of how big and
how small you should go before it gets
too difficult to see so when we go
bigger than the bigger line it detects
that you're getting close to having
overlap
but it's up to you as the Builder okay
so we have size 4 sales again and for
profit onto color again so you can see
anything that is more profitable is
darker and anything that is less
profitable or less than zero in this
case is Orange Let's do what we did with
color before
change it to red blue diverging and set
our Center Point to zero okay
so now we know that if anything is red
it was negative in profit perfect let's
name this sheet
sales profit by state
great now let's look at sales and profit
by category so we have category and
we've made columns so this is when we
drag something to the columns shelf just
remember we want one column per category
and let's double click on sales and it's
going to put it into text and that's not
what I want so let's take sales and drag
it onto rows and it automatically makes
a bar chart so now we have a one bar
with the axis of sales for furniture
office supplies and Technology now let's
take profit and also put it on rows so
now we have two bar charts one for sales
and one for profit we can change which
one is a bar and which one is maybe a
bubble chart by clicking on its
appropriate marks card so if we want to
change them both we can click on all and
change them both to maybe circles and
you can see how they go up and down but
if we want to just change one of them
let's put those back to automatic we'll
go to profit and change that one to the
circles so now we can see those profit
numbers and if we want them to be
overlaid on the same area we would right
click on profit the second measure on
the rows and click dual axis so now
let's put them onto the same axis you
can see that their axes are not lined up
let's go to sales and change it back to
a bar
so now we have two charts occupying the
same space one of them is a bar chart
and one of them is a bubble chart and we
can see our sales versus our profit at
least they're not the same amount of
dollars obviously but we can see a
higher sales and a higher profit we also
have medium sales and a medium profit we
have a medium sales but a really low
profit and it's interesting to see that
contrast so let's rename this sheet as
sales
profit
by category
and finally we're going to make our
details sheet so we're going to go down
to subcategory level and bring it onto
rows and remember subcategory can expand
out to the actual products let's bring
that back in and we're going to bring
sales onto columns which makes this a
sales bar chart and profit onto columns
which makes this a profit mark art now
let's color them by their appropriate
individual color so we'll go to the
sales marks card and drag sales onto
color now sales is colored by sales
we'll do the same thing here we did
before we'll go red blue diverging
and make the center zero we actually
don't have to do that for sales because
sales will never be negative but it's
pretty important for profit so we'll go
to the profit marks card and take profit
onto color
and do the same thing there we have red
blue diverging
Advanced Center is zero great so now if
it's negative it will be there so let's
sort this by profit and so both of them
have sorted with profit in mind and we
can easily see our subcategories that
and we'll call it our details sheet so
now we have these four visualizations
that all have to do with similar
information
I think I want these bigger on the
states so I'll just keep making that
bigger perfect now we're going to make
our first dashboard so for our dashboard
we have information over here that shows
you what sheets you can bring on these
get a little bit more complex so they'll
be covered in more in-depth type of
videos and then we have our size so we
could make a range of sizes based on
um maybe what you're viewing this on but
we're just going to change it to a fixed
size and we're going to make it 1400 by
a thousand and this is our dashboard
size so let's bring on sales profit by
region sales and profit by state now a
map needs a little bit more horizontal
space than region does let's bring sales
and profit by category underneath the
region and the detail underneath the
state give our map more space again
perfect now Tableau has this neat
feature called uses filter so you can
click use this filter here and now if I
click on any of these it will filter the
other dashboards based on these features
so if I just want to look at the South
and I click on South it zooms in to all
my South States now my categories have
updated to be just the South ones and my
details have updated as well so we could
see that Central has pretty big sales
you know bigger than the South but the
profit is lower than the South so we can
click on Central and focus on Central
let's use that uses filter on all three
of these dashboards that lead us up to
the detail so building a quick dashboard
like this let's make this taller would
allow you to do some sort of analysis
such as let's take a look at Central
because they have relatively High
profits but low sales so we click on
Central and then we see oh man Texas is
having a really hard time so let's click
on Texas and now we're seeing in Texas
that we have negative profit in these
categories so we can control click on
furniture and office supplies and we can
see all of our products that are really
just killing us in Texas all of our
subcategories and if we want to go
deeper into products we'll just click
that plus sign and now we see all the
products and we'll sort again
and we can see all the products by
subcategory that are really just killing
us
and are maybe not worthwhile to make
anymore so we're gonna have to
reconsider making the 3.6 cubic foot
counter height office refrigerator at
least for Texas it's not very helpful
there and then when you back out of that
subcategory section you can also click
somewhere neutral in the dashboard or
Click on each thing that you had
selected to unselect it and go back to
the main part of your visualization and
start it all over again now let's move
on and take a look on how to create
parameters and sets so new sheet and
let's make a quick visualization that
will apply our parameters and our sets
to
so let's take a look at all of our
customers by their sales and let's sort
customer name descending by sales great
so now we're going to make a parameter
that will allow the user of the
dashboard to choose how many customers
they want to see how many of our top
customers that they want to see
so let's click this down arrow and click
create parameter
and we will name it
top and customers
great we're going to make an integer and
we're going to give them the option to
choose the number of customers within a
range our low is going to be 5 so we'll
let them see five
or up to 20
and we're going to let them skip with
step size of five let's start their
current value right in the middle with
10. okay so now if you want to see how
this parameter looks you can come down
to parameters before we only had
dimensions and measures on the left side
of our Tableau workspace but now we have
parameters that has appeared once we
create a parameter we can right click on
that parameter and click show parameter
control and we can see our top end
customers right now our parameter
control isn't built into any of our
visualizations but you can see how it
works we allowed them to go down to five
and up to 20 with steps of five great
now we're going to create a set a set is
a custom field that defines a subset of
data based on some conditions so the set
we're going to build is going to be
based on customer name so when you right
click on customer name you can come down
and click create hover on Create and
create a set with so far when we created
a parameter and a calculated field you
clicked here
with this down arrow and you saw create
calculated field and create parameter
but it's not there a set has to be based
on an existing field so you come and you
click on the field you want it to be
based on and then hover on Create and
you see set
so here's how we can create a set let's
name it
top and customers
by sales so we're going to allow them to
select the top end customers and have
that select our top customers by sales
so we want this set to include anything
that is in the top however many they
Define by the parameter
Buy sales so you can come over here to
top
and change it to by field we want it to
be top but not just top static 10. we're
going to click here and our parameter
shows up so it's going to be top top end
customers
and then you can choose another field
here for it to be defined by and it's
sales and we want it to be by some of
sales if we wanted it to be by the
average profit we can come here and
click profit and change this to average
and now we would see our top end
customers by average profit but we want
sales and some Okay so we've created our
set and we can drag it onto rows to see
how it works and we can see these are
our top 10 customers by their sales and
we have this in slash out
that's generated by our set so if we
take our set
first let's see how this line moves when
we change our number here so right now
it's 10 when we move it up we see our
line moves down to include the top 15.
and now we can quickly see our top 20.
we'll go back to 10 and let's grab the
set and drag it onto our filters so now
we have filtered the data down to our
top ten if this were applied to a
dashboard this would allow the end user
to see the top 10 quickly and then maybe
expand it out to the top 20 if they're
interested in that information now let's
move on to creating a donut chart so a
donut chart is basically a pie chart
with a white center so let's start by
building a pie chart which in Tableau is
pretty easy especially if you use show
me so let's create a pie chart for each
category
by sales so you're going to click
category and then we're gonna control
click sales so we have them both
selected we'll come over to show me and
click pi and there we have our pie chart
we'll close show me let's come up here
and click entire view so we see our pie
very clearly here if we wanted to have
one Pi for each region we can take
region and drag that onto columns so we
have one column for each region and then
one Pi for each of them you can see that
the pi varies in size based on sales as
well as the angle is for sales so East
has more sales in general than South and
this helps you to see that technology
has smaller sales in the South than it
does in the East so I recommend keeping
if you're going to make pie charts
allowing the size of the pie chart to be
affected as well as the angle by
whatever measure you're using but for
our purposes for donut charts we're
going to want them to all be the same
size so we took sales off of size and
now we have all of our pie charts the
same size now we're going to make what's
called a dual axis chart and to make a
dual axis chart we have to have two axes
so let's grab number of records and
we'll grab it and drag it to rows and we
will change it from sum to minimum and
that's because every record will have a
minimum number of rows of one and then
they all end up on the same axis great
and now we're going to make a second
number of Records by minimum and we can
do that by doing those steps Again by by
dragging number of Records up here and
changing it to minimum again or a quick
trick that I can show you is if you want
to duplicate anything you have on the
chart here you can just hit control and
then click and drag it and it will
duplicate it so if you wanted your
number of Records to also be down here
onto your details or on your labels you
can control click it and then leave it
there great so now we have our two axes
and we have our two marked cards that
each affect their own set of
visualizations so let's go to this top
one affects these so let's show that by
changing the size
and it's made these bigger and this
bottom one affects these and we'll do
that by changing it to Circle so now
each of these are a circle let's take
category off of color and we can take
some of sales off of detail and let's
change the color to white and now we're
going to put this white circle on top of
our pie chart by clicking here on our
second measure and clicking dual axis
and now it's got them lined up one on
top of the other and we have our donut
chart so if we want our donut
slices to be a little thinner we can
change the size of our Inner Circle and
make it bigger
perfect and so now we have one pie chart
for each region one donut chart for each
region and if we wanted to take this
header and put it inside of our pie
chart what we can do is take region and
put it on the label for the circle and
it's putting it down here you can come
and edit that by clicking on label and
changing its alignment so let's put it
in the middle
perfect so now we can see our header
here so we don't need it down here
anymore you can right click and click
show header and it hides that header we
also don't want to see our labels for
our axes so we right click and click
show header there and now we just see
our pies so to get how the number of
sales here for each of them let's go to
remember our PI marks card and let's
take our sales and add it to label so
now each of our slices of pie can tell
you how much sales they have if you take
the sales here that's on label right
click and click format we can change
that to currency and let's get rid of
our decimal places
perfect now close formatting and let's
say we want the total amount of sales to
be in the middle here with Central so we
go back to affecting our Circle grab
sales drag it to label
so now we have four donut charts
formatted to allow us to quickly see the
sales numbers for each segment and also
for the donut as a whole you can also
change the colors that Tableau selects
for each slice by coming to the marks
card that has color for the pie so
category color and clicking edit colors
and you could change it to any of these
automatic ones or if you double click on
one it gives you all of the options for
colors that you could possibly want
there's also several different palettes
you could choose from so let's say we
like this one and you can just click
assign palette and it will grab those
off of there those look very similar to
what we have already so I'm going to
pick a different one
and click assign palette click apply
and this allows you to make some color
changes you can fit your business a
little bit more specifically perfect
let's say we make our pies bigger
increase that size and will also
increase the center size oh not that
much perfect
now we'll use a similar technique to
create the two-dimensional pie chart
a two-dimensional pie chart can be used
so that you can show two pie charts at
the same time or a pie chart that's kind
of split up by different categories this
has been available in some other tools
and Tableau can do it too so let's just
demonstrate that we're going to start
again by creating our generic category
by sales so with control click sales we
come over to show me and click pi and it
makes our pie for us it remembers the
colors that you have determined in other
pages so that's a nice feature again
let's make it entire view so we can see
our pie nice and big and now we're going
to create our dual axis again so we grab
number of Records put it on rows and see
how it adds an axis but each one of
these categories has a different value
for the number of Records however they
have the same minimum
value for number of records and it puts
them all back onto the same spot great
and then we will control click and drag
to make our two axes let's come to our
top one and make it bigger that affected
both of them because we still have sales
on size
for both of them so sales is affecting
the size of the pie chart as well as the
size of the angles so let's take sales
off of size for both of them and make
the second pie chart a little smaller
perfect now let's also affect our second
pie chart by having the color defined by
region instead of defined by sales let's
talk about how I'm replacing it with
region so you could change the color by
dragging region onto color and that
replaces it or let's go back and we can
drag region right on top of the thing
we're trying to replace and it will
replace it there
great so now we have the smaller Circle
that's going to go on top split up by
region with the angle defined by sales
and the categories on the top one with
being able to find by sales let's pick
some nicer colors
maybe we'll use the same palette we used
for category
this one this one seems right but we'll
pick different ones than those three so
we click on the one we want to change
and click on the color we want to change
it to I'm just going to keep following
that's right down
apply great and then we
put it on top of the other one by
clicking dual axes now sometimes it's
easier to see these when they have a
border so we can come to color we click
border and add maybe some black lines
so allow you to see the inner Pi
separate from the outer pie Maybe
our border could have white lines how
does that look
and we can make them both bigger like we
did before
well not that big
and you can also add labels like we did
before
sales onto our labels here
and you can see that hovering allows you
to see all the information you need now
one more thing so while we like to hide
this axis
we'd also like to maybe hide this grid
line that's occurring so you can click
right click and format and let's go to
our lines
that changed that zero line To None
perfect get rid of some of the Clutter
on this visualization I still feel like
this outer pie should be a little bigger
and we want to clean up our tool tip so
it doesn't have Min number of Records in
it this piece should be 100 behind the
scenes so we can come to Tool tip right
as you click on it it'll pop up with
everything that's in your tool tip and
we're just going to erase mid number of
Records I erase too much you need to
leave your angle brackets
okay and now this piece of the pie no
longer has that the inner one let's do
that there too
mid number of Records remove that right
out
and there you have it a two-dimensional
pie chart and here are our donut charts
this demonstration goes to show you that
even when Tableau doesn't have
visualization you're looking for in
their basic show me options you can
still get to it so donut charts aren't
included up here and neither is a
two-dimensional pie chart but without
too much extra work we can make it
happen these visualizations are a little
bit more complex than your everyday
visualizations and so I recommend going
through this tutorial with the data set
and following along if you want access
to the data set just comment below in
the simply learned team will get back to
you also comment below with any
questions you have at this point in the
presentation we're going to put together
some dashboards so first let's build our
worksheets for this dashboard we're
going to build a worksheet called sales
by year which adds the name up here and
we're going to take our order date and
drag it onto columns and now we want
this to be a continuous axis so we're
going to change it to our continuous
year and now we have an axis and we're
going to look at sales
so now we have our sales by year if we
want labels on each of these dots we can
drag sales onto labels and if we want to
have different color lines for each
region for example we can drag region
onto color
and that splits our lines up into the
different regions and gives us a legend
over here perfect now we're going to
duplicate this sheet by right clicking
down here and clicking duplicate now we
have sales by year two let's rename it
to
profit by year and then let's drag
profit right over top of sum of sales
so that it replaces it with profit now
it's been replaced with profit and all
of these different data points are here
however it's still showing the title of
sum of sales and that can be very
confusing so always make sure that your
labels are consistent with your data so
let's take profit and drag it over top
of the type labels as well that's more
consistent with our access
so now we have sales by year and we have
profit by year
do a couple of things to clean these up
like right click here go format and
we'll change our numbers to currency
custom
and now it's marked as dollars one thing
you can do in Tableau is let's undo that
since sales is going to be dollars
pretty much everywhere we use it we can
Define our default property for these
numbers so when we right click on the
measure here you can go to default
properties and you have the options to
change the defaults for any of these
things and we're going to change our
number format
change it to
currency custom
no decimal places hit okay and that also
has updated this sheet now that only
works on places where you haven't
specifically defined it to be formatted
differently so we could still Define it
to be different here on this sheet than
it is on any other sheet let's do the
same thing for profit
change our default properties
to
the same thing great now let's build our
dashboard
we're going to call this our
overall dashboard
change our
size
this size is a personal preference of
mine I think it fits nicely on the
laptops that I use and that is used by
most of our customers and let's drag
sales by year now watch what happens
when I drag it on here it brings sales
by year but it also brings the legend
for the region that was created the same
thing should happen with profit by year
it's detected that the same Legend is
being used so it didn't bring over a
second Legend and we have highlighting
turned on let's see if this works for
both charts we click on Central and you
see it highlights Central in both charts
that's great so now we have a dashboard
showing us profit by year and sales by
year but let's say we want to be able to
filter this dashboard to just maybe one
category so let's go back to our sales
by year sheet
and let's drag category
onto filters
and now it's going to let us select
we're going to select all
and hit OK and then right click on
category and click show filter so now it
is over here and we're going to do a
similar thing on profit by year but
we'll do the shortcut where you come
over here to category you right click on
it and you just click show filter and it
puts it here and it puts it here so now
we have a filter here for category
and a filter here for category
and so when we go to overall
we can come to our drop down here more
options
hover over filters and you can see
category now here's an interesting thing
that we'll see even though we have a
category filter on both charts when I
take furniture out
you can see only sales by year changed
and profit by year stayed the same now
why would that be that's because we have
two different filters for category one
on the sales worksheet and one on the
profit by year worksheet I'll show that
by clicking here going to filters
and grab category now we have category
that will affect
profit by year and not sales by year
that's not what we want we want one
filter to affect them both so let's back
it up a bit
take these back off let's go to profit
by year and we're going to take off
category let's go to sales by year and
we're going to say we want this same
filter to affect both worksheets so
we're going to right click here hover
over apply to worksheets and click
selected worksheets now we select sales
by year is selected and we select profit
by year okay so when we go to the profit
by year sheet you can see that it now
has category on there let's go to
overall let's come here filters category
and now we have a filter
that affects both worksheets
there we go let's format this filter a
little bit we'll come to more options
and we're going to select we want them
to be able to select multiple values
still but let's do it in a drop down
so now you still have those options
but it is a little bit more compact
let's do a couple more filters so we can
do by category let them filter out
regions
let's do it the the shorter way right
click show filter there it is apply to
worksheets selected worksheets
both of these
okay
dashboard
filters and by region
multiple values drop down
and let's let them change their time
selection so this one's a little bit
different since we've already determined
that we wanted year and we wanted it to
be continuous filters for continuous
fields are a little bit different than
filters for these discrete fields and
that's because continuous fields are a
range instead of just a list so we don't
list out a continuous field we make a
range for it so we've already defined
that we want it to be continuous year
and if I come over here and click on
right click order date and click show
filter it's doing discrete year by
default
so remove filter if you drag order date
onto filters
it lets you pick what you want it to
look at let's come up here to year
that's already marked as continuous and
click show filter and now it is year but
it's based on a range and we have this
slider
and you can see how that slider affects
our visualization let me show you a
trick to make this apply to both not a
trick but just if you have not applied
it to both worksheets but you already
added it to the visualization see it's
here but it's only affecting one
worksheet you can change the worksheets
settings right on the filter instead of
having to go to the worksheet where the
filter exists
and it will only give you the options of
the worksheets that are on the dashboard
so there we have it
now it affects both and now we have our
overall dashboard
now let's say you want to be able to see
the total sales on this chart as well as
the sales split up by each of the
regions we can do that as well so let's
go back to our sales sheet as a quick
tip you can go to the sheet by clicking
this go to sheet button here or here in
the event that you want to go to a sheet
but you don't want to scroll back and
forth to find where it is so go to sheet
now we're going to do a dual access
chart again like we showed earlier and
I'm going to control
click and drag
so now we have sum of sales twice
this marks card affects the top one so
we can see that by if I change the
opacity
how it changes the color right here this
is the top one
and this marks card is the bottom one
and we're going to remove region
off of color and that makes our combined
one line again perfect now if we want
this to be on the same space as this we
right click here the second measure in
the row section and click dual axis so
let's put it right on top I can see this
versus this now if we wanted to un hover
show that this is overall sales we can
click on tooltip region is missing
because we don't have it with the color
by region anymore so we'll erase that
and put oh we don't want it to be Orange
Let's Make It Black
overall sales okay so when you hover
here it says overall sales so we can see
the difference easily let's make it
um a little bit more of a color that'll
stand out just a little darker than the
others perhaps
so when we go back to our work or our
dashboard we can see sales and we can
see our overall sales let's do the same
thing for our profit by year go to sheet
and
control
drag release we'll go to our marks card
for this second sheet and pull off
region
make it darker
change our tool tip
not Orange
overall profit
okay and right click
dual axis there we go now I forgot to do
one thing on the last dashboard when you
make a dual access dashboard it doesn't
necessarily sync up these axes and so
this axis over here is for the overall
line and this axis over here is for the
region line
so if we want it to stay that way we
should edit our axes and instead of
calling it just profit over here
we'll change it to overall profit
and over here
profit by region
just so that it's clear which axis goes
to the which one or you can come here
and click synchronize axes so it's very
clear that this is much bigger than
these and if you synchronize the axes
let's go back before we named him okay
synchronize the axis then we don't need
both of these headers so we can come
here and click show header and we just
have the one let's do the same thing on
sales by year
synchronize
always good to make sure that your axes
are either synchronized or well labeled
and let's hide it let's see what it
looks like now
great
okay one thing to keep in mind when we
do filter
to just one region
the lines are going to end up at the
same spot
have we filtered a two
then it's only the sum of those two so
perhaps the header overall sales and
overall profit isn't quite accurate
because it isn't overall necessarily
when we have it filtered
um why does this happen why doesn't this
line always show the total no matter
what you select here well that's because
this filter applies to the whole
dashboard so it filters this line to
those regions just as much as it filters
these lines
okay
so I'm going to remove out that tooltip
line because it could be a little
misleading
let's continue on and make a dashboard
that digs a little bit more into sales
specifically great so we'll make our
first sheet we'll call it
sales by region
and we're going to make another pie
chart so let's do it using show me we'll
click on region and then we will control
click on sales open up show me click Pi
let's close it again great so now we
have the sales by region Pi we'll make
it the entire View and when you hover
you can see that it's showing us sales
in dollar amounts now it would be more
like a pie for it to be percentages so a
lot of Pies each of these slices is
shown as a percentage of the whole at
100 so let's come here to our slice size
we'll right click on it and we're going
to use what's called a quick table
calculation and change it to percent of
total so now when you hover you can see
that the West is 31 of the pi
great let's also label each of these
slices so I'm going to control click and
drag region onto label and add region to
the labels I'm going to undo that and
show you what would happen if I just
dragged region onto labels without
copying it without holding Ctrl it will
move it and get rid of our colors and we
don't want that so we're going to
control and drag another way to do this
let's go back is by taking region and
dragging it onto label just straight
from over here but in this case for the
sum of sales where we've applied the
quick table calculation we want that
quick table calculation to also show up
in our label so I'm going to control and
drag and it brings that quick table
calculation along with it if I were to
undo just drag sales on it's going to go
back to that dollar amount and I'm going
to have to add another quick table
calculation so instead control move and
drag that's probably one of my very
favorite upload Turks great now let's
add a filter for region so I'm going to
right click here and click show filter
and we will make sure that this gets
added to all of our sheets once we've
made them all okay next sheet we're
going to call this sheet sales by state
let's do a map great so um one way to
get your map started is to double click
on any of these Dimensions that have a
globe next to them so with this we want
to go with State we can double click on
State and it starts mapping out state so
what it does is it adds latitude and
longitude to our rows and columns that
are generated here and another way to
get going so let's go back is to click
on the geographic part you want and then
control click on sales like we did for
map sorry for our pie chart come over to
show me and choose one of our Maps we
could do it with the circles but we're
going to do a fill map
click on that so now we have our filled
map based on State
we can choose one of these different
palettes if we'd like let's try this one
or blue teal
or we could do green so that darker
green means more money
great so now we have all of our states
colored by sales let's also control and
drag sales onto label and you can see we
have the dollar sign and the money
formatting that we made earlier and
let's control and drag State onto label
now maybe we want the state to be on top
so we can click on label and it pops up
with all these different options and if
we want to edit the text you can click
here on the ellipses and edit it there
so let's cut state
and paste it
at the top there I think I lost my
Center alignment so we'll do that again
hit apply see what we think great okay
so now you can see that it puts the
state on top you can also see in some of
these places where they're super close
together that you can't see all of the
states labels and that's because
um this option here in labels is
unchecked allow labels to overlap other
marks so Tableau senses when the marks
are too close together and it's going to
become too hard to read and will hide
anything that overlaps with each other
if we click this option now you see
everything but it gets a little crowded
over here so let's unselect that and
you'll be able to see what the sales are
upon hover
right now we have our sales by state for
filters for this one let's no let's
right click on sales here and click show
filter so basically wherever you're
using your metrics your Dimensions or
your measures you can right click on
them
and create your filters
um so now we could add the lowest amount
for a state is nine hundred and twenty
dollars for sales for this time period
and we could filter out ones that have
sales lower than that but I think this
isn't what I want let's remove that
filter let's do it for the state show
filter great so now we could filter out
a state we could just show Arizona
or show them all
excellent let's move on to our next
visualization new sheet rename it to be
called sales by sub category
great so we're going to drag on category
onto columns and subcategories of our
hierarchy press plus now we have sub
category and category and let's bring on
sales it's defaulting to this bar chart
which is perfect that's what I want and
now we could color it by subcategory and
this is a discrete coloring we could
also color it by sales
and this is a continuous coloring so the
darkest corresponds with the height now
we don't need to do this there is
already an indicator of who has the most
sales and that's based on the bar height
so if we wanted to color it by
subcategory then each one of them gets
their own color we could color it by
category to add to the distinction
between the different categories so
that's very clear where they start and
stop let's do
by subcategory excellent so now we have
three different dashboards oh let's add
some filters for our subcategory so
let's bring on category as our filter so
we'll right click here click show filter
and there's category and let's do a
filter for our dates so we're going to
come here to order date let's drag it
onto filters and let's click years
now these are all the years options
we'll click all and hit OK right click
here and click show filter
so now instead of doing a range where we
could drag that line now we have
discrete filter and so we can check and
uncheck boxes to choose what years we
want to see
awesome let's start with our dashboard
let's call this dashboard our sales
dashboard and change our size
if you have any questions about
different sizes what's available here be
sure to ask that in the comments below
and let's start with pulling on our
sales by region so last time we pulled
on a chart we saw that it added the
legend for us
but this time you can see it added both
the Legends and the filter so last time
we created the filters after we built
the dashboard but this time you can see
that the filter
um gets brought in when we brought in
the dashboard let's do our sales by
State Side by Side here and let's do
sales by subcategory underneath so I
dragged it you can see how I pull it
towards the bottom of the dashboard and
it kind of fills in the space where it's
going to be and then brings it in so now
it's brought in all our filters and all
of our Legends it defaults to putting
the filters and legends over here we're
going to click select layout layout
container it's going to select what's
what they're all inside of and we're
gonna make it take up this whole side
but it doesn't need that much space
so you can see in Tableau there's a lot
of dragging there's a lot of dropping
and um a lot of resizing to get things
the way you want them to be give our map
more room
and we have a mixture over here of
Legends and filters let's move our
Legends out of there so we can grab this
Legend and come and put it on this side
and this Legend come put it over here
so that we're getting a little bit more
near the visualizations they belong to
this Legend goes up here with this one
I'm going to actually click here and
change it from a tiled so right here it
says tiled object to a floating object
that lets it sit on top of a
visualization I'm gonna put it on top of
this visualization right up here
excellent and then we have this one
that's showing us the size of sales
that's because on this dashboard it says
that size is determined by sales but
since it's just one Circle there's no
size comparison so it's not like we have
several circles and we have to look and
see which one's the biggest so that we
can tell that the amount of sales so we
don't need this Legend and we can just
remove it from the dashboard let's clean
up some of these we have several
different versions of what your filters
could look like so my personal favorite
is multiple values drop down it gives
you some of the most flexibility but if
you wanted them to only be able to
select a single value you could turn it
into a radio button list so that it's
the selected all or it's one at a time
you could also do a drop down or a
slider and make that happen
a slider is a little bit different from
a range on the Range you can see that we
could edit either side and it's picking
everything in between but with discrete
values if you say everything in between
it doesn't make a lot of sense because
what's everything between furniture and
Technology we don't know that office
supplies goes between those there's no
order so let's do multiple value drop
downs
um for big ones like State there is the
option of searching so I know I want
Utah and I search and there's Utah
instead of having to scroll through the
list this could be really helpful for if
you had a filter for by products and
that would allow somebody to look at
just one product at a time if they know
their name of the product but also not
have to just open up the product list
and scroll and scroll and scroll since
there are very a lot of products so we
can filter by region by doing this oh
this is a great reminder you saw that
this did not change all the
visualizations we have yet to apply
these filters to all the worksheets so
let's do that right now apply to
worksheets selected worksheets and we
will click all on dashboard
okay
we'll do this
again until we have selected them all
great so it's really nice you get to
choose what worksheets you wanted to
apply to because in the event that you
had maybe
um a total number up here at the top
that you just wanted to stay the same
all the time no matter what they
selected you could make that happen by
not selecting that worksheet to be
changed by these filters oh great great
so we can change what region we're
looking at by selecting Central here and
then we're just looking at Central
throughout all the visualizations I love
looking at it on a map and seeing just
one at a time it just really makes the
region name just stand out to you but if
we wanted to use this as our filter to
filter the rest of the dashboards we can
click this uses filter button and now
when we click on Central here it stays
in context here but the other two
dashboards change
one thing you may notice is that Texas
is not the darkest on this chart because
of the scale the scale goes up to half a
million there but then when we click on
Central the scaled updates just for
what's selected so everything else is
filtered out and now the darkest of the
dark is only a hundred and seventy
thousand dollars and Texas becomes the
darkest on the visualization there are
some ways you can change that but if
you're wondering why do my colors look a
little differently when I filter that's
why
great we could also click use this
filter here so if we just wanted to look
at Texas we click this this updates to
just Central this updates to just Texas
down here and unselect
by
clicking on maybe another state or when
you click on the state again it should
unselect and we could do the same thing
here or if we just want to look at one
subcategory and say let me scroll down a
bit storage now everything updates to
the storage it's interesting I wouldn't
have known very quickly that there are
some states that didn't have any storage
sales but now when we click on storage
we can tell I showed you before that you
can control click and look at binders
and storage and it puts those two
together also in Tableau you can drag
and we could select all of these so we
have art binders envelopes Fasteners
labels paper and storage and none of
those are getting sold here
I don't know what's up with Wyoming
excellent so now we have our sales
dashboard and let's get started on our
next one our next dashboard is going to
be the profit version of this dashboard
so some of these visualizations we can
use again so let's go to sales by region
right click and click duplicate
rename it to
profit by region
now you have to be careful whenever you
go to reuse the visualization because
like I mentioned before you got to make
sure everywhere that sales is used you
have to replace it with profit I'm also
going to drag this sheet to be
more at the end here after the sales
dashboard just to keep them separate so
that we have the sheets that lead up to
overall than the sheets that lead up to
sales and then we'll have the sheets
that lead up to profit great so we'll
grab profit and drag it onto angle size
and that updates the angle size drag it
onto the size of the circle shouldn't
make a difference since we only have one
Circle and on to the text now when I
dragged it on it didn't do the percent
of total anymore so let's change that to
the quick table calculation of percent
of total for there and for
the label
percent of total there we go now we have
our percent total Again by region region
okay here's another thing since we
duplicated that filter it's going to be
using that exact same filter
you see it's using region from sales by
region all the sales dashboards but we
don't want that so let's remove out all
the filters here
and these action filters that are
generated by our filtering that those
come from
this
these are called action filters
and it's generated when we click this
uses filter button okay back to profit
by region great we're clear of filters
and let's add back in a region filter
and this one no longer has the icon
that shows you that it affects multiple
sheets which is what we want for now so
you might want perhaps there would be a
situation where you would have two
dashboards and you would want these
filters that you put on here to affect
both dashboards and in this case that's
not what I want great so another one we
can use the basics for is sales by
subcategory so let's duplicate that
great profit by subcategory already
exists we made this earlier Tableau will
not allow you to make a worksheet that
has the same name as another worksheet
you can call it number one or since it
does put the title up here you can put
an extra space at the end or it does
detect that space it counts it as a
different title even though it's the
same title just with a space that does
cause some issues so like when we're
looking here and we're saying oh profit
by subcategory I want that oh this is
when we made it but you don't want this
one you want this one and it gets a
little confusing the nice thing is when
you're dragging things onto your
dashboard when you hover you should get
a little picture here of what dashboard
what visualization you're looking at it
really helps you to make your decisions
and not just have to do it by name if
you're a little bit disorganized and you
have all of these called sheet5 sheet
seven you won't know exactly what that
is right away and so that little preview
is very helpful great profit by
subcategory we'll do the same thing by
removing out all our filters so I just
click on it and hit delete you can also
control click
and then hit delete or you can drag them
off into a space that's not the
visualization space great and we only
have some of sales right there so we'll
change that to profit
and we have some negative profits there
we'll keep the colors the same for
consistency between the two dashboards
and let's bring on category as a filter
okay
shell filter there we are and let's do
our order date filter right now order
date we'll do years okay
all the years so it gives you this
option here because it assumes that
you're making a filter because you want
this dashboard to just be filtered to
your selection you can do that you can
make a filter that isn't exposed to the
end user so let's say you're making a
big dashboard and it was just focused on
furniture then and you don't want them
to be able to select a different
category for because of your analysis
you can make that happen
you could just click furniture and not
show this by clicking hide card here but
in this case we want to be able to make
this Interactive
in a lot of different ways great profit
by subcategory exists now instead of our
map we're going to make an area chart
so I'll rename this and call it profit
over time
by category
so we're going to bring on our order
date into columns and it goes to our
discrete value let's change it to our
continuous value so we get that axis
let's grab our profit onto rows and then
makes us a line chart we're going to
change that to an area chart an area
chart is nice because when you split it
up by category by dragging category out
of color you can now see what category
is responsible for how much profit like
you do with a line chart however its
area is what defines that so you can see
that area over time and do comparisons
and also it Stacks them on top of each
other so that you can tell that for 2013
our profit was around fifty thousand
dollars really quickly otherwise we have
to add that line this line here and it
makes these lines smaller and lower more
difficult to see so back to our profit
over time by category so that's some of
the benefits of having an area chart and
if we wanted to go a little more
detailed then here you can hit this plus
and now we have over quarter we have
some negative profits that's interesting
but let's go back to over the Year great
and for this one we're gonna make one
more pie chart so we could start from
scratch or we could duplicate our profit
by region pie chart which I'm going to
do
we're going to do this for the
comparison between a pie chart and an
area chart so it's going to be profit by
category
but not over time so right now it's
profit by region let's drag category
right on top of colors there
and now it's split up
he's having some trouble because it's
splitting it by category but because of
we brought region on to text it's also
splitting it by region so we have region
region region region inside of this
category and we don't want that so we're
going to drag category right on top of
region here as well and now it's just
the three segments so whatever you have
in this marks card unless it's on tool
tips will affect your level of detail in
the visualization here when it's on tool
tips sometimes it won't change the level
of detail but it could have an effect on
like so if we brought oh let's do this
right now so right now the level of
detail of this chart does not go to the
category by region like it did before
you can bring it onto detail here and it
won't affect color and it won't affect
labels but it will change the detail and
you see how it splits it out again this
is what it would look like if it's by
region by category and you have much
more slices to this pie we'll go back
but if we take region and put it onto
tooltip it's not at a low enough level
for that tool tip to make any sense so
it's going to put that star you see
region is star that's because this
section of the pie covers multiple
regions if we filtered the region to
just Central now it populates
so there are sometimes benefits to
having it in there even when at all
levels it doesn't make any sense but we
won't leave it there
excellent so you can see
how the color is what determines is a
big part of what determines how many
slices you get the level of detail for
the whole chart is a big factor as well
on how many slices you get great profit
by region profit by category by
subcategory and by a profit over time
and we have our category filter we don't
have our subcategory filter yet we
grabbed category but let's right click
on subcategory and click show filter
there we go now we have a filter for
category and subcategory
here's our region one we have region in
two places and we don't want that
we wanted to apply to all of them we'll
do that when we get to the dashboard
and we have category year of order date
and subcategory great those are all the
filters I wanted so let's build our
dashboard
we'll call this our profit dashboard
once I get it set
the size I want
start with profit by region
and we'll have our profit by category
over time next to it great we'll give
that some different space have this at
the bottom have this underneath there
now it's bunched all these up next to it
so it's again drag it over to the side
it's always good to pay attention to the
highlighted section and it gives you
kind of an idea oh you see I
accidentally dragged an individual
filter instead of this whole section so
when I grabbed this I didn't grab all of
these so if you want to grab all these
and they happen to be inside the same
section you can come and click select
the layout container and now I'm
grabbing all of them
there we go
we'll do the same thing as before you
know what I'm going to make these
floating
because then it kind of sits inside of
that same area I'll make that one
floating
and this one too
this category Legend applies to both
this chart and this chart so that's very
nice and this subcategory Legend I won't
make floating I'll just put here by
subcategory
and this profit by category doesn't need
quite that much space
let's give our bar chart some room
excellent we don't need the size of the
circles
make these
drop downs now
um because I didn't have to on this
chart and this chart change profit to
dollars because we set that as the
default it definitely saved us some time
so
I recommend setting default number
formatting
at the beginning of your visualizations
really nice
excellent now you can rearrange the
order of these so I like to have the
date at the top it's sometimes hard to
get it to the top so I take it the
second to the top and I drag the top one
down and then
um category above subcategory just for
logical sense excellent and we have our
profit dashboard let's
there is this check box down here called
show dashboard title so if we wanted to
have the title at the top here you can
click that button any floating objects
don't shift down like everything else
did
there we go
so we could have that title we could not
have that title that's up to you
excellent so at this point we have our
overall dashboard that looks at sales
and profit we have our sales dashboard
and we have our profit dashboard our
profit dashboard isn't 100 Complete
because I forgot to make sure all of
these filters apply to all of these
worksheets so let's go ahead and do that
right now
applied worksheets selected worksheets
all on dashboard
one thing that is nice from this view
it's really nice to click on dashboard
and you only see the ones on the
dashboard but you can click here and say
show all worksheets in workbook and you
can see the rest here so if you want it
all on the dashboard and you wanted this
one or something like that then you have
the option to see them all
great perfect so before you ever publish
a dashboard it's always good to double
check that your filters work
when you filter to just one year this
area chart becomes a lot less useful but
if you're looking at two or more
you start to see the shape of it
great
now we're going to take a look at
linking from our overall dashboard to
our sales dashboard
great so we'll go to our overall
dashboard and we'll be creating what's
called an action so you can make an
action on a worksheet
you can see right here actions or on a
dashboard actions so since we're linking
between two dashboards this is going to
be a dashboard action
sorry just trying to unhighlight there
but if you're ever looking for an action
you made but you can't find it look in
the other one great this is our actions
dialog box here we can see the Highlight
that has been generated when it says
generated next to it that means that you
didn't come in and Define an action it
was made by clicking
this highlight button here that'll
generate an action or when we look on
our sales dashboard we clicked on this
uses filter button so we should have
several actions here that we're all
generated
we have a couple different kinds of
actions when you go to make an action
there's a filter action that we see when
we click uses filter a highlight action
that we can see from here in region and
go to URL action that we haven't used if
you have any questions about go to URL
please post them in the comments below
it basically allows you to be able to
select a URL here and so if you had a
dashboard that had to do with maybe
stocks you could put in a URL here and
then put your stock ticker symbol there
so that you could have a URL that would
then take you to a finance website that
shows you your stock information it can
get pretty cool okay but we want to link
from this dashboard to one of our other
dashboards and you actually do that
using a filter action so we're going to
name that action go to sales dashboard
and we want it to happen when we click
on our sales sheet so you see right here
it shows us the two sheets that are on
this dashboard one we click on the
profits dashboard we don't want this
action to occur this is our go to sales
dashboard now you can have an action
occur on Hover or select you've seen
select happen that's what our filter
uses filter actions use and on menu so
we're going to do it on menu and the
targeted sheets it defaults to this
dashboard saying when I click on this I
want the rest of this dashboard to
update but instead it's going to take us
to our sales dashboard
so when we click on this I want these
sheets to update now we're going to
Define what filters it's going to apply
by default it's going to apply all of
the filters based on what we click so if
we click here it will filter to just
2013 let's say we click here it'll
filter to just 2013 and it will filter
to the region we selected so
let's see what happens when we do that
okay it's just going to default okay now
when I click on this it's going to
filter to 2013 and West go to sales
dashboard this is where it pops up when
you have it on menu
it's taken us to our sales dashboard it
is filtered 2013 and west
just so you know actions will not affect
these filters here you see that it
thinks all of them are selected because
it creates a separate filter there is
such thing as show only relevant values
for these filters so if we click this it
will filter this to only the ones that
are relevant so we can see that it's
only 2013 that this dashboard is
filtered down to but if we click all
values in the database this filter
doesn't have any only one particularly
selected it does have them all selected
right now so we can get here
for that information and to get back
we just need to navigate back to overall
great so it works there
but when we click on this up here go to
sales dashboard
we get a blank dashboard now that
happens because it's trying to pass
region information to that dashboard but
this doesn't have any region detail
on this line it doesn't know what that
is so it's giving it a bad region value
so let's fix this
go to our actions we're going to edit
our go to sales dashboard and we're
going to select What fields
it'll filter on
we will filter on
our order date
year
and let me go back to that we clicked
order date year and it goes to the
Target data source sometimes your target
data source will be a different data
source than the one that you are using
for your Source data source now that
gets a little bit complicated right now
we're just using one data source so
that's not something you need to worry
about in a simple visualization like
this okay and we're going to add one
more
we're going to add region
and it automatically selects region over
here but you could select it yourself
let's see what happens here okay if One
dashboard has region in it and the other
dashboard doesn't have region in it or
doesn't allow you to filter by region
then sometimes you'll get an error here
that will say it's missing out of your
target dashboards
so we don't have any errors so let's see
what happens
so we go to click here
go to sales dashboard what if
we take out region remove region and
we're just doing it based on year
Okay Okay click here go to sales
dashboard and there everything is so now
it will filter into the year that you
selected so this is all 2013 but it will
not filter to the region you selected
so even when we come here and we select
West
it takes you to the dashboard but it
doesn't filter it to West
you have to do that yourself
so now we have links
from sales to sales let's make one for
profit to profit
go to sales dashboard add action
filter
we're going to call this go to profit
dashboard
and we're only going to come from the
profit table to make this happen
let's go to profit and let's select our
fields
we're going to do the same thing where
it's only going to filter it to the year
now you can see oh I started to type in
I didn't show you this before but you
can search text so I started typing in
year and it shows you that under order
date you have all these different
options in this dashboard right now if
you remember we're using the continuous
one that is marked by the little
calendar
so that's it knows it's a calendar date
instead of just trading it like a
discrete field okay
excellent go to profit dashboard and
there we go this visualization like we
said when it's filtered to just one year
isn't quite as useful but one thing you
can do is for West here we can select
both years and I'm going to do it by
control clicking click
click go to profit dashboard
and now we've got 2015 and 2016. so
that's how you do linking between the
two dashboards if you wanted to be able
to include region as well
you could put a note in the tooltip for
this that this doesn't work for region
linking from this area doesn't work or
perhaps you could not have this total
line on the same visualization you could
have a separate visualization that shows
the total or an area chart instead and
that will let you not have this problem
of go to sales dashboard not linking
appropriately so now we're going to
create our final dashboard our segment
dashboard and it's going to use a
parameter in it so we'll get to take a
look at parameters on dashboards
so let's rename this we're going to call
it
profit and sales
by segment
you don't have to name all of your
dashboards a description of what they
are but it makes it really nice and easy
and it automatically puts it up here but
if you wanted to change this you can
just come in here and name this whatever
you like and then it will just show up
up here so
we could call this segment analysis
click apply or OK and there it goes
that means this and this does not have
to be the same if we go forward again
segment analysis and profit and sales by
segment that allows you to have some
more useful names down here that make it
easy when you're looking at them side by
side but have a name to match your
dashboard up here great so we're going
to
make a profit and sales it's going to be
a bars and circles chart and we're going
to bring in our segment that we haven't
looked at yet consumer corporate and
home office and then we're going to look
at it segment and we're going to make a
matrix with category and we get to fill
in this space with our visualizations so
we're going to do sales
and it's going to make these bar charts
so we can see for technology by consumer
by corporate by home office and that is
a matrix of bar charts but we also want
to be able to see profit
and right now it's making two sets of
visualizations but we want just one so
let's dual axis
and it's automatically changed it to
circles also it is not
synchronizing the axis now because
profit is blue and these profit is not
anywhere near the same amount as sales
which makes sense you shouldn't have
profit that's higher than sales so let's
synchronize our axis
and let's change our sales our marks
card over here is associated with sales
and it's nice and easy when the two
marks cards are based on a different
measure to let you know which one you're
affecting and we'll change that to a bar
and now we have a circle on a bar chart
now if we had profit in front of sales
you can see how it's behind and you can
fix that by taking it to the back of
sales another way you can fix it say you
wanted the profit access here over here
for some reason you can right click on
the axis and put Mark type or oh move
marks to front
another way to change it we don't need
both of these so let's not show that
header and we don't need this to be
labeled profit because it's for both of
them so the way you get rid of that is
actually you click edit axis
and then you just erase the title
oh and you don't hit reset you just
erase the title and then you close it
so now no title here but we still have
the axes and we have three sets of bar
charts across excellent the next chart
we're going to build oh so right now
they are it automatically added the
colors based on measure names measure
names is a dimension that is created by
Tableau and it's just what it sounds
like we're coloring it based on the
different measure names one of them's
named profit one of them's name sales
and we know that you can come here click
color and hit edit colors and it will
open this dialog box but you can also
come here and double click on a color
pops open that dialog box let's pick a
palette
let's see
there's a lot of different ones of these
tableau 20. let's pick colors from this
palette
profit can be
so you click here make sure it's
highlighted click the color you want
click here make sure it's highlighted
click the color you want
hit apply
and then you can come to color and make
it a little more opaque
whatever and you make it more opaque you
start to be able to see through your
circles there are benefits but also
drawbacks to doing that
anyway
stick with the Tableau orange blue great
we have our first chart our next chart
is going to be called
top customers Buy sales and this is
where we're going to use our parameter
where we made our top end customers so
let's bring in our set of sales make a
bar chart for that and then we're also
going to we're bringing in our set as we
have our in and our out we're going to
break up our set by our segment as it's
part of our segment analysis and we'll
bring in our customer names
and let's sort it excellent now you can
see that when we sorted it it didn't
take this big guy and put it all the way
at the top it just sorted it each within
its own section great and so here we
have our in and out and that's not a
super user-friendly title for our users
of this dashboard they're like in and
out of top end customers by sales maybe
we want this to say something a little
bit more user friendly so let's make a
calculated field and we're going to call
it the top and customers
label
and we're gonna go and say if and we're
going to use our set top in customers by
sales and since it's an in their outset
it treats this like if it's in top end
customers by sales
then
at the top
we're gonna do a streak so it's going to
be top and then we want to use the
number that's in our parameters so we
have to convert it from a number to a
string and we have to concatenate them
together in Tableau you could use a plus
side top and always make sure you have
space
something that thing that I tend to
forget top space customers so if they
pick 20 it'll say top 20 customers
so if it's in the set then top flank
customers else if it's not in the set we
will just call it other and in Tableau
you always need to end your if statement
with an end here it tells us our
calculation is valid while we're here I
want to show you a little trick there's
this arrow button here
that can give you all of the different
functions that are available within
tableau and it even sorts It Out by
different categories so if we didn't
know how to make this into a string we
could go to type conversion we could
click on string and it gives you an
example also when you click on
a function in here did you see how it's
on date and then I clicked on string and
I'm like what does this do click on it
and it tells me so this makes it really
useful inside of Tableau also in Tableau
you can make a comment in here so if
somebody's like what's going on here you
can press Dash Dash or slash slash and
type in this is a more user-friendly
title hit okay and there we go we have
our more user-friendly title we drag it
here we see our top 20 customers and
other and we don't want to show this
anymore but we still want it in place
you can click right click on it up here
and click show header and it hides it so
that in out is still happening there and
let's drag it to our filters and there
we have it we have our top link
customers and it tells you right there
how many and and we need to come here to
parameter right click and click show
parameter control and that's how we can
control
these changes so let's set it to 10 at
first and we have it our top customers
by sales but it's interesting to know
profit as well so we have really big
sales but how is their profit doing so
let's drive profit onto color and you
can see this person has a negative
amount of profit despite their big sales
so that's important for us to know and
we can change our color like we did
previously to go from red to blue
and we can change our Center to zero and
now we can see the negatives really
quickly
no they're not the only one either I
have a negative profit but some of our
highest sales that's great to know
excellent those are our visualizations
for the segment dashboard so let's talk
about filters really quick we have this
filter we won't show the filter itself
we don't want to allow them to show in
or out we just are going to allow them
to show how many but we do want to be
able to have them filtered by category
so let's show that filter and by segment
show that filter and and then we'll have
our parameter great let's make our
dashboard
um automatic as you probably read right
there the dashboard will resize to fit
any screen that is displayed on that can
be really handy especially if your
visualization is really Dynamic and can
change however some visualizations like
this visualization for example if it
gets too squished you stop being able to
read things very well so automatic has
its definite pros and cons
so we're gonna bring on our profit and
sales by segment and it already pops up
with its Legend and total customers by
sale and it pops up with its Legends and
filters and it pops up with its
parameter now we're going to close that
and be like if you don't see your
parameter when you first bring it in the
parameter is affecting this sheet and
you can go to parameters and find it but
parameters are workbook wide meaning
that it's going to exist over here too
it doesn't affect this sheet however
it's still going to show up there
because it could affect it is available
for any sheet and it's the same there is
no determining what worksheets this
affects this will affect any sheet that
it is on so if I I've changed it to 10
and if I come down here and go back to
the other visualization that uses it
this is why I should name my sheets
let's see if I can find it
nope
here we are sheet13 in sheet 13
we have our top ten so I've got a 10 and
I've got a 10 over there and if I change
it to 20 and I go back to my segment
dashboard it is also changed to 20. so
it will affect all sheets always very
important to know great so here's our
visualization here are some of the more
useful Legends so let's make this
floating and put it over by the
visualization it matters for we can do
the same thing here floating right up
here floating does not work very well
for if you were to make this an
automatic dashboard so that the size
changes all the time because floating
could end up right on top of your
visualization and keep you from being
able to see what you need to see
and let's make these effects all the
dashboards in the workbook
again we don't have to do this for our
parameter it will already affect all the
dashboards in the whole workbook
and
format these
another thing you should know is that
there are more formatting options for
these
including edit title so it's already
named it category automatically but if
you had
like here oh this is a great example
edit title top end customers and you
could change it to
select number of top customers
or something like that give it a little
more space
and yeah these floating ones do not
shift when you shift things so it's
always good to double check your
floating Legends
and this is a little bit more user
friendly
than the title we made for the
Developers
and that's using parameters in a
dashboard
today in this video we learned about an
overview of business intelligence on
Tableau we talked about how to install
Tableau public and how to connect to a
data source we also talked about
creating calculated Fields like this one
we talked about making sets and
parameters we learned how to make a
donut chart
and a 2d donut chart we learned about
making dashboards
and adding filters to those dashboards
and we also learned about connecting
between Dash boards welcome to Tableau
training part two we will be learning
about the topics we discussed in part
one live versus extract data sources
we'll talk about joins and unions and
we'll look at table calculations we'll
look at the rank functions and we'll
look at actions specifically URL actions
we'll talk about reference lines and
bands we'll look into some insights in
the data such as delay analysis also
we'll learn how to build a waterfall
chart and then finally we will learn
about level of detail calculations while
making two different visualizations in
part one of this Tableau training we
introduced Tableau Basics and we learned
how to create
donut charts and two-dimensional donut
charts and we learned about linking
between dashboards now let's discuss the
difference between a live connection and
an extract connection first it's
important to note that these different
types of connections are not available
in Tableau public it's always a live
connection and a live connection is
where the data will update based on when
the source of the data updates so if any
if you're connected to a database and
something in the database changes then
you'll pick up those changes when you
open the report as it will query that
database when the report is opened
whereas an extract connection is
extracted into creates a subset of the
data that improves performance so when
you're looking at it locally on your
computer you have an extract of that
data set that subset of the data right
on your computer or up in Tableau server
depending on where you're looking at it
and it does not update when the database
updates it only updates when they're
refresh updates it so without a refresh
set for that extract you won't get the
new data as an example of this let's say
that in our sample superstore we have
Kelly Williams associated with the
central region but that's changed so
let's go ahead and change that
we will change it to
Sarah Smith and
we'll save it now let's go back to our
Tableau workbooks
and you can see we can refresh it over
here and see Sarah Smith come in over
here in our extract it Sarah Smith
doesn't come in if we click to refresh
the extract it doesn't refresh the
extract until we navigate to sheet1
but when we go back to our data source
then we see Sarah Smith coming in so
that refresh can be scheduled and it
could run once a day or once every
several hours
but you would need to set up a refresh
or else you would never get Sarah
Smith's data coming in next let's talk
about joining data in Tableau so here we
have the people table but let's say we
want to join it to our orders
information so I'm going to start with
our orders table and then we're going to
pull on people and Tableau is going to
create a join for us and it's going to
choose the column that we would like to
join on based on the names in the two
data sources so if these two data
sources didn't have a column that had
the same name then Tableau wouldn't be
able to guess what to to join on
so we would have to come in and select
out of the order side and the people
side what we'd like to join on and then
we have the options to do an inner join
a left join a right join and a full
outer join let's review quickly what
these look like so say we had two tables
that we wanted to join together one of
them was the student table that had the
student names and the key to their grade
and which we could use to look up their
grade over here in the grade table which
had the key to their grade and the
actual grade ABCD F and incomplete we
can see here that somebody has made a
mistake and put in a letter grade
instead of the key to the letter grade
and we'll see how that affects what
we're looking at so if we were to do an
inner join
that would only take the rows where the
join could complete so we have one that
could join to one just fine but we don't
have two and we don't have three a
doesn't join to anything so this row
would be not included and then four five
and six would all join so that would
look something like this where we would
see Adam when we grab student from this
table and grade from this table we can
see Adam had an a that really had an a
Dale had a d Elizabeth had an f and
Frank is incomplete and Charles is
missing also you don't see any B or C in
this list of grades for a left join it's
going to take everything
from the left table and only the pieces
from the right table that apply to the
left table so it looks pretty similar to
our inner join only Charles shows up so
the join wasn't able to complete since a
doesn't exist in grade but we include
Charles anyways and grade becomes null
for Charles it won't put in the grade
key because it's we're not asking for
the grade key we're asking for grade
from the grade table so we try to look
up a inside of the grade table we can't
find it and then returns null we look up
a inside the grade key Perfect Right
join is like a left join only it takes
everything from the right table instead
of the left table so it grabs all the
grades a b c d f and incomplete and only
the rows from the left table that join
appropriately so since Charles isn't
joined appropriately he doesn't show up
we also have B MC showing up even though
it doesn't exist in the student table
and it won't be tied to a student
because that join wasn't able to
complete as it didn't exist over there
and the last one is a full outer join
where it takes everything from both
tables whether or not the join is
complete so we have all of the people
where the join completes we also have
Charles where the join doesn't complete
from the left to the right and we have B
and C where the join doesn't complete
from the right to the left so those are
our options in tableau
here
in our sample Superstore data set
you could look and see if there are any
regions in the orders table that don't
exist in the people table and that's how
you can know what kind of join you want
and so if you want those orders to still
show up even though they don't have a
region
or their region is not in the people
table that's when you would do a left
join
for our purposes we'll do an inner join
now let's say we had a second Excel
sheet here that had more orders and you
can do a union which is just adding more
orders by dragging that second order's
table right underneath the original
orders table you can see it says their
drag table to Union and that's helpful
for if you have an Excel sheet for maybe
different years so say you had a
separate Excel sheet for the orders in
2015 and then another one for the orders
in 2016 you could pull on your 2015
orders and then drag your 2016 orders
right there to Union and it would take
these orders and then add the rows
instead of the columns for the 2016
orders
for example we've added people but as a
join and that will first put in all of
our orders
as columns and then add the columns for
our person
but if we were adding more data that
fell under the order columns so it would
have the same data the same order ID
ship date but we wanted to add more rows
than that would be when you Union
now we're going to take a look at
calculations and which ones are
calculated on the database side versus
which are calculated on the table side
so here we have percentage of total
sales split up by subcategory and
category we also have percentage of
total sales a long table down so the
difference between these two things are
one of them is made using
a calculated field
which is where we do the sum of sales
divided by the sum of fixed sum of sales
this part is called a level of detail
calculation
and this calculation the sum of sales
and the sum of the level of detail of
sales which basically makes the database
find the total sum of sales regardless
of these Dimensions we pulled on so it
gives us our total number so this will
be sum of sales for bookcases and this
will be sum of sales for everything this
calculation is done on the database side
whereas this one percentage of total
sales along table down is what's called
a table calculation
it's a quick table calculation of
percent of total and it is done in
Tableau it's processed locally right
inside of the table after the
aggregations have occurred there are
some pros and cons of doing it this way
so for this percent of total sales
I had to create the table calculation
here and it does the fixed sum of sales
where it finds the sum of sales for the
entire database and since it is fixed it
will ignore filters so for example I
took off both of the sales and I'm just
going to put on the percent sum of sales
and let's say we wanted to see how
office supplies and Technology are as
percentages of sum of sales and ignore
Furniture so we can grab category and
we'll control click and drag
and we're going to unselect furniture
and hit OK
now it's still
taking it out of the total sum of sales
including furniture and so our grand
total down here is only 67 instead of
100 percent
whereas if we take sales
and double click it and it adds it over
here on the table then we right click
and do a quick table calculation and
click
percent of total
this one is doing it out of 100 and
these numbers don't match and that's
because it does take into account the
filter of category so let's pull the
filter category off and we can see that
they're both out of a hundred percent
now and each of these take into account
um the same amount of data since we have
no filters here
so if you wanted to take into account
the filters on the table then you need
to use a table calculation however when
you push the information back to the
database to do the calculation it's
doing it as part of the query to the
data source and it can save you some
time and so which one of these is faster
sort of depends on what data is
available already when the original
query comes back
next we're going to discuss ranking in
Tableau first let's add a second data
source so we can do that by coming up to
data and clicking new data source or you
can just click this Plus data source
right here and click Microsoft Excel
we're going to use this rank example
worksheet
perfect and it's already pulled in the
sheet we want because there's only one
sheet
and we'll go to sheet2
pull on store pull on sales and we will
rename sheet2
as
rank example
great so now we have here's all of our
stores and here are our sales and if we
wanted to rank them based on who had the
highest sales to the lowest sales we
could create a calculated field
ranked by sales
and we're going to use our rank function
and we're going to put it in sales now
we receive this error here so when we
hover we see what that Arrow says oh you
can click and it says all Fields must be
aggregate or constant when using table
calculation functions or fields from
multiple data sources so we learn
something unique here
that you might not know is that a rank
is a table calculation
and it requires it to be aggregated so
we can make some
and put the parentheses around sales
and our error goes away so now we know
rank is a table calculation
and we have our box here that expands
out and can teach us about what we're
using here so when I click on rank it
will tell us that it Returns the
standard competition rank for the
current row and it says identical values
are assigned an identical rank so let's
see what that looks like we'll hit okay
we'll double click on Rank by sales and
we can see our ranks so e had the
highest sales so it's one D is next and
c and b are tied 20 and 20.
and so they both share the rank of three
and then because they are two of them
that share the same rank we skip four
and the next one gets fifth place but
now this isn't the only way to rank
so let's make another one of these we'll
click duplicate
and edit let's erase copy
and we're going to call this rank dense
by sales double click on rank start
typing rank again and we're going to
click rank dense
now the difference here is that rank
dense Returns the rank where identical
values are assigned an identical rank
but no gaps are inserted in the numbers
so click OK double click rank dense and
you can see instead of going one two
three five it goes one two three four so
it doesn't include that Gap now let's
give them a little bit more space here
and maybe I want it to be in the order I
created it so these measure values are
defining what's going to happen up here
so we can take sales and put it at the
top
and that'll move sales to the front and
put rank dense at the bottom so now we
can see sales we can see Rank by sales
we rank dense by sales
now let's duplicate
and look at the next one
we have rank
modified
next
and
change the name here you notice that I
receive an error
and that's because that name already
exists this Tableau won't allow you to
use the same name
and it will give you that error so those
errors can be pretty helpful in finding
out what's going on hit apply and okay
and then double click rank Modified by
sales
and now we can see
the difference here
let's go back here and
look at what it says here click on
remodified and it says it Returns the
modified competition rank where
identical values are assigned an
identical rank
but
what happens instead
is instead of both receiving three
for third place they both receive four
which is the lower of the options so if
we were going by Rank and we just
arbitrarily decided that this one's
third place and this one's fourth place
then they both receive the same rank
here but they received the higher of the
two options whereas this one receives
the lower of the two options
and let's do one more
duplicate
edit
erase copy
and we're going to do
rank
unique
and let's change the name
to rank uni
perfect and now this is going to give it
a unique
ranking even when they share the same
number so we'll hit apply
okay double click rank unique
and we have one two three four and five
so what it's doing is let's quickly look
here so Rank by sales
we haven't talked about this yet but you
can choose to rank it ascending or
descending that means that do we want to
rank it based on
whether you see here it says ascending
or descending and that's how you'll
Define so right it defaults to
descending and it's saying the biggest
is the best
so in for sales that's accurate so what
it's doing is biggest down now here it
has to decide which one to give three
and which one to do four and it's doing
that based on the ASCII values of the
store
so it's looking at more information on
the row and since uppercase B comes
before lowercase C uppercase B is
getting the three
even though they both have 20 for sales
let's go back now to our orders data and
we'll make a new sheet and now we're
going to talk about actions in Tableau
we've talked about actions briefly
before in our Tableau training video for
beginner so if you want to see the
introduction you can go and look there
also if you want to follow along with
our data sets you can comment below and
ask in the simply learn team will get
you that data set
so let's make a chart where we're going
to look at category so we'll drag
category onto columns and then we're
going to look at sales so we'll drag
sales onto rows and it will create three
bar charts for us
and we're going to
call this
sales by category
now let's make a second chart that we
will use together and we'll bring
category onto columns and we'll bring
subcategory onto columns
and let's bring sales
on two rows again
and let's take
subcategory and bring it on to color and
that makes each subcategory its own
color and we'll call this sheet
sales by subcategory
so now back to sales by category here
you can make a worksheet action
where we're going to move from the sales
by category sheet to the sales by
subcategory sheet and also filter down
that sheet to only the category we want
to see so click filter
and we can name this filter
go to subcategory
and we're going to do this filter on
select so this name won't be seen except
for in our actions list and which sheets
do we want to affect we're going to have
sales by category show up one thing to
note here it is only showing the sheets
for it to affect based on the ones that
are using this data source at this point
so you can see we have four sheets down
here but it's only showing three sheets
and that's because rank example if you
recall is using the rank example data
source so you can click here and you can
see all the sheets or you can see the
other data source if we click rank
example it will show the rank example
data source so we just want sales by
category to be the source sheet and the
target sheet we want it to be sales by
subcategory
so on select we wanted to be sales by
subcategory we're going to use all the
fields available to create this filter
and hit OK so now we have our go to
subcategory on select we'll hit OK again
and let's make this a little wider so we
can see and so when we click on
furniture it will take us to Only
Furniture of
the sales by subcategory we go back to
category we click on office supplies now
we just see office supplies and this is
a way to make Tableau drill to a lower
level
foreign
so we have those
now let's
duplicate this sales by category sheet
and let's see if we go to worksheet and
we go to
actions you can see that we have the
action here
go to subcategory that still exists on
our duplicated sheet as well so you can
see it's affecting both sheets sales by
category and sales by category two let's
say we don't want that and we can
unselect sales by category two
and hit OK and hit ok now when we go to
worksheet actions
now you can tell that it's not affecting
that sheet so if we come and click
technology nothing should happen but we
go to sales by category and click
technology it'll take you to the
technology subcategory great so we have
our sales by category two let's bring it
to the end
rename it
we're going to call it sales by category
stacked
because we're going to take subcategory
here and drag it onto color
and now we can see our different
subcategories in the colors there
now we can take a look here
and sort by subcategory based on some of
sales
and now you can see that
it is the biggest sales at the bottom
for each subcategory that's just a way
that I like to view it so let's do a
highlight action and we're going to do
it on a dashboard
so let's take
sales by
subcategory and look at it over top of
our sales by category stacked over top
of sales by sap category so we want both
of those let's make our dashboard
automatic for
testing purposes and we'll go to
dashboard we'll click create actions so
we're going to add an action it's going
to be a highlight action
highlight sales by
subcategory
and we are going to have the sales by
category stacked be the source sheet and
the sales by subcategory be the target
sheet for all Fields okay okay and on
select you can highlight
your chart there
and see where it falls inside of the
other visualization
a cool thing you can do is you could
select office supplies here and it will
highlight all of office supplies or if
you drag and select a couple of them it
will show you those so you're just like
I want to see all these small ones or I
want to see this one and these small
ones or whatever then it will highlight
the ones that you drag and select now
this is also true of our sales by
subcategory and sales by category so
when we clicked on technology it
filtered to just technology
and we'll undo that and when we drag and
click office supplies and Technology we
get office supplies and Technology now
if we go back to the dashboard we can
see that this dashboard is now filtered
also to office supplies and technology
and that's because we're using the same
sheet and when you navigate away from
that sheet it doesn't mean that your
filter goes away
so when I click undo that's when it
caused the filter to go away so if
you're going to have two things affect
that sheet just remember that just
because you navigated away from what you
selected doesn't mean that what you
selected goes away that filter will stay
there and it shows up right here
and if we pull it off everything goes
back to normal however the action is
still there so when you click on it it
comes back
now let's take a look at the last kind
of action which is a URL action
so we're going to make a map based on
state so I'm going to double click State
and it's going to build out my map let's
change it to a filled map
by clicking map up here
and we're going to take sales and put it
onto color
so now it's colored based on the darkest
is the highest sales
we're going to put State on to label so
you can see the state name and we're
going to put sales onto label so we can
see the sales amount let's quickly
change our default property for sales
so that it always shows up as currency
and we're gonna lose the decimal places
so it'll by default show up with a
dollar sign and
so on great so now we have our sales map
and we're going to create
a worksheet action now the difference
between a worksheet action and a
dashboard action is that a worksheet
will only affect the worksheet and
dashboard will only affect the dashboard
and so when we created our worksheet
action on sales by category if we were
to pull sales by category onto the
dashboard that action won't transfer
over you'll need to make a dashboard
action
so we're gonna make a go to URL action
we're going to have it on menu
we're going to call it Wiki
and it's going to only affect our new
sheet sheet6 which we should rename and
we're going to have a URL in here so
this will take us to Wikipedia and then
whatever you put at the end of the
Wikipedia link it will take you to that
page on Wikipedia so we're going to take
State and add it to the end of that link
and now to test the link you can just
click test link
and it will take a random value and show
you what it will look like
so now that's how we know that we have
our link set up Okay click OK let's
rename our sheet to
URL
filter by state and so when we click on
Texas okay back to URL filter by state
let's go to our worksheets
and what are our actions and on the go
to subcategory
it is also affecting this URL filter by
state because we didn't unselect it now
to keep that from being a problem we're
going to just come here in sales by
category be the only sheet and that way
it will Auto Select new sheets as you
create them
so we'll no longer have that problem you
click on Texas and nothing happens
except for it highlights that one only
that's how it should be but when we
hover on Texas and wait long enough oh
yeah on click sometimes you just have to
hold still it'll come up with our little
link here and we click on Wiki and it
will open up our browser with the
Wikipedia page for Texas this can become
really handy in the event that you have
data that maybe has an order ID and you
can take that order ID and insert it
into a URL in your system so that it can
take you to your web interface page for
that order
here it's helpful for if we wanted to
learn more about the state of California
which it can have information about the
languages spoken
and population
which can be helpful when we're looking
into our sales information
another way this can be useful is by
showing the web page right inside of
Tableau so let's make a dashboard
change our size to automatic and let's
pull in url filtered by state
if we go to dashboard actions you can
see there are no actions for this
dashboard yet so we're going to add a go
to URL action on select
and since it's on select the name of
this URL won't
show up
but it will show up in our list here so
it's nice to name it something unique
let's put in our Wikipedia page and
it'll take us to state so we'll hit okay
okay and now when we click on Oklahoma
it'll open up a page for Oklahoma
but let's unselect Oklahoma if we drag
on web page from the objects here
you don't even have to enter anything
for your url you just hit OK and now we
have the bottom half of the screen is a
web page and when we click on Oklahoma
instead of taking us to Oklahoma in a
separate thing it'll take us to Oklahoma
right here
in the visualization so we'll change it
to Texas and this will change to Texas
if you unselect it leaves the page there
based on the one that you had just
selected
next we're going to take a look at
reference bands and lines so let's make
a new sheet
and we're going to call it
reference
line
and so a reference line is found on the
analytics Pane and it is something that
comes and draws
a line on your visualization based on
the data on the screen so let's make our
visualization we'll do our category and
subcategory again
and we'll double click on sales
and it brings it on to text that's not
what I want so let's do sales onto rows
and we have our bar charts
and
we'll talk about the difference between
a cell a pain and the table so when we
go to Analytics
and we go to drag our reference line
onto our visualization it says you can
add the reference line for the whole
table for a pane or for a cell so
if we
take our subcategory and drag it onto
color
since the subcategory is our lowest
level it's going to Define our cell so
each one of these if we drag our
reference line onto cell each one of
them gets a reference line you see how
it added those on this is our dialog box
we will look at that in just a moment so
let's remove that if we take reference
line and put it onto pane
that's going to be similar to having
category on a color so each of these
different colors is now a pain
reference line onto Pane and you see how
we get reference lines
based on each pane
so let's undo that
and now if we take category off and
everything is all one color and we take
reference line and put it on to table
now we have our reference line for the
whole table
great so we're going to do find out the
average for each section so I'm going to
take category and put it back onto color
and we'll take reference line and put it
onto pane now we have our reference line
it's based on the computation of average
and it's using the value of sum of sales
so since it says sum of sales here you
might think that it was taking the cut
reference line and putting it at the sum
of the sales but that's not what's
happening it's just using our aggregated
version of sales to figure out the
average so instead of taking each
individual sale that makes up the
bookcase section it's taking the sum of
sales for the bookcase section and
comparing it to the sum of sales for
chairs
so it's taking an average across these
added up sections
you could also have it be total where
it's adding all of these up and it makes
that total line
the stem line is the same as total in
this case a constant which is where you
get to define the value and so if we
wanted it to be 200
there it is
let's go back
there we are back to where we were
constant minimum which shows you the
minimum for each section
the maximum for each section
or the average or the median so let's
stick with average and now you can see
it's labeling the line as average we
could also have it label the line as the
value so now we can see that the average
is this amount of dollars
or you can choose custom and then you
can put something in here
like maybe we wanted the computation a
colon and then the value average
this amount
you can also have a show recalculated
line for highlighted or selected data
points that means when you click on the
section it will recalculate the average
just for what you've selected we'll hit
OK and so in that case when we click on
tables you can see our recalculated
average line
so the average for tables for just
tables is the sum divided by the number
so the sum of tables is 206 966 divided
by one is still 206 966. so selecting
just tables isn't really helpful but if
we wanted to know the average of tables
and we'll control click appliances and
we'll control click binders oh there we
go all three of those are selected we
can see the average of those three which
is this line
you could also select like this
and see your new average
oh and it's doing the average
independently so
like these guys and now we see the
average of just those five categories
and those are reference lines now let's
duplicate this sheet
and I'll show you how to delete a
reference line
so we'll rename this to reference
dance
click on this reference line
right click and click remove and it
takes it off we have the same thing for
reference bands we had with reference
lines where you can have it be for the
whole table per pane or per cell so
let's do a reference band for the whole
table so it's doing entire table and
it's taking from the minimum to the
maximum now we could change the minimum
to be the average to the maximum and now
that will highlight the whole table
everything that's above the average
becomes highlighted
and if you wanted to change it you could
do the minimum to the average
but let's go to average to
maximum and then you can change things
like you could add lines so we have a
line for the average or the maximum you
can make it thinner you can make it
dotted
you can change your fill so maybe if you
don't want it to be quite that dark you
can change it to be a little bit of a
lighter color of gray and you can have
show recalculated band for highlighted
or you can remove that and that way when
we highlight stuff everything just stays
where it belongs for the entire table
and that's how you create a reference
band
reference bands and reference lines can
be really handy in making several
different kinds of visualizations such
as bullet charts
if you have any questions about that
please comment below and the simply
learned team will get back to you now
let's do another analysis on average
days to ship
and for this one we're going to look at
it by state
and we're going to look at it by ship
mode
and so we'll take average days of ship
and put it on columns
and now we can see the average days to
ship by first class same day second
class or standard class
and you can see
how they differ so let's change the
order of these really quick if we come
up here to ship mode and we click sort
we click manual we can have same day
above first class so that it kind of
goes in order of priority so same day
first class second class standard class
there we go and now we have it in
order of what you might expect and
priority and now we're going to create a
calculated field that we will use to do
a sort of conditional formatting
and we will name it delay analysis
great so let's do if the average days to
ship is less than or equal to two
then we'll have it return the words
shipment early
so
if we want to press enter there that
won't cause any problems to our
calculation so you can press enter or
you could have extra spaces and it won't
a tableau will ignore those so this
allows us to format our calculated field
in a way that's easy to read so if it's
less than two then they're going to call
it an early shipment
else if
average days to ship is greater than or
equal to 5
then shipment
late
and else if let's get the rest of them
and average days to ship is not less
than two
greater than two
and less than five
then on time
two words one time
and now you can see we have an error
here
it says expected end to match if and
that means that we don't have an end
at the end of our if statement if
statements always have to have an end
okay let's hit apply
and let's grab our delay analysis and
put it onto color
and it has on time as blue
early shipment as orange and shipment
late as red
we can double click on the color and we
can change shipment early to Green
and now we can see the best ones the
on-time ones and the ones that stand out
as late
and standard class happens late a lot
it's interesting to see that on average
the District of Columbia
has second class as a late shipment
you can see that all of these
share the same access size so they all
go from zero to six
even though this one never gets that
close to Six
if we click edit axis you can choose if
you want that to be the case so it's
like right now all of them use uniform
access range for all rows or columns and
that's really nice because it's easy to
compare Colorado to Colorado to Colorado
if you change it to Independent access
for each rows you can see now this one
only goes from zero to not even one
whereas this one goes from zero to six
and you can compare it with color but
you can no longer compare it with size
across all of these different categories
so uniform access range is the default
in this case
and we will keep it that way
so now we have a quick analysis of our
delays
we're now going to build a waterfall
chart based on profit
so we'll call this our profit
waterfall
and we'll take a look at what a
waterfall looks like at the end and talk
about how it works so after we build it
we'll talk about some of the benefits of
having a waterfall chart so what we're
going to do is build it over time for
this visualization we're just going to
look at the year of 2014 so I'm going to
filter it to the order dates for 2014.
and then we're going to take our order
date and bring it onto columns and we're
going to look at it by month but we're
going to look at it by
our discrete month so you can see that I
chose the one that has month and year
and then when I chose discrete
and then we're going to take profit and
put it onto rows and we're going to
change it from profit to our running
total of profit
so you can see that it takes January and
then it adds February to it
and so it's always getting bigger when
we undid it sometimes there's up and
down
so
back to where we have our running total
where it will some January and February
for the February Mark and then some
January February March for the March
mark
if I take profit
and put it here you can see January is
negative 3000 and February is positive
two thousand but here it's the sum of
those which is negative 467.
take that back off we're going to change
our marks to a Gant bar
and now we're going to
duplicate profit
and edit what we have we're going to
call this negative profit
and it's going to be just profit with
the negative side in front
oh it looks like I've done this before
so now we have a new name because I
added a space at the end so hit apply
and let's um delete the old one
okay so now we have our negative Profit
just to look at it it's just minus
profit and we're going to use that to
determine the size
of the Gant bar so what it does is it
takes where the line was and it adds the
size of it to be the size of profit but
because the line was at the top and we
didn't want to build the profit up we
had to change it to negative profit so
it would build it down
so here the line was down here because
it was so low negative and we added
negative profit and then let's take
profit and put it on color
and so you can see where profit is
negative it turns to Orange
and my profit is positive it turns it
blue so what's happening here what we
can do now is we can see our total sales
at the end and how we got there so for
the first month we were at zero when we
started and we went down to negative
three thousand the next month we were at
negative three thousand when we started
and it grew up to be almost back to zero
and then we can see that from there on
out we grew up
each month and you can see how much each
month contributed
our biggest contributors are November
and March November being a little bit
bigger and you can see where we started
at the beginning of that month and where
we ended and that's how a waterfall
chart works so it lets you go through
over time and see exactly where our
problems were and exactly which months
helped the most where we started and
where we ended for each month
next we're going to talk about level of
detail calculation and we'll talk about
those first by showing an example so I'm
going to bring all my customers on
by name and then I'm going to bring on
order ID
and it's going to add all members but
then I'm going to change order ID from a
dimension to a measure and we have a
count distinct so now we can see each
customer and how many orders they have
so let's sort it and we can see one
person has 17 orders and we have one two
three four five six seven
people have 13 orders
and it goes on from there
so what if we wanted to make a
visualization that would show how many
customers had how many orders and what
number of orders was the most popular
we would need to do a level of detail
calculation so let's clear the workbook
a level of detail calculation allows you
to build a visualization and bring on
metrics that are at a level that is
different from what's shown on the
visualization so
in order to do this we need to
create a calculated field
that will show us the number of orders
per customer
even though we're not going to have our
visualization be per customer so let's
call this orders
per customer
and we'll come here and we're going to
use a level of detail calculation called
fixed
now there are two other level of detail
calculations
and they are called include
and exclude
and you can learn more about those
in some of our simply learned classes
and if you have any questions please
comment below and we can answer them so
we're going to do it fixed and you can
choose
dimensions and they could compute that
aggregation using only the specified
Dimensions so it'll ignore all the other
dimensions and we're going to have it
based on customer name
so we're going to have fixed customer
name
and we're going to call
get account distinct
of order ID
and make sure you close it with your
curly bracket and we have no errors I
will hit okay
and this allows us to see number of
orders per customer so let's pull it out
first let's make it a dimension
and then pull it out onto our columns
and now we can see one two three four
five six seven eight up to 17. so that
means we had
some customers just order one and some
quote customers order 17 and we had them
order everything in between so if we
never had a customer that had nine
orders
then nine wouldn't appear in this list
now we're going to take customer ID or
name
let's do ID because it should be unique
and we'll pull it onto rows and we're
going to change it to a measure and it's
going to be account distinct and so now
we can see
how many customers ordered how many
items
so we have our number of orders per
customer which is at the per customer
level even though this visualization is
not at the per customer level
there's nowhere in this visualization
where we pull on the customer
item as a dimension
so let's sort it biggest to smallest
and we can see that 134 of our customers
ordered five items or had five orders
and so it just five is the most popular
seven is the next most popular 17 is the
least popular one is relatively
unpopular which is interesting to know
and so you can use this to analyze how
many items your customers generally
order and maybe if they have four items
that they are going to order that
perhaps if you made good suggestions you
could get them to go up to five
and that's an introduction to level of
detail
so let's name this sheet
level of detail LOD
ders per customer
perfect now let's make a new sheet
and we are going to do an analysis about
new customers
so we'll call this level of detail new
customer
analysis
so this visualization is going to be
about customer acquisition over time so
when we do things over time we grab our
date and pull it up here and for a line
chart or anything over time we're going
to use these
so that it makes an axis instead of just
change to line instead of Dimensions or
something that is not continuous and
then we're going to take our customer ID
pull it onto rows but let's change it to
kind of distinct customer ID and now we
can see our count of customers on every
day I think day is too low of a level
let's go ahead month
so now we can see how many customers
made an order during one month
let's take region
and split it out by region
I'm going to click on Central we can see
Central now this is including all
customers but say we only wanted to
include a customer when they're making
their very first order
so we're only going to include their
first order so we need to create a
calculated field
and we want to compare
we'll call it new or existing
and we want to compare their order date
per customer
to their first order date the Min order
date
nope order date
and we're going to get this error it
says cannot mix aggregate which is min
and non-aggregate functions and what
it's saying here is that
this order date is at a per Road level
since we don't have any aggregation on
it and this order date is at a per
visualization level so it's only going
to split up based on the visualization
and I won't let you put those two things
together so we're going to
use our level of detail calculation
again and we're going to make this fixed
per customer ID
and then we'll do our min
order date
so now instead of trying to return
something different based on the
visualization it will always return the
Min for each customer ID so if the order
date on the visualization is equal to
this order date
yeah the order date on the visualization
is equal to the first order date for
that customer
then
new
else
existing
end
so
when the order date equals the very
first order date that means that the new
customer making their first order
otherwise it's an existing customer
because it's no longer their earliest
date apply okay and now we can take our
new field
which is new or existing drag it onto
filters and we only want new we'll hit
apply
and we can see that we have new
customers but less over time
so
so now we're going to change this count
distinct
to be a running total and we can see
over time how our new customers are
adding up so it's taking the prior value
and adding our new customers and then at
the end we get our total customers for
each
region and we can now make this a more
the lowest level which is day and you
can see places where it like levels out
so we can see we have a lot of new
customers and it's increasing but then
here for the region of East there kind
of is a level spot where we're not
getting new orders and that seems to be
the same for each of them so for
February of 2014 why were we not getting
any new orders
and how come the west region is getting
new customers how come the west region
is getting new customers faster here
while it's leveling out in the red it
looks like the west region leveled out
as well but picked up sooner and started
getting new customers so this type of
analysis will help you view new
customers over time and it's only
possible because we were able to do a
level of detail calculation here on new
or existing
that would compare
this data at
only aggregating the data for the
specified Dimension so we were able to
grab their minimum order date here so
those are a couple of ways that level of
detail calculations can be very helpful
in summary today we learned about live
versus extract Tableau Data sources we
learned about joins and unions in the
data sources we also looked at table
versus database calculations we looked
at how the different ranks compare we
built some actions into our dashboards
filter actions and highlighting actions
we also looked at URL actions we built
dashboards that used reference lines and
ones that use reference bands we did
analyzing of average days to ship and
delay analysis we build a waterfall
chart and we also looked into some level
of detail calculations we will be
building dashboards from start to finish
first about world population then Health
next we'll build a dashboard about
economy and finally we'll build a
dashboard about business ease I would
recommend getting access to the data set
before you start this tutorial so you
can build along with me if you would
like access to this data set please
comment below and we'll get you access
so first we're going to build a
dashboard that revolves around
population so we're going to build a map
based on Country so I'm going to double
click on country and it's going to map
out all the countries and then on our
marks I'm going to change it to map
so it's a filled in map and we want this
to be colored by population total
and we can see
who contributes the most to population
we're going to label it with population
as well
but you can see that it's labeling it
the total population and what we want to
label it is how much it contributes to
population by percentage so let's add a
table calculation and we're going to
have it do percent of total based on
country
okay so now we can see which countries
contribute what percent
let's also bring the country name onto
the label and let's put it on top so
country names on top now it's getting a
little bit of crowded in here so
we're going to unclick show marks label
and we're just going to show the ones
that we want to see specifically so when
we can right click on China here hover
on Mark label and click always show
and on India
since these are our two biggest
contributors
we can see that this one's a little bit
darker than the others in that area
and here
here
and that's just a manual way to choose
which ones have indicators labels and
which ones do not
and we're going to put a note here so
we're going to annotate an area
that explains that
China and India
contribute the most to world population
just calling out
this section of the visualization
and let's name this sheet
so here we have our visualization and
when you hover you can see both the
total population and its percent
contribution and the country name
our next visualization for this
dashboard is going to be
population over time
so
let's bring on our time element but one
trick for bringing on a time element if
we just drag it on so here with the
calendar Mark here if we just drag it on
it'll default
to
a discrete version so let's take it back
off
and then we could edit it there but one
thing you could do is if you on a
Windows machine if you right click on it
and drag it on then it will pop up
with the dialog box that allows you to
select what kind of
date value you want to use in the first
place so we're going to use year here
and now we have instead of discrete we
have a continuous axis and we're going
to bring on population total
and we can see that over time
one thing you can do when the value is
up so high in your axis is you can
uncheck this box that says include zero
and it will not always include zero in
your axis but this can be misleading so
you can see that it looks like
population growth is something really
dramatic by increasing that slope of the
Y
whereas it really wasn't quite as
dramatic as it seems so as long as it's
communicated well and you're not doing
it to
mislead your users you just need to keep
in mind that this includes xero can
change what your graph is saying so
we're going to not include the zero at
this time
just so that we can focus in on our data
a little bit
now we're going to add our forecast so
we're going to click on forecast and
drag it on
and it adds the forecast to our
visualization right there and now we can
right click here
and see forecast result is actual and
forecast
so you can see that the forecast picks
up here in 2012 and pushes out what it
thinks it'll be in 2013 as well you can
change how far out that forecast goes by
right clicking on the line and clicking
forecast option
and we can change it says automatically
the next two years but we could change
it so that it's the next 10 years and
we'll go out into the future out to 2022
you can change prediction intervals or
if you don't want to show them you don't
have to show them and this is just kind
of
a visual guide for those prediction
intervals
okay and then you can also have your
trend line show
where it shows your trend line following
out from where your population growth is
and also the trend line for your
forecast right there
and we'll call this
world population
excellent we're going to make one more
visualization for this and it's going to
be a pie chart so the pie chart is also
going to be based off of population
so we're going to click on population
and we're going to control click on
country and come over to show me
click your pie chart
great so I'm going to make this the
entire view so we can see the pie chart
better
and this is getting really crazy in here
and so I have changed my mind and
instead of country I'm going to drag
region over top of country and now we
see something a little bit more
manageable so we can see that here's
Asia and it makes up
the biggest piece of the pie and then
here is everybody else so right now
each of these is population total and we
could keep it that way or we could
do what we did last time and change it
to percent of total so that on Hover we
can see the population and the
percentage of population that it
contributes
so for this pie chart we're just going
to show Asia versus everybody else so we
need to make a group and what we'll do
is
select all of these and we're going to
right click and click group
so now we have all those things we
selected and we have other let's edit
our group right click edit group
we're going to rename this group
Asia because
that's all that's in there and we're
going to rename this group
rest of the world
okay so now we have our group we can
drag it on to label and we can see Asia
and rest of the world and now see how
it's breaking it up into those different
sections that's because we still have
region on our detail right here so we
pull region off now it's just split Asia
rest of the world
we can change our colors
make it a little bit more
visually interesting
and we can still see our percentages
and now let's rename it and then we'll
put it all together on a dashboard
all right so let's make our dashboard we
have this new dashboard button down here
and you can choose what sizes you want
so we have a fixed size where you just
select the width and height we have
automatic which will just fill your
screen
and we have a range which has a minimum
size and a maximum size some of the
good things about fixed is that once you
have it you can have it always look that
way so no matter where they're looking
at it you know that it's going to be
laid out the way that you expected
however if somebody's looking out on a
screen that is bigger or smaller than
yours then it doesn't fill up the screen
or it will felt screen too much and
they'll have to scroll up and down and
left and right if you have automatic
then it will fit the screen that it's
displayed on however the things that
you've placed might get squished too
close together and then the range gives
you a minimum size and a maximum size
meaning if the screen is too big it
still won't fill up the screen but it
can get closer and then as they get
smaller and smaller screens you at least
know that it will never make it get
smaller than this particular size so
there's some benefits to that as well
where you still have a little bit of
control of what it will look like in the
end
great let's bring on our worksheets
and you can see that way you hover it
fills up that space and that's where
it's going to show up you can also
adjust the lines in between different
visualizations for things that need more
space or less bass another important
thing to recognize is that when you
click on a visualization
like this one up here it will tell you
how it's viewing that visualization
within that space so if you click
standard then it will do a standard Fit
versus if you have entire view where it
will make it fit into inside the box
over here we could have fit width
or fit height on some of the
visualizations it doesn't make as much
of a difference however when you have a
visualization that maybe has a lot of
text in it and they need to be able to
scroll you'll want to have it fit width
but you don't want it to fit height
because then it will shove all of that
information into the box and not allow
you to scroll up and down
so if you saw as we drag these on it
took these
Legends and added it to the left here
we can modify that
and make them floating
and drag them next to the visualizations
that they
are relevant to
and
this particular one
it has a couple of things wrong with it
we might not want the title of this to
be region group so we could come in and
we could edit the title and then
maybe just call it region
however I don't think we need this
Legend at all because it's very clearly
marked on the visualization there so you
could also just remove it from the
dashboard
and this one
is telling you how big of a circle
it would need to be before it gets to
that population number so
it belongs to this circle as well but
again is unnecessary potentially because
we have our two population numbers
showing upright as we hover
so we'll remove that as well so at this
point we have a visualization or three
visualizations all on the same page
which is the basics of a dashboard
however we might want to be able to
interact with them a little bit more
than just hovering
and so this is where we should look into
adding filters so we have information
over time we have information by country
and we have some information by region
here
and one of the quickest things you can
do to add functionality to the dashboard
is by
clicking this uses filter button so if
we click this that means whatever
country we click on here
will filter the other visualization
and then you can unselect it
to go back
now that uses filter button actually
creates an action here filter one
generated that it's made on its own now
you can see that when we click on China
it doesn't make a lot of sense to have
this pie chart update based on that
China click because it's just going to
show
duplicated information so it shows the
20 or the 20 here and the 17
billion
and then here it does the same thing
except for it shows a hundred percent
because it's filtered everything else
out of the chart so it now makes up 100
of the circle so that doesn't make a lot
of sense
so there are ways to
format your visualization or your
actions modify your actions so that they
only affect the things that make sense
so we can come here and click edit
we're going to call this country
action
and we want it to
use the population by country sheet and
then modify only the trend
so now when we click on
China we see China's Trend over time
and it doesn't affect our pie
because that doesn't make sense for it
to affect our pie
we might want to select on our pie
Asia or rest of the world and have that
affect the other visualization so we can
click use this filter here and click
Asia and now it zooms into Asia on our
map
and shows us just the Asia world
population Trend and here's rest of the
world and we can see that Asia is grayed
out
and there's the rest of the world and
here's the rest of the world population
we might also want to be able to use
this to filter to a certain year
so if we click use this filter
then we click on 2011.
see these numbers are slightly updating
so this is 19 percent
and we come here 19.5 percent
come down here and we can see that the
pie updates a little bit although it
hasn't been anything dramatic
you can kind of see it over time
so that's one way to add filters to your
visualization another way
is to use actual filtering instead of
just actions so if we come back here to
our Trend we could take the year we're
going to control click and drag it onto
filters
and now we have a year filter so we
could have it the actual year number so
just look at one year at a time or a
range of dates
so if we click range of dates that makes
this slider
from 2000 to 2012. so if we hit OK
we'll right click it we'll click show
filter we can see it here and as we drag
this
it updates
but kind of messes with our forecast
so let's not do a year filter
in this case
so it could remove filter there
but maybe we want a filter just on this
for the different years so let's drag
year onto the filters we're just going
to do the year number next
and here's all the years we're gonna let
all of them be selected for now
and then we're going to show the filter
and here's all of our years
and we can change the way that our quick
filter shows up and we can make it like
a drop down so they can still select
multiples but is it drop down or maybe
we want this visualization to be just
one year at a time so we could choose
single value in a list and it lists out
all the years or in a drop down
and we want it to be 2012.
and then we want this to show up on our
dashboard so we come to the dashboard
and we click more options here hover
over filters and we can see the filters
available and we can click year over
year
and now our formatting hasn't passed on
so that's one thing to remember that
formatting it just on the workbook
doesn't necessarily mean that the
formatting will pass over to the
dashboard so I tend to not do any
formatting on the workbooks and just
format it on the dashboards because the
dashboards are what I publish
so we're going to single value drop down
we're going to
add it we're going to move it to the top
so now how we do that
let's talk a little bit about what each
of these sections are come here to
layout
and you can see we have this layout here
item hierarchy so tiled is the whole
screen and inside of that we have a
horizontal
container
and inside this horizontal container we
have another horizontal container and
when you click on something in this View
it shows you where it exists
so we can see this horizontal container
is outlined now and then we change it to
vertical and it outlines this now a
horizontal container allows things to be
side by side and the vertical container
allows things to be out one on top of
the other and so in our vertical
container we see all this extra space
for extra things to be on top of each
other but if we wanted to have it at the
top
we would maybe want things to be able to
be side by side so if we go back to the
dashboard and we grab horizontal and
drag it to the top
it adds a horizontal container up here
and now you can see everything that's
floating kind of stays in the place that
it was even though all the other things
shifted so that's one of the
disadvantages of floating is that you're
kind of just manually choosing
where it will stand
using your X and Y position
and it's not Dynamic so let's give us a
little bit less space up here
we can add a text box into
our horizontal container all right we'll
say copy
information dashboard
and we can format it
now we have our title up here and then
we can add our filter
we're going to drag it to be on
inside of our horizontal container but
on the
side here
you can give it more or less space
bring our Legends down to places where
they make sense again
perfect and so now we have this that
will affect this
only and show you just 2012 2011 2010.
so we don't want it to affect the trend
because we want the trend to show all of
time and just looking at one year for
this trend that is only at a yearly part
and forecasts into the future doesn't
make any sense but we maybe wanted to
also affect this worksheet so that these
two are in sync and so the dashboard is
basically for 2012 except for the trend
which shows you the pass in the future
so one way that you can do that is
clicking apply to worksheets here
and you can choose selected worksheets
and it will show you all the worksheets
in this visualization or in this
dashboard and you can click show all
worksheets in workbook and then if there
were other worksheets it would show them
so we wanted to do Asia versus rest of
the world and population contribution by
country
okay and that's another way we can
change what year they show so it's only
going to show one year at a time
unless we select all
and then this visualization isn't
affected by it
if we don't want
to click on a country and have it make
the change if we instead want to have a
filter for Country we can do that
by taking country and dragging it onto
filters
we'll have it show off for now
and then when we go back to our
dashboard and we come to this
visualization we can go filters and add
country
and it's just added it side by side
where we had our other filters so that's
a nice feature of Tableau where it can
kind of guess where you might want
things we're going to do multiple value
drop down
and right now
it only affects that visualization and
we can just look at one country at a
time
and we might not want it to affect this
visualization because it doesn't do us
any good to just look at one region in a
pie chart
but maybe we want it to affect the world
population Trend so we can do the same
thing we did before
and we wanted to affect these two
we'll click ok
and so now
we could look at
all these countries
and that would update both these
visualizations
another thing I like to do on a filter
is customize and click show apply button
and this means we can make all these
changes in here
see I've selected none however these
visualizations aren't updating and then
I wanted to look at Turkey so I found
turkey and then I hit apply and that's
when they update
perfect so now we have a dashboard
complete with filters and actions
we also have a title on our dashboard we
can give it a little bit less space and
some Legends
we have titles on each of these pieces
however if we didn't want a title here
we can click hide title and it will just
show our visualization there and this is
dashboard number one
here's what it looks like in full screen
mode full screen mode is a good
opportunity for you to test it to see
what it will look like to the end user I
press escape and get back out and it
doesn't give you these highlights when
you hover over things that are dashboard
formatting related
you can see that all those extra lines
went away
and it just gives you the opportunity to
test out your dashboard in a more real
way and see how they will use it
instead of giving you the dashboard
editing options
next we're going to make a dashboard
revolving around the health information
so first we're going to make a map
about birth rates so we're going to call
it birth rate
rank
and to make a map we're going to double
click on country
and we're going to change it to a map
type so we have a filled map here and
then we're going to bring birth rate
onto color
so let's define our colors a little bit
by clicking on this color part of the
marks card we'll click edit colors and
we're going to change it
to
red and gold
and the idea here is that the red is for
a higher birth rate which is more
associated with countries that have poor
health so we'll hit apply
and now we have our higher birth rate
countries highlighted in red next we're
going to create
a class so we're going to duplicate
birth rate
and let's edit that field
we're going to call it birth rate class
and so we're going to say that anything
that is in the top 50 countries
with the highest birth rate is
categorized it has having an alarming
birth rate so we will
first do the average
birth rate
and then we're going to do a rank on
that
do you see sometimes
when you're Auto completing your
statements it will replace
one of these functions that you have
with the one that you pressed tab for so
if I type if or I start to type if and
then I come here and click on if it
replaced my rank with if so keep an eye
out for that if you're like where did my
thing go it's because I was typing it
right next to it so if I put a space and
then I start to type if and I click if
it will not delete rank so we're gonna
say if the rank of average is less than
or equal to 50. so if it's in the top 50
then
alarming
birth rate
else if
and we could take this again
is greater than 50 then
normal over 3.
always make sure you put on the end also
we didn't necessarily have to have this
else if statement
so if we had just done else normal birth
rate that would have covered all of our
bases so with these if statements just
make sure that you're always getting all
the different options
that you want but in this case we
defined both however we didn't have to
define the second calculation because if
it is not in the top 50 then it's
obviously in the bottom the rest
so we're going to hit OK and then we're
going to put birth rate class onto label
and it's gone around and labeled
everything
and I am seeing alarming birth rate on
so let's see what the problem is
so if we open this back up by right
clicking and clicking edit you can see
it says results are computed a long
table across
so we're going to click default table
calculation here and instead of compute
using automatic we're going to change it
to compute using
country we'll hit OK and hit apply
and that didn't seem to fix it so this
is the first place I would look if it's
not doing what you would expect
so
we'll put it back to automatic okay the
second place I would look is inside of
the table calculation that is created so
when we defined rank here we put a table
calculation on it so when we right click
here we get edit table calculation
and we're going to choose that we want
to do the rate based on
the specific dimension of country
so now we can see
using the logic
the calculation assistance that
we no longer have just alarming birth
rates we have normal birth rate and
alarming birth rate on our screen so we
can close this
and
we are done here but one thing you could
do is
when we have allow labels to overlap
other marks selected then it will make
sure that every label shows up but it
gets super crazy in there so there are
some times where the labels May overlap
a little bit and so you'll want to
select this option in our case we don't
want that
and now we have a visualization
showing birth rate map based on rank our
next visualization
is going to be about
average life expectancy
male versus female
so we're going to do a chart across time
so we're going to click year and bring
it on two columns and we're going to
change it to this year in the continuous
section so now we have an axis
and
we're going to double click on female
life expectancy up there we go double
click on female life expectancy and then
double click on male life expectancy so
what that did was made us two charts put
one on top of the other but we don't
want that so we'll take this off and
we're going to drag me a life expectancy
right onto this axis for the female life
expectancy
and what this has done is made what's
called a blended axis chart so it's not
a dual axis chart where we have another
axis over here
for the second visualization this one is
a blended access chart so they
necessarily use the same axes and they
necessarily have the same kinds of marks
so we'll take a look and see what the
difference is there so if I were to
change this to a bar chart we would have
bar chart for both of them and I can't
Define one separately from the other
change it back to a line chart
and they're both a line chart now if we
go back to when we just had female life
expectancy and we drag male on next to
it and we have two charts now we can
change it to a dual axis and we have one
on top of the other however our axes
don't line up we can see at the top here
is 15K and over here it's 14k so we're
going to synchronize the axis and you
can see
one on top of the other
and we have two marks cards so we could
have this one be a bar chart and that
would be a line chart
so that's some of the differences of
those two we're going to do a blended
axis chart so I'm going to take mail and
drag it here
and we have our Blended access chart and
now you can see the our scale here is
really strange so what it's doing is
it's adding up all of the life
expectancies for all the different
countries instead of averaging it so
we're going to change that by right
clicking on the measure down in this
measure values card hovering over
measure sum and we're going to change it
to average
since I only changed one of them and
they share the same axes it's really
spread out now and it almost looks like
a straight line down there and then
let's change the other
and it should get everything a little
bit more
in sync there we go so now we can see
the average life expectancy over time
which for both of them seems to be going
up
however
it seems to be higher for females
now let's take a look at our analytics
and let's drag on forecast so it's
forecasted out the next two years for
both line
and we'll bring on Trent
onto linear
and let's change it
to a square so now we see each
individual point for the life expectancy
for our females and males and we can see
what they're expected to be in the
future and our trends
and our next visualization
is going to be a heat map
about
multiple different measures so we'll
just call it a heat map for now and for
our heat map we're going to look at the
different countries so we'll bring
country onto rows and we're going to
look at their
birth rate
so I just double clicked on birth rate
and brought it on we're going to look at
their health expenditure percentage on
GDP so how much they spend on GDP
so when I double clicked on it it did
what we did before where we have a
measures value card and so now whenever
we put measures on here that determines
what goes here because we have our
measured names on columns so every
measure in here their name is going to
define the name of the column and the
values Define what's in the text right
here
great we're also going to bring on
infant mortality rate and the life
expectancy for females
okay
so now it has
changed these to not have decimal points
after them which is not as helpful so
we're going to
format those
and you can format it field by field so
for birth rate we definitely want to
have
decimals afterwards as a matter of fact
the birth rate is a percentage so
instead of doing a number standard we'll
just go to percentage
and now we don't need to have those
decimals afterwards we can just look at
the birth rate as a rate and for
percent of GDP for health expenditures
we can come click there and do the same
thing
and for infant mortality rate
okay
and to make this make a little bit more
sense we again need to change it from a
sum
to an average
and for some of these we could
change it from a sum to an average right
inside of
the full for all of these we could
change it from a sum to an average in
the default properties under aggregation
so that it will automatically average it
whenever we bring it out
default is sum
but if we make it automatically average
then we won't have to do that again for
any other visualizations
I won't do that at this time because I
get a little bit confused sometimes when
I don't have my thumb on there by
default because that's what I'm so used
to seeing by default great so we now
have
a matrix
by country and by our different metrics
here and so we can
take our measure values
and drag it on to color
and we'll make our marks from automatic
to square and it will make our heat map
now what happens with a heat map
is it colors Darkly the higher the
number it is in this case and right now
it's doing it for the whole area so one
percent is obviously much much smaller
than 82 but if we wanted to be able to
look at birth rate independently from
life expectancy we can right click on
the measure values on the color and
click use separate Legends
and so now we have a legend
for each one of these let's change the
colors on those Legends so that we can
see them separately a little bit more
clearly
so we'll change the colors by coming
over here to each of the legends and
we'll leave one the same
but we'll change this one
and if we click edit colors you can see
our different palettes
you can see some of them just have one
color others have one color two another
color we used the
Red Gold before
so now you can see that one is changed
we could use another one that goes from
green to blue
great
you can also Define your own
so you can make a custom one that could
go from light to dark and then you can
choose what color you want as your dark
color
so we could pick
a lighter blue
and then we see that last one
and now with these separate color
palettes you can quickly see the
difference with birth rate and
spending for on health
and that is our heat map
with separate Legends so let's build
this all into a dashboard now
we're going to call it our health
dashboard
and for Simplicity we're going to make
it automatic so it fills our screen
and then we're going to first bring on
our map
we're going to bring on our health
related map with birth rates then we're
going to bring on our heat map
and we'll bring on our life expectancy
lines
now as we brought on all of our charts
it brought in our Legends here
and we're going to move our Legends up
to the top so let's add a horizontal
container
and then let's put our Legends
into the horizontal container
and let's put these ones in order so
life expectancy
oh so birth rate is going to be over
here
great now one thing we can do is make
these
smaller
well that's actually just making that
one bigger huh okay so it would make
them smaller
by making something else bigger or by
adding in a blank space
which would then
help you adjust the size
by taking up the space that you're not
using
another thing to pay attention to is
this fixed width so once you start to
drag the size on something it no longer
is dynamic
so if we unfix that width
so that it's only taking up whatever
space is left oh and that one is not
fixed with
and then we can edit the width on this
to be even bigger
then I will squish things over to where
we would like them to be so
that's one of the ways you can add space
or make things the size you would like
them to be now let's take a look at
filters oh before we take a look at
filters I want to look at this map one
more time because I think that it would
be useful for our colors to be a little
bit more
distinct so one quick way to navigate to
your worksheet from your dashboard is to
click this go to sheet button and while
we're here I'm going to click on color
edit colors and we did red and gold and
we're going to change it from this
sequence to a stepped color
now we're going to change it to three
colors so it's going to either be this
color this color this color I want to
hit OK
you can kind of see it's a little bit
more dramatic in our differences and
it's put everything into the three
categories we defined so let's go back
to our dashboard
and we can see the difference there
and now we're going to take a look at
our filters so we want to be able to
filter by country
so let's bring country onto filters
now we're going to allow it to use all
and we're going to
here you can click apply to worksheets
and you can click selected worksheets
and it's going to pop up with all the
worksheets
in the whole workbook
and so one disadvantage of doing it on
the worksheet is that you can see all of
the worksheets in the workbook and you
have to differentiate between which ones
are on the dashboard which ones aren't
and these are the three on this
dashboard so we're going to hit OK
now we're also going to do it by year so
when we drag the year onto filters
we're going to
allow them to
two years so we're going to do
the distinct number of years we'll click
use all
okay
and we're going to apply to the
worksheets
this one with the birth rate and the
average life expectancy male versus
female we're not going to filter down
our line chart by year because we want
to be able to see it over time and if we
filter down the time then we don't get
as much context so we'll hit OK
let's go back to our dashboard
if I click on more options here and
hover over filters you can see that year
filter and that country filter
you should also be able to see both of
those filters on the heat map
because I told it to apply to that one
as well so here's the country oh
I made a mistake let's go back to this
visualization
and
apply to worksheets selected worksheets
see I wanted it to be on the birth rate
and the heat map not the line chart and
I clicked the wrong one
so that was a good test
so when we go here to the heat map
and click down
you can see now we get the year of year
as well so we'll click year of year
let's put it over here
and we're going to make it
a multiple values drop down and we'll
bring it over
to the middle
and let's also
get the countries filter
great so now that we have these in here
we don't need this to be so big so let's
edit the width
and make it 300
even smaller
great and let's change our country
to be a single value drop down so you
can pick one at a time and let's also
change it or this year of year since we
can select multiples let's change it so
that
on customize that you show the apply
button
so here since they can only select one
we don't have the apply button because
it will just automatically apply
and here since I can select multiples
we'll let them unselect all and pick
their years
and then hit apply and then you'll see
the changes and you can see that even
though I've selected only 2011 and 2012
you still see all the years on this line
chart as expected
and there is our health dashboard
our next dashboard is going to have to
do with economy our first sheet is going
to be
another map that is going to have to do
with overall GDP
and as we usually begin with maps by
double clicking on country
and changing it to a map Mark type
and this time we're going to bring on
GDP onto color
and change it to average
and we can edit the colors
let's this time do a custom diverging so
you get to pick both colors and let's
pick
a little bit lighter
hmm
okay red for there and then we wanted to
do maybe like a deeper green and that
way you can see who has the highest GDP
which is green we hit apply okay and
then it will eventually get lighter and
lighter until it goes to gray which then
it will lead to Green
and next we're going to make
scatter plot
which we will call GDP versus GDP per
capita
so
GDP or gross domestic product versus
gross domestic product per capita or per
person
and to make a scatter plot
you have one
measure on one axis
and then another measure which is going
to be
GDP per capita which we will now create
on the other axis
so let's start with GDP and we'll hit
duplicate
and let's edit that and we're going to
call it
GDP per capita
and we're going to take
some
of GDP
and divided by the sum
of the total
population total
what is my error
opening parenthesis there we go
and then we have GDP per capita so let's
what this will do is sum up the GDP
across whatever measures we have in
place okay we'll cross whatever
Dimensions we have in place and then sum
up the population for those same
dimensions and then divide it instead of
dividing it per row and then
doing an aggregation on it
so now we're going to bring on GDP per
capita on the rows
and we have the sum of GDP and the GDP
per capita and to make it more than just
one
little Mark on our scatter plot we will
drag on country to detail and now we
have one Mark per country
and you can see some countries have
a high GDP per capita and some countries
have a high GDP overall but not as high
of a GDP per capita
and so on we have some middle of the
road people here so we can change this
from automatic to circles and now
they're dots like you might see on a
scatter plot and you can
drag region
onto color and now we can see our
different regions
and see we see a lot of Reds here
and
it's quick to see
what region things belong in also you
can click to highlight and you can see
all of the Americas highlighted in
context
the next visualization we're going to
make
is going to be
showing how much countries spend on
Health Care
as a part of their GDP so we're going to
rename it
to be GDP on Healthcare
and we're going to look at each of our
countries
and we're going to make a bar chart
that shows
the health expense GDP
and we're going to change this to
average
and we're also going to show the health
expense per capita
over here it shows how much is spent per
person on health
and this
is showing how much
is spent on health
based on GDP
click at the top and click sort and it's
sorting by this first one
and you can see which countries spend
the most of their GDP on health we can
again bring region onto color so we can
see the different regions
highlighted
and
let's bring on labels so
for our different marks cards
we're going to want to control click
this and drag it onto the labels
and we can see that it's a percentage
but it's coming up as a number so we can
right click and click
format right there
and
we're going to change the number to
percentage
maybe just do one decimal place
and then for this one
we're going to control and drag
that on the labels
and maybe we'll change this one to
currency
however if you don't want to change it
to currency
since we aren't sure necessarily what
currency this data set is in
um it's worth checking out what currency
it is in so for now we'll just have it
as a number
and now we're going to customize our
tool tip
so we're going to go to the overall
marks card
and we'll click on tooltip and we wanted
to tell us the country in the top so
we're a race region
and we're going to
erase country label in Center country
and then we're going to put
this country
bends
this percentage
on Healthcare
and if you want to preview it you can
hover or click here on preview and it
will show you an example of Marshall
Island spends 2.1 on Health Care we'll
hit enter and then when we hover
tells you the country and it has our
custom tooltip on both visualizations or
on both
of the different axes
so let's build our dashboard
we'll bring on our map
we'll bring on our
Healthcare
visualization
and our GBP versus GDP per capita
and we'll move our Legends to the top
again
by adding a horizontal container to the
top
and bringing them up here
one thing we can do also
is to give this more space
we can have it go all the way to the top
and these Legends are just side by side
just above the map
and the GDP per capita
scatter type plot
an interesting thing you can do in
Tableau is you can see this outlier of
the United States is making it difficult
to see the rest of the information or to
visualize if there's any Trend there so
you could right click on it and click
exclude and then it will exclude it from
your data set very quickly
and then you'll just click this back
button to get it back
great now let's take a look at filters
we are going to do a single filter
so let's go to this visualization and
we'll bring on country
we'll click use all okay
and we're going to apply it to
worksheets so I showed you how we can
apply it to worksheets here
you can also apply to worksheets once
it's on the dashboard so if we come here
and look at filters we can see that
countries on the filters for this
visualization but if we come down here
and look at filters
we still see some country because it's
in the details of the information so
either way when we add country
since I added it from this visualization
it only affects this visualization
okay
but we want it to affect all on the
worksheet
so we're going to apply to worksheets
and we can click selected worksheets and
we can click all on dashboard
okay
let's bring this over here we're going
to allow them to see all at once and be
able to scroll and select the ones they
want and now
when we select different ones it affects
all three worksheets
we're also going to add an action
for a URL action add action go to URL
and when we click on a country on the
overall GDP map we want it to take us to
the Wikipedia page that talks about the
economy for that country
so that is
this URL and it's going to say Wikipedia
for economy of
now we're going to add our country to
the end
so we hit OK
we have it running on menu so let's
change it to run on select and as soon
as you click it it will take you there
okay so now let's try it
and we can click on Canada
and it will take us to the Wikipedia
page for the economy of Canada
great I'm gonna click on Brazil same
thing
so if we unselect on Brazil then it will
make our map highlighted normally again
we can also use this one to filter the
other visualizations and so we could
click use this filter here and then when
we click on France
it will filter these two other
visualizations to France
you can see that when we filter this
visualization
to a particular country
so if we look at
Germany
Germany wasn't green before on our map
but now it is that happens because our
scale has changed just for the ones
selected
so if we control click France and
Germany and Switzerland
and Austria we now have a scale that
reflects only these countries and the
biggest is going to be the darkest green
or the highest GDP is the darkest green
and the lowest is the lightest pink
and there is our economy dashboard you
can see that we have some nulls on these
visualizations that occurs when we don't
have all of the data for every point
you can ignore those and they won't show
up on the final visualization when you
publish it to server or you can deal
with those by clicking on them and
filtering that data out or showing that
data at the default position which is
showing the null values at zero our
final dashboard is going to be about the
ease of doing business in a country so
our first visualization is going to be a
bar chart which we will call days to
start
business so how many days it takes to
start a business is important to know
when you're trying to start a business
in a country and also can be an
indicator of how easy it will be to do
business in that country so let's make a
bar chart that includes every country
and then we're going to bring on days to
start a business
and we will sort it smallest biggest
and we have some days
or some countries that don't have
any days so let's filter out those
countries
and we're going to filter it to only
those that have a good Market
we're going to make a calculated field
we're going to Define business Friendly
Market
well
we're going to Define our Market based
on how easy it is to start a business
and how many days it takes so if it
takes less than 25 days to start a
business we'll consider that a good
market and so we're going to do
if
the days to start a business is less
than or equal to 25
then
else if
they used to start a business is greater
than 25 then
business
might or might not
work
doing by less than or equal to 25 or
greater than 25
allows us to be able to Define these two
different markets so we'll hit apply
there
and we're going to filter it
just to a good Market
and we're going to look at
just one year
we'll look at 2012.
our most recent year
and we're going to color it based on
region and we can see which regions tend
to have
the shorter days to start a business
and we're going to move on and build our
next visualization which is also a bar
chart
which we will call ease of business
so we have this ease of business field
and we could bring on the country and we
can bring on ease of business
and we want to
make it a measure so ease of business is
at this point looking at it like it's
a string
and we can change that in our default
properties and convert it to a measure
or use it up here and change it to a
measure
when we try to change it to a measure
here it wants to treat it like a string
so it wants to take the minimum or the
maximum but if we here convert it to a
measure then it also automatically made
it a count
so the first thing to do
would be to change the data type to a
number
and now
we can change it to a measure and
aggregate it so we could do like the sum
of ease of business in our use case
we're actually going to do the average
of ease of business and then we want to
have the smallest on the top we do have
some that don't have ease of business
ratings so we're going to filter that
data out
and again we want the year to be 2012
but how we're going to do that is by
coming to this visualization
and by applying this particular year of
2012 so we'll do it on select workbooks
and select easy business okay
and now this one also has
the year of 2012 there
and we're going to segment this by
creating another header
we're going to call that
business friendly
and we're going to say
that if the ease of business
is so I guess this is a nice thing to
know so if if we start typing in what we
want to see then we can select it from a
list here but you can also interact
outside of this box so you could just
grab these of business and drag it into
the dialog box here and that's really
nice so we're going to say if it is
greater than or equal to 1
and less than or equal to
three
then
we're going to say it has the most
business
friendly
regulations
give us a little more room to look at
okay and this statement will work
because it's saying and what is less
than or equal to three so you have to
have ease of business in both places
and then this should say then and not
the
great so now we're just getting an error
because we don't have an n
so if that's all we wanted to do then
that's what we would do but then we'll
just do another else if
and it's already taken this if statement
goes through one condition at a time so
it's already classified everything
that's between these two numbers and so
now we can just say
if ease of business is
less than or equal to 10.
then
we'll call it very very business
friendly regulations
and we'll keep going
elsif ease of business is less than or
equal to 50
then
we're going to call it
moderate
and we're just going to say moderate
business
regulations
for later years
less than equal to 150 then
strict
so the reason that this doesn't grab
everything that is less than or equal to
150 is because these sections one to
three and then three or well four to ten
and then 11 to 50 have all been
classified up to this point so it's just
getting everything else
and we're going to finally
say else everything else
is going to be called
not preferred for
business
and see if we get any errors calculation
is valid let's see if this works as we
expect so we'll hit apply and we'll
bring business friendly onto our rows
and now it categorizes everything
based on what we said so we want to
Define what order these go in so we're
going to click sort
and we want the most business friendly
at the top
then we want moderate then strict then
not preferred okay so we have our top
three that are the most business
friendly and then we've got four through
ten which are very then we've got our
moderate
are strict
and are not preferred
so let's bring region again onto color
and we can see which regions are the
most business friendly
and we have our year of 2012 there and
now we're going to make this even more
useful by adding the business tax rate
onto the label
so that you can see that business
friendly is like Singapore but they have
a pretty high tax rate of 27 whereas if
you get down to some of these that are
not preferred some of them have really
low tax rates
so let's make sure that we're getting
okay the right tax rate
so
you can see that
27 is definitely not the highest tax
rate that we have for business
but you can also see that there are
places that have
even lower tax rates
like Saudi Arabia
and
we have
eight percent here
it looks like we don't ever go to
that segment decimal place so let's
quickly
format this
oh
business tax rate is also text
so if we could convert
our data type to
decimal
and then we will
format it
to be a percentage
and we just need the one decimal place
okay
now let's make some annotations so we
could come and click here on this Mark
and then we can annotate that Mark which
will make this dialog box and it's
already filled in here and so we could
use some of this information so I'm
going to copy that
and I'll put some in hard returns there
so we're going to say that this country
is the most
business friendly but has a
business tax rate of and let's grab the
tax rate
and then We'll erase this
and we'll hit okay
and I've made a typo so Singapore is the
most business friend is not what I meant
to say so I can click edit
business friendly
but has a tax rate of and you can move
this around draws the line to Singapore
which is the mark
that we wanted to annotate so that is an
annotation on a Mark if we wanted to
just make an annotation for the area
then we could
point out that
more business friendly
countries
foreign
often have
hide
business taxes
we could change that size make
everything fit
now we have this second note
where our user can come in and see some
more information about what's being
presented here
great and now we're going to make one
more visualization
and it's going to be
about phone and internet usage
because you may want to know about the
phone and internet trends
when you're looking to start a business
so we're going to do this one over time
so it does not need to have that year
filter on it
and we're doing our continuous our axis
and we're going to look at mobile phone
usage so I double clicked it it shows
mobile phone usage over time
and we're going to change it to average
so that it's averaging it across the
countries and then we're going to bring
on
internet usage so we'll bring it on side
by side so we have two visualizations
and we're going to also make that
average
now we might not want these to share an
axis because they are measured a little
bit differently and so we can make it a
dual axis
but allow them to keep their independent
axes
or you can synchronize the axes
and see them at their rates however the
uses is just a little bit
of a different measurement we can have
one of them be
a bar chart and the other one be a line
let's have this one be the bar chart
okay and then the line is in the front
you can also change which one's in the
front by
coming and clicking
on the axis itself
and you can click move marks to front
and then move that one to the front Okay
and now it's made in each of these wide
and there's like a star point and end
point on the axis for the bar and that
comes here under size where they're all
fixed or you could have it be manual
where we can Define the size of the bars
so we're going to make those bars like
this
now we could see them going up over time
we can also change the width of the line
itself
make it thicker or thinner
and
we can change the colors here
so let's change it to Orange
since red might apply that it's bad
In some cultures
and now we can see our internet usage
and our phone usage over time and how
it's trending
and so this will all come together on
our new dashboard
which is about
ease of business
you can see that I have a sheet called
these as a business and a dashboard that
I've called is a business but it won't
let you create a dashboard with the same
name
worksheet so
ease of business dashboard
let's have it fit the screen
and we're going to bring on our
days to start business visual
our ease of business visual
and our phone and internet visual
let's put our Legends at the top again
so we'll make our horizontal
container
and we'll bring our region Legend into
there and then our
measure names for internet versus
mobile phone
and we have a filter that already is
pre-applied to two of the visualizations
called year of year
and it's selected 2012 and if we select
it's only changing this one it's
filtering out all the information for
this visualization and changing this one
to
2011. so let's see why that's happening
if we go to this visualization
and click the go to sheet
we can see year of 2012 is here let's
click show filter
and if we change the filter
2011 okay it's not showing up here and
the only filter I can see that could be
removing it is this averages of business
that is removing anything that is null
so if I pull that off you can see that
we don't seem to have any information
for 2011 for ease of business
and the more years I select I'm not
seeing any
ease of business information
so
we are going to want to set this to
2012 only because that seems to be the
only information that is useful for this
visualization
so let's go back until we're back to the
state we were in
when we started
okay so here we are
now we're going to want to remove this
filter
and we're going to give it its own
that only selects 2012.
that is not connected to the other
filter
so now when we change year view it only
changes this visualization sometimes
that's useful to note sometimes it's
useful to put
let's do a single value
drop down sometimes it's useful to put
this right next to the visualization it
affects
so if we could change it to floating
and just put it like here
that makes it clear that it's just
changing this chart
so that people don't get confused
another thing that we can do that we
should do on all of our visualizations
is
change the titles so that they're more
business or user friendly
great and
so we have our filter
and let's use this as a filter and that
way we can click on New Zealand and we
can see it's in most business friendly
regulations and we can see it's internet
and phone usage over time
we can click on
a lot of different countries to see
those changes
you can see that
some countries have a steeper change so
some of them have adopted phone and
internet usage and have stayed pretty
similar whereas other ones have only
really adopted it in the last couple of
years
also if we wanted to filter to just one
country we could do what we did before
and create a country filter
here's another way to go to the sheet
you can click this down arrow and click
go to sheet or you can come over here
you can see that it's highlighting a
visualization over here or a sheet and
whatever sheet I click on is highlighted
over here
and there's this little pop-out Arrow
here that also takes you to the sheet
and we can bring country on
use them all
go back to our dashboard
we'll go to filters and select country
we'll make it a multiple value drop down
we're going to add the apply button and
now we're going to make it apply to all
the visualizations by
clicking apply to workbooks selected
worksheets all on dashboard okay
now we can see that we just want to look
at Afghanistan
okay we can see
how many days it takes to start a
business there it's not preferred for
business and it's internet and phone
usage over time
and those are our
four dashboards so as a review we have
made a dashboard on population
we made one about health we made one
that had to do with our economy and one
that had to do with our ease of doing
business business intelligence is a set
of processes and techniques to analyze
raw data and extract information that
helps Drive business decisions it helps
you keep track of business data and draw
valuable insights there are several
tools that play a key role in business
intelligence some of the popular tools
are power bi Tableau and click view hi
guys welcome to this tutorial on what is
power bi in this video you will learn
why power bi is needed what is power bi
the various features of power bi and the
different components of power bi later
you will look at the architecture of
power bi for power bi services and how
to create a power bi dashboard finally
you will understand a case study on
Meyer and do a demo using power bi now
let's understand why power bi is needed
first Power bi has the ability to access
vast volumes of data from multiple
sources it allows you to view analyze
and visualize huge quantities of data
that cannot be opened in Excel some of
the important data sources available in
power bi are Excel CSV XML Json PDF Etc
second power bi provides an easy to use
drag and drop tool with features and
functionalities that allow you to copy
all formatting across similar
visualizations power bi has exceptional
integration with Excel it helps you
gather analyze publish and share Excel
business data power bi helps to
accelerate Big Data preparation with
Azure using power bi with Azure allows
you to analyze and share vast volumes of
data as your data leak can reduce the
time it takes to get insights and
increase collaboration between business
analysts data engineers and data
scientists power bi allows you to get
insights from data and turn insights
into actions to take data-driven
business decisions finally power bi
allows you to perform real-time stream
analytics it fetches data from multiple
sensors and social media sources to get
access to real-time analytics so you are
always ready to make business decisions
now let's see what power bi is power bi
is a business analytics service provided
by Microsoft that lets you visualize
your data and share insights it converts
data from different sources to build
interactive dashboards and bi reports as
you can see we have an Excel data about
sales using this data power bi helps you
build different charts and graphs to
visualize the data now that we have
understood what power bi is let us look
at the important features of power bi
first is power bi desktop power bi
desktop is a free software that you can
download and it allows you to build
reports by accessing data easily for
using power bi desktop you do not need
Advanced report designing or query
skills to build a report second as
already discussed power bi supports
stream analytics from Factory sensors to
social media sources power bi assists in
real-time analytics to make timely
decisions third support for multiple
data sources is one of the major
features of power bi you can access
various sources of data such as Excel
CSV SQL Server web files Etc to create
interactive visualizations and finally
custom visualization custom
visualization is another vital feature
of power bi while dealing with complex
data power bi's default standard might
not be enough in some cases in that case
you can access the custom library of
visualization that meets your needs let
us jump into discussing the various
components of power bi as you can see
there are six major components of power
bi now let's discuss them one by one
first is power query power query is the
data transformation and mashup engine it
enables you to discover connect combine
and refine data sources to meet your
analysis need it can be downloaded as an
add-in for Excel or can be used as part
of power bi desktop second we have power
pivot power pivot is a data modeling
technology that lets you create data
models it also allows you to establish
relationships and create calculations it
uses data analysis expression language
or Dax to model simple and complex data
third we have power view Power view is a
technology that is available in Excel
SharePoint SQL server and power bi it
lets you create interactive charts
graphs maps and other visuals that
brings your data to Life Next we have
power map Microsoft's power map for
Excel and power bi is a 3D data
visualization tool that lets you map
your data and plot more than a million
rows of data visually on Bing maps in 3D
format from an Excel table or data model
in Excel then we have power bi desktop
power bi desktop is a development tool
for power query power pivot and Power
view with power bi desktop you have
everything under the same solution and
it is easier to develop bi and data
analysis experience finally we have
power Q and A the Q and A feature in
power bi lets you explore your data in
your own words it is the fastest way to
get an answer from your data using
natural language an example could be
what was the total sales last year once
you have built your data model and
deployed that into Power bi website
right then you can ask questions and get
answers easily now let's see what power
bi service is power bi service is the
software as a service part of power bi
it is also referred as power bi online
to access power bi service you need to
log into
app.powerbi.com now let me show you that
I'll go to Google
we'll open a new tab and search for app
dot power bi
.com
it's loading
but this is how the home page of power
bi service looks like I have created
some dashboards on it first you need to
log into app.power bi service you can
see I'm logged in
now under my workspace if I go to
dashboard here I've created a finance
dashboard you can see the different
charts and graphs I have prepared and
pinned it to the dashboard so power bi
service allows you to connect to your
data create reports and dashboards and
you can also ask questions to your data
as you can see in this dashboard we have
created some charts and graphs so this
is a tree map there's a pie chart
there's a bar graph below you can see
the line charts and donut charts it
tells you the total sales that were made
the total number of units solds the
sales by product sales by country sales
by segment and lots more one of the key
features of power bi is creating
dashboards from multiple reports and
data sets power bi dashboard is a single
page visualization to tell a story the
visualizations on a dashboard are
generated from multiple reports and each
report is based on one data set a single
page dashboard is known as a canvas the
visualizations you see on the dashboard
are called tiles these tiles are pinned
to the dashboard by report designers now
let me go back to my dashboard so this
is called a canvas and each of these are
called tiles so on the top you can see
we have three tiles now let's understand
how to create and publish reports in
power bi dashboards power bi allows you
to create different reports on power bi
desktop these reports can be published
on the power bi dashboard using power bi
service here you can see there is a
power bi report created on power bi
desktop if you click on publish it will
take you to the power bi service where
you can build a dashboard here is the
button for power bi publish once you
click on power bi publish it will take
you to the dashboard so this is a single
page power bi dashboard on power bi
service now let's understand the power
bi architecture power bi architecture is
a service built on top of azure there
are multiple data sources that power bi
can connect to power bi desktop allows
you to create reports and data
visualizations on the data set Power bi
Gateway is connected to on-premise data
sources to get continuous data for
reporting and analytics power bi
services are basically the cloud
services that are used to publish power
bi reports and data visualizations using
power bi mobile apps you can stay
connected to their data from anywhere
power bi apps are available for Windows
IOS and Android platforms now let's look
at a case study on how Meyer which is
one of United States largest Supermarket
chains used power bi to solve its
business problems initially Meyer had
become dependent on its it organization
to extract insights from its data it was
time consuming and inefficient as you
had to wait for it to build every report
Meyer was unable to perform ad hoc and
real-time analysis easily so what Maya
did was it connected power bi to an
on-premises SQL Server analysis Services
Cube this allowed them to refresh 20
billion rows of data in near Real Time
with power bi teams can now pull in the
data faster and perform real-time
analysis to derive insights from data a
bakery department inside Meyer used
power bi to compare its sales with
regional performance they analyzed where
Meyer was behind the regional Trends
focused on the problem and created a
solution with power bi they can now
drill down into hourly sales and send
out a sales flash to 800 Maya Business
Leaders so power bi enabled them to
standardize data sources and Empower
store directors and team leaders to
develop and track that data to ensure
what they can improve now let's do some
practical Hands-On demo with power bi so
this is how the power bi desktop
interface looks like on the left you
have the report view the data View and
the model view the report view is where
you visualize your data with different
charts and graphs to build reports the
data view allows you to view the whole
data while the model view is where you
check if there are any relationship
between the tables on the right you can
see the different visualizations that
you can build we'll quickly run through
all of these in our demo
so here you can see there's a finance
sample data that will help you draw
insights about the sale of products in
different countries we will create a
report to visualize different charts and
graphs and analyze those sales so let me
go to my power bi desktop first we'll
import our data so let me go to our get
data Tab and choose Excel as my data
source I click on Excel so here is our
finance sample data
we'll select sheet1 you can see the data
here click on it and then select load
this might take some time to load the
data now if I go to my data tab you can
see the entire data set it has Fields
such as segment country in which the
Salesforce made the name of the product
the unit sold and the sales price and
many more let's start building a report
now I'll go to my report view so first
let me create a text box
let me resize it
let me name it as
Finance dashboard will increase the size
of the text we'll use Font Consolers
Center it will also add a background to
this we use blue color change it to
White
and
increase the size now let me first show
you how you can create a matrix I'll go
to visualizations and click on Matrix
let me resize it
from the datasheet tab I'll select sales
and drag on to values
so you can see the total number of sales
that were made now let me do some
formatting so I'll go to the format tab
click on column headers let's add a
background color and let me increase the
text size to 20. similarly under values
we'll increase the size of the text to
20 as well we can also click on border
and choose the color of the Border we
take as Let It Be black so this is a
simple Matrix that we created which
shows the total number of sales that
were made similarly let me choose Matrix
once again now we'll drag on the units
sold onto values we'll continue with the
same drill under column headers We'll
add a background this time let's choose
some other color and under values let's
increase the size of the text to 20.
even for the column headers let's
again we will switch on Border let me
resize a bit
so here we have two Matrix created for
our report the first Matrix shows us the
total sales that were made the second
Matrix shows you the total units that
were sold now let's move ahead and
create a simple bar chart so under
visualization I click on clustered
column chart
under this we'll drag the date column
onto access and the sales onto value let
me expand it so it shows you the sales
per year this is the sales that were
made in 2013 and this shows you the
sales that were made in 2014. now
there's a drill down option which gives
you more granularity
this depicts the sales per quarter if I
drill down further you can see this
shows you the sales by month also you
have some options like sort by sort by
sales so you can see October month with
the highest number of sales
moving ahead let me now create a pie
chart where we will see the sales by
different segments under visualization
I'll click on pie chart let me first
resize it
here
I'll drag the segment column onto the
legend and the sales column onto the
values as you can see we have the sales
made by different segments government
segment made the highest number of sales
with 44.22 percent now let me add a
border to both the visualization I'll
click on the pie chart and go to the
format tab I'll switch on the border
similarly for the clustered column chart
I'll go to the format Tab and click on
border now let me resize a bit alright
next we'll create a very simple table
that will depict the total sales made by
each product so under visualizations I
click on table let me bring this below
so from the data sheet I'll first drag
product onto values you can see the
different products and then sales just
below it
so this depicts the total sales that
were made by each product and finally it
displays the total value of the sales
that were made this is same as the one
shown here now let's do some formatting
under format tab I'll go to values and
increase the text size to 15. expand it
also under column headers I'll increase
the text size to 15. then let me go and
add a border
now let me create a map that will show
you the sales that were made by each
country so first let me create a new
page and under visualization I'll click
on map now I'll drag the country column
onto location
so you can see we have our map ready and
we'll drag sales onto size
you can see the different countries and
the sales that they made if I move the
map you can see the sales made in the
Europe region
let me resize it I'll add a border to
this
now let me go ahead and create a donut
chart that will show you the profit by
each segment under visualizations I'll
click on donor chart
and move this to the top now from the
data sheet I'll add profit onto the
values and segment
onto the legend
if I expand this you can see government
segment made the highest amount of
profit with 65.04 percent let me resize
this and we'll add a border
okay in the final visualization I'll
show you how to create a tree map this
tree map will tell you the total amount
of sales made by each product so under
visualizations I'll click on the tree
map let me expand it
I'll drag sales onto values and product
onto group so here you can see our tree
map and the sales made by each product
you can see now we have a report ready
we have created two separate canvas to
visualize our data now if you want to
change the color of these parts you can
simply go to the format Tab and under
data colors you can choose whichever
color you want in power bi desktop you
have an option to switch your theme this
will make your dashboard or the report
look more attractive so now we are under
the default mode Let's try out different
themes that's Frontier temperature
solar which is a little yellowish the
one which I like is tidal I hope this
was helpful in making you understand the
basics of power bi and how it works you
learned the various features and the
components of power bi and looked at the
architecture of RBI finally you saw a
demo to create a report using Finance
data set in our previous video on what
is power bi we had learned the basics of
power bi its features and components the
architecture of power bi followed by a
demo in this video we will learn what
power bi dashboard is we'll understand
how to create different reports in power
bi desktop then you will publish a
dashboard onto power bi service and
finally you'll derive insights from the
dashboard now let's understand what
power bi dashboard is power bi dashboard
is a single page visualization to tell a
story here on the screen you can see
there's a dashboard which has been
published on power bi service there are
multiple charts and graphs that you can
see the visualizations on a dashboard
are generated from reports and each
report is based on one data set a single
page dashboard is known as a canvas the
visualization you see on the dashboard
are called tiles and each of these tiles
are pinned to the dashboard by report
designers today we'll be covering the
following dashboard that you see on the
screen it will be a three page report
where we will be analyzing the
superstore sample data as you can see
there are three tabs now let me move
over to our data set so our Superstore
sample data set is in the form of an
Excel file you can see there are
multiple columns you can see there's
order date shipment date the mode of
shipment customers first name and last
name the segment to which the customer
belong to country of the customer the
city state and if you go towards the end
you can see that the different product
names the sales quantity sold discount
and the profit so the report that you
see here and the one which we are going
to create might vary a little in terms
of the color formatting and the spacing
so you need not worry about that now let
me go ahead and bring up a new workspace
so I'll go to file click on new this
will take some time to bring up our new
workspace now it will ask you for trying
the free version or if you want you can
go ahead and sign in I'll just close
this so here is our new workspace before
creating the dashboard we need to make
some changes to our Superstore data set
using the features of power bi desktop
first we'll extract the year month and
quarter values from the order date
column I'll go to get data tab click on
Excel as my source I'll locate my file
it's on desktop click on open this might
take some time to load the data set I'll
select the orders sheet you can see the
preview of our data here I'll go ahead
and click on load this will take some
time to load the data set onto power bi
desktop I think we have successfully
loaded our data set you can check that
by going to the data tab so here is our
data set first let's make some changes
in the format of the order date and the
shipment date I'll click on the order
date under the modeling tab
we have this data type and the format
I'll click on the drill down option
and the date and time now let's choose
the first one which is in the format of
ddmm why why
click on it
as you can see our order date column has
been changed to that particular format
similarly I'll select the ship date
column
go to the format option under date and
time I'll click on the first one
here you can see even the ship date
column has been changed to that
particular format now let's extract the
month values from the order date column
to do that right click on the order date
column
select new column
so this will create a new column if you
go to the end so there's a new column
rename this column as month and since we
want the month value from the order date
column I'll search for order date
dot since I want the month I'll select
month if I hit enter
it will give me the month values from
the order date column
similarly if you want to get the quarter
values from the order date right click
select new column
rename the column as quarter
[Music]
then choose the order date column
followed by the quarter name hit enter
so you can see you have a quarter column
and it has all the values of the quarter
to which the date belongs to now let me
go ahead and create one more column
this time we'll create a new column for
the order year this time we'll extract
the order year values so let me rename
it as year we'll continue with the same
procedure I look for the order date and
then select the year
hit enter
so it gives you only the year values on
which the order was placed
now let's find which day of the week was
the order placed so we need to use the
weekday function and give the order
data's parameter followed by which day
you want the week to start with I'll
show you how to do that so I'll click on
order date
then select new column
let's rename this column as day of week
I'll use the weekday function of power
bi you can hit tab to finish I look for
my order date column
comma
I'll choose 2 here since I want my week
to start with Monday and end on a Sunday
hit enter
so you can see we have the day of the
week column
so the idea to create this day of V
column is to find out if the order was
placed on a weekday or a weekend now let
me go ahead and create one more new
column
let's name this column as
weekday
or a weekend
I'll use an if clause
and pass in my parameters for logical
test I'll use the day of the week column
so I'll search for orders
and then look for day of week if this
day of the week is equal to 6 which
means if it's a Saturday or I'm using
the or operator
with the day of week is a Sunday that is
7 then
it's a weekend
else it's a weekday
I'll close the bracket hit enter so you
can see we have our weekday and weekend
column so moving ahead another thing we
can do is we can find the total number
of days it took for the shipment of the
product this can be done using the
dative function of power bi so let me
show you how you can do that I'll click
on any column right click go to new
column let's rename the column as
days for shipment then I'll use the date
div function
I'll give my starting date which is the
order date so I'll search for
order date
followed by the second date will be our
shipment date which is ship date and the
day
I'll hit enter
so you can see here it gives us the
total number of days it took for the
shipment of the product now let's create
a full name column where we will
concatenate the first name and the last
name of the customer let me go ahead and
do that
I'll create a new column
let me rename the column as full name
then I'll take the first name
from the orders table use the Amber sent
followed by a space using inverted
commas followed by another Ampersand and
the last name
I hit enter
you can see we have a full name column
if you go back so there were two columns
in the name of first name and last name
now we have merged both the columns into
a single column named full name and you
can see the first name space and the
last name now let me give the sales
column
a currency value so I'll select the
sales column
here
under General
if I go to currency I can see there are
multiple currency symbols
choose whatever you want for this video
I'll take dollar English United States
you can see our sales column is now
represented by a dollar value similarly
let me make some changes to the profit
column as you can see there are multiple
decimal values for each profit so let's
standardize it
so I'll select the profit column and
this is where you can standardize it now
it's Auto so let me make it two decimal
places
so our data is ready now let's go to the
report View and start building our
reports
before that
under the model view you can see the new
columns that we had created you can see
there's weekday weekend this year
this quarter column month column
the same you can see under the report
view as well
under fields you can see these are the
columns that we created days of shipment
day of week
quarter
month weekday or weekend and year now we
are under the report view first let me
go ahead and create a text box
so under the Home tab you have the text
box
I'll select that
let me stretch it a bit
we'll give a title
sales
dashboard I'll select this and increase
the size to
let's say 28 we make it bold
and Center align it also under the
visualizations tab under background
will add a background color to this text
box let me select this blue color and
let me make
the font as white
so now we have our title ready
so under General you can decrease the
height of the text box let me make it as
first let us create a new card from the
visualizations panel so under
visualizations there is an option to
create new card I'll click on it
let me resize
I'll move it to the top
we'll see the total amount of sales or
the total revenue that was generated
from the sales after selecting the card
I'll choose sales onto fields
so here you can see it gives you the
total sales that were made so which is
nearly 2.3 million dollars
if I go to the format tab under data
label
let me switch on the border under title
you can give a new title for example
total
Revenue hit enter
now you can
increase the text size to say 15 and
Center Line it you can also change the
color of the sales value so under data
label under colors you can choose
whichever color you want
similarly let's create one more card to
find the total number of units that were
sold I'll copy the same card
Ctrl C Ctrl V
I'll move it a little below
now I'll remove the sales column
from the fields and add the quantity
column onto fields
again
under title I'll edit this title as
total
quantity sold
let me create one more card
where we will see the total amount of
profit that were made I'll select this
I'll remove the quantity column
and add profit
under the format tab
under title
I'll make this as
total
profit
hit enter
stretch it a bit so that you can see the
total amount of profit that were made
now
let me add a slicer
wherein
will have the order date column
so I'll add the order date column onto
fields
so you can see here we have the order
date column and
under slicer header
let me increase the text size
to 15.
and
let's switch on the border
you can also give a title to the slicer
so under the format tab to go to title
switch it on
and we'll give a title text as
slicer by
order
date
scroll down I'll Center align it and
increase the text size to 15.
now if you want you can also change the
date colors
to Blue so under date inputs then go to
font color and select any blue color
now let's create a line and stack column
chart to visualize sales and profit by
each year each month and each quarter so
from the visualizations tab let me
select line and stack column chart
I'll resize this
after that let me add the order date
column onto the shared axis
we'll drag the sales onto column values
and underline values I'll take the
profit column
so here you can see we have the sales
and profit by each year
the bars represent the sales and this
line represents the profit it made for
each year
let me go to the format tab
and
make some changes to the data colors let
the color of the profit remain the same
but the bars I'll choose a custom color
give a hexadecimal value like
hit enter
so we have successfully changed the
color of the bars power bi has an
interesting feature where you can drill
down the seals by each year each month
each quarter or by days so let me show
you so on the top it shows you go to the
next level in the hierarchy so if I
click on this here you can see the sales
and the profit that were made for each
quarter in every year
quarter four for every year made the
highest amount of sales and the profit
similarly if I drill down further you
can see let me expand it you can see by
month this is for each month
over all the years how much sales were
made
you can check November month give us the
highest amount of sales and
December month gave us the highest
amount of profit
similarly you can still go to the next
hierarchy here you can see
the sales and the profit made for each
day over all the years so day 17 meet
the highest amount of sales
and day 23 gave us the highest amount of
profit if you see the lowest sales and
the profit you can see order date 25
gave us the lowest amount of profit
and similarly you can see day 29 gave us
the lowest amount of sales
now you can also go to the format tab
and switch on the data labels
so you can see here in 2014 we got
nearly 49.5 K profit and nearly 0.48
million dollar sales similarly in 2015
we had nearly 61.6 K profit and 0.47
million sales and so on
now let me go ahead to the format Tab
and
switch on the border let me now create a
clustered column chart for sales by year
and quarter so from the visualizations
let's select clustered column chart let
me resize this a bit
and under access
we'll add the year column
so I'll drag here on to access under
Legend I'll take the quarter column
and under values I'll choose sales
so you can see here the sales that were
made under each quarter for each year
this picture clearly says quarter 4 for
every year Meet the highest amount of
sales and quarter one
made the lowest
let me go to the format tab
and I'll go to the data colors let's
change the colors for each of these
quarters we'll be using hexadecimal
values so under custom colors for
quarter one
let me select hexadecimal value as
follows so for example PF D6 D9
similarly for Quarter Two
I'll select 6D 9 ba6
for quarter 3
and finally for quarter 4
I choose a little darker color
so here is how our clustered column
chart looks like and we can see the
sales by year and quarter
now let me go ahead and
let's add a border now
we'll analyze the seals by each state so
for that
we'll use field map so I'll click on
field map
let me resize it
now let me add the state column onto
location
and the tool tips I'll
add the sales column
let me expand it so you can see here we
have the map which shows the sales by
each state
now let's do some color formatting to
this I'll go to the format tab click on
ADD colors
and blue is the default color there is
an additional option
where you can use conditional formatting
so I'll use that so it gives you the
option to choose your color between
maximum value and the minimum value you
can also choose this diverging option
where you get a center value or a mid
value as well now for the minimum value
I'll choose a color again I'll use a
custom color it will be similar to a
green color
red okay then
let's use some orange color for the mid
value range for example EB
and similarly for the maximum value
we'll use a little darker color which
looks similar to red
click enter so now we have defined our
color scheme
let's click on OK
let's zoom out so you can see the states
which are in green color meet the lowest
amount of sales while those which are in
orange or in red meet the highest amount
of sales so in this example you can see
California had the highest amount of
sales similarly New York is next is just
below California with the amount of
sales followed by Texas we'll go back
let me also
add a border to this similarly you can
also select the profit column or the
unit sold column to see the units or the
profit that were sold by each state
so let me now go ahead and create a
donut chart in the donut chart we'll
analyze the sales and profit by each
segment
so under visualizations I click on donut
chart
so under Legend I'll add the segment
column
under values I'll take the sales column
and
we also want the profit so I'll take The
Profit column onto tooltips
so you can see we have our donor chart
prepared and you can see the sales and
profit by each segment
let me expand this the donut chart
indicates consumer segment made the
highest amount of sales and profit while
home office segment made the lowest
I'll go back
let me go to the format tab
and we'll make some formatting to our
data
let's change the color of all the
segments
choose custom color
let's give a color
coding as
1558c
similarly we change
the color for corporate segment as well
let's take a gray color
and finally we'll change the color for
home office as well
I'll also switch on the border
so we have our donor chart prepared now
let's move ahead and create a pie chart
to analyze the profit and sales by each
category of products so under
visualizations I'll select pie chart
I'll drag the category column onto
Legend
under values I'll take the profit column
and under tooltips I'll take the sales
column
so you can see we have a simple pie
chart that tells you the profit and the
sales that were made by each category
as it's evident category technology made
the highest amount of sales and profit
while Furniture category made the lowest
amount of profit and sales
I'll go back
under format I'll change the data Colors
Let's go ahead and do that
I'll use custom colors and give
a hexadecimal color value
similarly for office supplies
I'll take another hexadecimal value
and finally we'll change the color of
the furniture category
also
let's give a border
so we have a pie chart prepared that
tells you the profit and sales by each
category of products now we are done
with our first sales dashboard so I can
go ahead
and rename
this tab as
overall sales
next we are going to analyze the sales
profit quantity sold and all of these
by taking region and the state as
filters so we'll continue with the same
drill first I'll create a text box
so under home menu I'll go to text box
I'll stretch this
I'll give a title to this page for
example region
and
state
level analysis
let me make it bold
and
I'll increase the size to 28
make it Center aligned
we'll make the text
as white
and
the visualizations
let's give a background color
I choose this blue color
so let me go ahead and create three
slicers a region slicer a state slicer
and a ear slicer so under visualizations
I'll click on slicer
let me resize
move it on top
and
for region slicer I need to add region
onto fields
so you can see we have a region filter
now
let's do some formatting to this
under slicer header
let me make the font color
white and
let's give a background
let's say blue
and let me increase the text size to
say 15.
you can also choose a font family
let's go for calibri
and
you can increase the size
of the items let's increase the text
size
to
say 15.
and
let's give a border
so now you have the region slicer ready
let me copy paste this
next
we'll create the state slicer so I'll
remove region from here and add
State onto the field
you can see we have the state slicer
ready similarly
you can also go ahead
and create a year slicer
but you can analyze the sales and profit
or quantity by year
I'll remove State from here
and
I'll drag the ear column onto field
you can see we have all the four years
from 2014 to 2017. so sometimes it might
be difficult for you to scroll through
all the values present in a slicer for
example in the state slicer
you can see there are multiple States
and if you want to filter your report by
a particular State you have to always
scroll down or scroll up and check
manually where the state is so power bi
gives you this feature where you can use
the search option so if I click on this
you can see there's a search option
select that so now
in the search bar you can search for any
state you are looking for for example if
you want to search for California state
you can just type on California so you
have just type Cal and it shows me
California that's an important feature
that power bi gives you
so let me now go ahead and create a
simple table where we will see the
quantity and the profit made in each
City so under visualizations I'll select
tables
let me resize this
so under values first I'll add the city
column
followed by
the quantity column
and
The Profit column
let's do some formatting
so under column headers
let me change the font color to white
and let's add a background
let me increase the text size also
let's make it 15
similarly if you scroll down under
values
let's increase the text size
to 15 as well
and
let's choose the font family let's take
consoles
so here
you can see all the cities
the quantity
sold in each City and the profit that
was made in each of these cities
now let me add a border to this
so now you can filter each of these
cities by region or by state
for example if I choose Central
as my region
it will give you all the cities that lie
in the central region
similarly
you can also search for any state for
example
I am taking Minnesota
so under Minnesota
you can see all the cities and the
quantity as well as the profits made
let me now uncheck the filters now let
me go ahead and filter this table
in terms of profit so I'll sort by
profit
you can see
we have our cities sorted in terms of
profit
so New York City made the highest amount
of profit followed by Los Angeles and
Seattle below you can see the total
units that were sold and the total
profit that was made from all the cities
so you can also filter down the quantity
sold and the profit made by each year as
well as by region and State
so let's see
suppose I am choosing
East as the region
so under East it tells you the states
that are present
let's
go for Delaware
and let's select 2016 as my year
so you can see
the cities that lie under delivery state
and the quantity as well as the profit
the made in 2016. similarly let's select
Massachusetts as the state and let's
go for another year for example 2017
you can see all the cities that are
present under Massachusetts the quantity
sold and the profit that was made below
you can see the total quantity and the
profit
let me uncheck all these
now moving ahead let's analyze the sales
by each state and the category of
product for this
will create a clustered bar chart so
under visualizations I'll select
clustered bar chart let me resize a bit
under access
I'll take the state column
I'll take category onto Legend
and and the values
I'll put the sales column
so you can see here
we have the seals for each category
under each state
for example California state made the
highest amount of sales under technology
category and it made the lowest amount
of sales under office supplies
if I scroll down you can see all the
states
and the seals they made
for each category
I'll go back to the report
now let's use some filters
you can filter here for example if I
want to check
the sales by each state and category for
2015 I can just
click on 2015
and it will tell you the sales that were
made
now let's do some formatting to this bar
chart
I'll change the colors for each of the
categories
similarly we change the color for office
supplies
and finally for the technology
so now we have our bar chart ready
moving on now let me add a border to
this bar chart
okay
so now that we have seen our sales by
state and category let's now check the
profit by year and category for that
we'll create an area chart
foreign
this chart
now
under axis
I'll take the year column
under Legend
I'll take the category column
and
the values
I'll take profit
so we have our area chart that depicts
The Profit by each year and the category
to which the product belong to
I'll go to the format tab and under data
colors
I'll choose some colors
let's change Furniture to this blue
color
I'll take office supplies a red color
and Technology I'll use a green color
so now you can use the filters
for example you can check the profit
that was made by each year and category
under east region
so you can see here
in 2017 technology meet the highest
amount of profit while furniture at the
lowest
similarly
let's
check for South Region
so you can see in south region in 2016
technology meet the highest amount of
profit and
furniture made the lowest in 2017 office
supplies made the highest amount of
profit and Furniture was the lowest
I'll uncheck this South Region filter
similarly you can also see the sales by
each state so under State slicer you can
choose whichever State you want and
check the profit it made by that year or
category
for example I'll choose Connecticut
so you can see the profit Connecticut
state made in each of these years
I'll uncheck it
let us move ahead and now let's see
profit that was made and the quantity
that was sold by each category and
subcategory of the product so for this
I'll choose the line and cluster column
chart so I'll select from the
visualizations now
under shared access
I'll select the category column under
column series I'll take the subcategory
column
under column values
I'll choose profit
and
I'll choose quantity
under the tooltips
so now you can see the profit that was
made under each category and the
subcategory
for technology category copiers
subcategory meet the highest amount of
profit the quantity sold was 234.
similarly
if you check for furniture category
we didn't make any profit for table
subcategory
and as well as for bookcases
under office supplies paper subcategory
made the highest amount of profit
now let me go ahead and add a border to
this
fine
moving ahead now we will see the sales
by each segment for that let's create a
funnel so from visualizations I'll take
the
funnel and
I'll drag
segment onto group
and the sales column onto values
so you can see here
the sales that were made by each segment
this picture clearly depicts that
consumer segment with the highest amount
of sales next was corporate and then
home office
now
let's do some color formatting so the
default color is this blue
I'll click on so all
now we'll give individual colors to each
of the segments
using custom color
let's give a hexadecimal value
similarly we'll change the color for the
corporate segment
and finally for the home office segment
now let me go ahead and give a border to
it
so if you want to analyze the seals by
segment and for
a particular region or state or any
particular year you can do that so let's
select
for each region
and
let's take New Jersey as the state
for year 2014 suppose
so you can see here corporate segment
meet the highest amount of sales
followed by consumer and home office
let me uncheck
these filters
so our second report is ready where we
analyzed the sales quantity profit at
Region level state level and by year so
I can rename this
as
a region and State
next we will analyze the sales quantity
profit in terms of categories and
subcategory of products so let me first
copy this text box
and create a new tab
I'll paste that text box here and
change the title to
say
category
and
sub category level analysis
first
we'll create a
slicer
where we will take
the category as filter
so if I want I can directly copy it
from my previous tab
and change the fields so let me copy
this
and paste it here
I'll sync it
and let me remove the region field and
add
category onto the field
so you can see
we have the three categories here
let me copy paste this again
and
let me take the subcategory now
so I'll select this
and
I'll track sub category onto the field
so here you can see we have all the
subcategories and above we have the
categories
let me resize this a bit
with that now let's analyze the sales
and profit by region and segment
to do this we'll use a tree map so let's
see how you can build a tree map under
visualizations I have tree map let me
select it
and move it to the top
and expand it a bit
now
under group
I'll select region column
under details I'll take
segment
I'll take the sales column under values
and let's take profit
onto tooltips
so if I expand this
you can see the sales and profit by each
region and segment for example in the
west region you have consumer corporate
and home office
as the segments and you can see consumer
segment meet the highest amount of sales
and profit while home office meet the
lowest amount of sales and profit
similarly you can check for the other
regions as well
now
let's give a border to this tree map and
under data colors let me change the
color of the regions
scroll down
custom color let me let me choose my own
color
let's take this as a gray color
and finally
for the best region
so now you can select individual
categories and subcategories to check
the sales and profit by region and
segment for example
if I select
Furniture as my category
you can see the changes that were made
to the tree map
you can also select office supplies and
see
how the sales and profit changes
similarly you can also go ahead and
select whatever subcategories you want
and then check the sales and profit by
region and segment with that let me now
create a pie chart
to see the quantity and the sales by
each segment
so I'll go and select a pie chart
let me resize this
if you want you can increase the size of
this tree map also
so let me go ahead
and select segment onto the legend
under values I'll take quantity
and
sales under tooltips
so this pie chart
depicts the quantity and the sales that
were made by each segment as you can see
consumer segment meet the highest amount
of sales and had the highest quantity
sold
while home office had the least number
of quantities sold and the least number
of sales
let's add a border
and
change the data colors
similarly I'll change the color for the
corporate segment let's make this
Gray
and home office
I'll take the following color
move this a little to the right
now let's build a scatter plot to
analyze the sales quantity and profit by
each subcategory
so under visualizations
I'll select scatter plot I'll resize
this
so I'll add
sub category onto Legend
then I'll add sales onto the x-axis
quantity sold onto the y-axis
and under size
will take the profit column
if I expand this
you can see the sales quantity and the
profit that was made for each
subcategory of products you can see here
subcategory phone has given us a
significant amount of sales with less
number of quantities sold and it has
given us a good amount of profit also
similarly subcategory shares has also
given us good amount of sales with close
to 2356 quantities sold and a good
amount of profit if you see this one
which is sub category paper it gave us
less amount of sales with more
quantities sold while it gave us good
amount of profit though so you may
promote phones or for example chairs to
sell more since it gives you more amount
of profit with less quantity sold
let's add a border to this
you can use the category filter suppose
if I choose for furniture
and expand this
you can see
under Furniture subcategory Furnishings
give us the lowest amount of sales with
the highest number of quantities sold
but it gave us a decent amount of profit
subcategory tables give us a decent
amount of sales with lesser number of
quantities sold but didn't give us any
profit
subcategory chairs give us the highest
amount of sales and also the profit
I'll uncheck this
let's now create a line chart where we
can see the profit by each year and
quarter so under visualizations
I'll select line chart let me resize
this
so under access
I'll take year
and a legend
I'll take the quarter column
and under values
I'll take the profit column
so now you can see The Profit that was
made each year and the lines depict each
quarter
so if you check for 2014 quarter four
meet the highest amount of profit while
quarter 2 made the lowest amount of
profit while quarter one made the lowest
amount of profit similarly if you see
for 2016 you can see
quarter four meet the highest amount of
profit
while quarter One Meet the lowest
if you check for 2017 you see a quarter
three and quarter four almost made the
same amount of profit while
quarter 2 made the lowest amount of
profit
I go back
now you can filter these by categories
also suppose if I see for technology
you can check the amount of profit that
was made in each year and in each
quarter for technology category
let's add a border to this
likewise we'll now create another line
chart that will depict the sales by each
year and quarter
so let me copy paste this
I'll drag this to the right
now I'll remove
profit from values and add sales
let me uncheck this also
so here you can see we have the sales by
each year and quarter
now if you see for 2014 again quarter
four made the highest amount of sales
and quarter 1 in 2014 with the lowest
you will see for 2016 you can see 2016
also quarter four meter highest amount
of sales and quarter one meter lowest
and go back
so our final report is ready where we
analyzed the sales quantity sold the
profit at category and subcategory level
I can go ahead and rename this as
category
and sub category
let me save this now if you want
you can also filter it by sub categories
for example if I select
chairs as my subcategory
so for chairs you can see the sales that
was made by each year and quarter
so in 2017 quarter four made the highest
amount of sales while quarter one made
the lowest amount of sales for cheers
similarly
you can select other subcategories also
for example
let me take
some other category like
machines
let's see the profit now
so for machine subcategory you can see
in 2014 quarter four meet the highest
amount of profit while
quarter 3
meet the lowest amount of profit
now if you check for 2015 you can see
quarter 3 made the highest amount of
profit in chairs while quarter 1 made
the lowest amount of profit
let's uncheck this
so now we are almost done building a
report using the superstore sample data
set
so we have our three reports ready you
can see the first one was overall sales
the second report we created
by taking region State and the year as
filters so we had a region and state
level analysis and finally we analyzed
the sales quantity and the profits sold
by category and subcategory so I have
arranged all these graphs and charts so
that it looks little better now let me
go to this publish option on the top so
that we can publish this report onto the
power bi dashboard
so I'll click on publish
I'll save it
you can select the destination here I
have only one destination which is my
workspace so I'll choose it and select
so there you go publishing to power bi
it was successful
I'll close it
and let me move to my power bi service
I'll refresh it for once
so under my workspace
you can see we have the dashboard report
So Below you can see there are three
tabs that we created the first one is
overall sales
the second one is sales by region the
third one is by category and subcategory
now to put this reports onto the
dashboard I need to pin each one of
these visualizations
so let me pin one by one
so it asks where would you want to pin
it to I'll select the existing dashboard
or better let's create a new dashboard
let's say
power bi
Dash code
spin it
close this
similarly let's spin the remaining ones
I'll select power bi dashboard again pin
it
let's spin everything
so this slicer you can't pin it
let's do the remaining ones
same will do for the donut chart
as well as
for the pie chart
now
now if I go to
my dashboards
and select power bi dashboard
you can see
we have a one page
dashboard here
you can resize all the charts and graphs
let me resize it
and move it to the top
so we have our first canvas here
which tells you the overall sales the
profit and the units that were sold over
different states different segments
and by categories so one of the
important feature that power bi service
gives you is that you can ask questions
about your data and it will tell you
what the exact solution is for example
you can see here you have a field where
you can ask questions so for example if
I type
total sales
and hit enter
so it tells you the total amount of
sales that were made which is 2.3
million dollars similarly if I want to
find out the total
profit I can search for it here
hit enter it will give you the exact
amount of profit that was made let's do
something else for example if you want
total
profit
by
say here
I'll hit enter it gives you a nice line
chart where you can see the total profit
that was made over all the four years
next suppose I search for total
quantity
sold
by
segment
see it gives me a bar chart where you
can see the total quantity that was sold
and it gives you a list of options where
you can find out the total quantity that
was sold by city state order ID first
name last name and many others so
consumer segment had the highest
quantity sold
let's see for something else for example
if you want
the total
sales by
say subcategory
I'll choose the first one see you have
all the subcategories and the total
sales that they made so it's a very
interesting feature that power bi gives
you go back
now if you want
you can go to the report menu
and if you want you can pin the other
visualizations as well
so another important feature about power
bi dashboard is that you can derive
insights from the visualization for
example
if I click on these dots there's an
option you find view insights I'll
select it
so on the right you can see Power bi has
itself given us some insights from the
data and the visualizations we have made
in C sales by year and quarter
the sales by day of week and quarter
sales by shipment mode where you can see
the standard classic Mode made the
highest amount of sales
you can also see the sales and count of
City by year
and many more
in this video we'll be creating two
dashboards using a sample sales data set
so if you want to get the data and the
dashboard file that we'll be creating in
this demo then please put your email IDs
in the comments section of the video our
team will share the files via email now
let's begin by understanding what is the
dashboard in Excel
a dashboard is a visual interface that
provides an overview of key measures
relevant to a particular objective with
the help of charts and graphs
dashboard reports allow managers to get
a high level overview of the business
and help them make quick decisions
there are different types of dashboards
such as strategic dashboards analytical
dashboards and operational dashboards an
advantage of dashboards is the quick
detection of outliers and correlations
with Comprehensive data visualization it
is time saving as compared to running
multiple reports
with this understanding let's jump into
our demo for creating a dashboards we'll
be using a sample sales data set let me
show you the data set first
so here is the sales data set that we'll
be using for our demo
so this data set was actually generated
using a simulator and is completely
random it was not validated though we
have applied certain transformations to
the data using power query features
so this data as you can see has
1000 rows so using the simulator we had
generated thousand rows of data
similarly if I go on top you can see
this data set has 17 columns
now let me give you a brief about each
of the columns so first we have the
region column so we have Middle East and
North Africa this North America Asia
sub-Saharan Africa and others
similarly we have the country names from
which the item was ordered
the third column is the item type so we
have different items Cosmetics
vegetables there's baby food cereal
fruits
Etc
then we have the representatives name or
you can see this as the customer name
who ordered the product
then we have a sales Channel column so
there are basically two channels whether
the item was sold offline or online next
we have the order priority column now
here C stands for critical
then we have H which is for high
priority orders then we have M for
medium priority orders and finally we
have L which is for low priority orders
you can see the order date column then
we have the order ID the ship date next
we have
units sold
which is basically the total number of
units sold for each item
then we have the unit price column this
is the price at which each product was
sold
then we have the unit cost column which
is basically the production cost for
each of the items
next we have the total revenue the total
revenue is actually the product of units
sold and unit price
then we have the total cost column now
the total cost column is actually the
product of units sold and the unit cost
similarly we have the total profit
column so total profit is the difference
between total revenue and the total cost
and finally
we have created two more columns that is
order year and then we have order month
now these two columns were actually
generated using the power query features
so we use the order date column which is
this column and extracted order year and
Order month
so first we are going to create a
revenue dashboard where we'll focus on
generating reports for Revenue by order
year Revenue by year and region Revenue
by order priority and much more
will create separate po tables and po
charts and format them to make them look
more interesting and presentable
we'll add slices and timeline to our
dashboards in order to filter it based
on specific fields
now let's create our first report to see
the total revenue generated each year
so we need to create a pivot table for
this I'll click on a cell in my data set
and then I'll go to the insert tab here
we have the option to select the pivot
table
I click on this
you can see
my table range is selected
next I want to place my pivot table in a
new worksheet
and let's just click on OK
there you go so we have a new sheet
where I can place my pivot table
so first I need to find the total
revenue generated by each year so what
I'll do is
I'll drag my order here column
under rows and then
I'll select the total revenue column
under values
you can see I have my Pivot chart ready
now if you want you can sort this
so from the data you can see we have
order Year from 2010 to 2017
now based on this data let's create our
pivot chart so I'll click on any cell
go to insert and here you have the
option to select recommended charts I
click on this
now actually I want a line chart so I'll
click on
line here and select ok
there you go so we have successfully
created our first pivot chart
now
let me show you how you can format this
chart to make it more readable
so first let me delete
these so I'll right click and select
hide all field buttons on the chart so
this will delete the buttons present on
the chart now let me go ahead and edit
the chart title
so the title I want is total revenue
I'll type it down
by year
all right
next
let's do a few more transformations
so if I click on this plus sign
which is actually for chart elements we
have some options like to add access
access titles chart title data labels
this grid lines Legend and others
Okay so
let's remove the legend now
you can see the total Legend is gone
now let me
add access titles so we label our x-axis
and y axis so here under x-axis
I can
write it as
year
similarly on the y-axis I'll put Revenue
okay now you can move
a bit
all right
now
let me select this chart Style option
and go to Colors first
here I'll select yellow color okay
and then let me go back to style
let's select a new style from this list
I want
this die
okay
now you can also add
data labels so I'll just click on data
labels
you can see we have
the revenue for each of the years now
this is not readable at all so we'll
format this a bit
if I click on this Arrow here I have
more options
if I scroll down you can see we have
something called as number here
I'll expand this
and under category I'll select custom
now here
will give a format code
which is a bit different
so this is actually a kind of a formula
so I'll write if my Revenue value
is greater than
let's say
9 lakhs
000.
let me make sure there are six nines
here so one two three four five and six
okay we are good to go
I'll close the bracket
I'll give a hash
give two commas
so if the revenue is greater than 9
lakhs 99 000 I'll put it in the format
of millions So within double quotes I'll
write m
I'll give a semicolon
followed by
another hash
and if the value is less than
the desired number
it should be 0 million let me click on
ADD
all right you can see how nicely we have
formatted our data and you see here we
have
added the new format which is in
millions
all right now if you want you can go
ahead and adjust the
boxes let me move this a bit up I'll
delete this
now if you notice this line chart you
can make a few conclusions for example
if you see here in 2010 the total
revenue generated was nearly 175 million
now this came down to 150 million in
2011 then the revenue constantly grew
from 2011 till 2014 it reached 195
million
and after 2014 it again came down to
180 million and the revenue dropped
significantly between 2016 and 2017. in
2017 the revenue was just 96 million
now before moving ahead to my next chart
let me just rename this sheet so I'll
write it as
Revenue
by year
all right
now
let's analyze the revenue generated each
year in different regions so for this
we'll create another pivot table
let me close this
I'll click on any cell go to insert and
select pivot table
I just click ok so that my PO table is
placed on a new sheet
all right
now this time we want the revenue by
each year and region so first of all
let's drag region to
columns
then
let's drag the order year column under
rows and then
I'll select total revenue onto values
so here you can see we have the pivot
table ready so for 2010 you can see in
Asia
this was the revenue generated
similarly if you see for 2013 this was
the total revenue generated in Europe
and
we have for other years as well
now let's create a line chart based on
this pivot table so I'll select any cell
in the pivot table I'll go to insert and
I'll click on recommended charts from
this list I'll select my line chart and
click on OK there you go
so we have our next pivot chart ready
so on the right you see the different
regions that are present in different
colors let me just expand it so that you
can see all the regions we have
so in total we have
seven regions
and each of the regions have been
represented in different colors
so if you notice this graph
for the
sub-Saharan African region in 2012
sub-Saharan Africa made the highest
amount of sales
now from the sample data you can also
tell
that the revenue for North America has
been significantly low compared to other
regions
similarly if you see
for Europe
this was the revenue Trend between 2010
and 2017 so if you see here in 2011 the
sales
where at this level then it
significantly dropped in 2012 then in
there was a huge Spike and then in again
came down in 2015 and so on so you can
make your own conclusions by looking at
these line charts now let's
format this chart so first of all let's
delete the field buttons present on the
chart and we'll also
delete the Legend all right now let me
just reduce the size of the chart
next we'll add a chart title so
will
give the title as Revenue
by
year and
region
okay
you can also format the
y-axis in terms of Millions
so I'll right click on this axis and
I'll select format access
I'll scroll down and here we have
the number drop down
let me scroll again
under category I'll select custom
and
we will use this format that we created
for our previous chart there you go you
can see
our access labels have been changed in
terms of millions now
so let's close this and let me save it
now you can reduce the font size or
increase the font size let me just show
you suppose you want to increase the
font size of the chart title so you just
select it and from here you can either
reduce or you can increase you can see
now it's 12 if you want you can make it
16. similarly you can also edit the
access labels also by selecting the
chart title you can also move it to left
or right or you can place it in the
center as well for the time being let me
just keep it to the left
all right
now
we'll see the revenue and total cost
by each region and will create a combo
chart for this so let me show you how to
do it
I'll go to my data sheet
I have my cell selected
go to insert and click on pivot table
let me just click on OK all right
so for this
I'll select
my region onto rows
and then
I'll have
two columns under values the first one
is going to be total revenue
and the next column will be the total
cost column all right so here we have
the pivot table ready now based on this
pivot table let's create our pivot chart
so I'll go to recommended charts and if
you see below
at the bottom we have combo chart so
this is the preview of the combo chart
all right now let me just click on OK
there you go so we have a nice combo
chart ready here
now the way to look at it is the bars
represent the total revenue which is
this column
now
the line represents
the total cost
so let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so first of all let's delete the
field buttons all right and let's also
remove the legend from here
next
we'll add data labels so I'll click on
data labels here
okay so these are the data labels for
the bars or the revenue column
now
let's format the detail labels in terms
of millions so I'll click on this Arrow
go to more options
if I scroll down
I have number
from here I'll select custom and
I'll choose my type that is in millions
all right so you can see we have
formatted our data
next thing we'll add a chart title
so here I'll write as
Revenue
by
region
it's actually revenue and total cost
by region
before moving ahead let me
rename the sheets as well I'll write
revenue and
total cost
similarly
sheet 3 also I am going to rename it as
Revenue
by
year and region
so this makes your sheet more readable
all right
now moving ahead
next we are interested to get the
revenue generated by order priority and
for this we are going to create a pie
chart
so let's go to the data sheet and create
our pivot table first
I click on OK
now
I'll select order priority under rows
and under values I'll select total
revenue
so this is a very simple pivot table so
you have your order priority so C is for
critical H is for high L is for low and
M is for medium now based on this let's
create a pie chart
so I'll go to recommended charts and
here you have pie chart
I want to select this 3D type of pie
chart and I'll click on OK all right so
we have our pie chart ready let me just
resize it and from here I'll remove the
field buttons
and also don't need the legend so I'll
delete this as well
all right now let's give a chart title
so this is going to be
Revenue by
order
priority
now let's add
our data labels
I'll check this option
okay now let's again format this in
terms of Millions
so here
I click on the last option I'll go to
numbers
under category I'll select custom and my
type is going to be in terms of millions
there you go
let me close this
I will just
move this
to the center
all right
now if you want you can change the color
of the text as well
so let's
have it in white color and see how it
looks okay so this looks pretty decent
cool
now
moving to our next report
so this time
we are going to find the total revenue
by countries so we have multiple
countries present in our data set we
want to visualize the revenue generated
in each country
so for this we are going to create a
horizontal bar chart so let me show you
how to do it but before moving ahead let
me just rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue
by
I'll just put op which stands for order
priority all right
now
let's create our horizontal bar chart
I'll go to insert click on pivot table
and select ok
so I want my Revenue based on different
countries so I'll select country and put
it under rows
and then I'll choose total revenue and
place it under values
so here you have the different country
names we have Afghanistan this Albania
let me scroll down you have Bangladesh
there are
a number of countries you have Czech
Republic there's Estonia France Gabon
similarly if you scroll down
we have India this Jamaica Italy and all
the way to the bottom if you go we have
New Zealand there's Netherlands
Philippines Portugal
we also have
Singapore
lots and lots of countries
we have the UAE United States of America
Zimbabwe and others
all right let me go up
So based on this pivot table let's
create our po chart
so I'll go to insert and select
recommended charts
from here
I'm going to select the column chart you
can see the preview here and let me
click on OK
all right
so here you can see
the different country names at the
bottom and the revenue for each of the
countries
let's go ahead and edit this chart so
first of all I'll delete
the field buttons okay and let me also
remove the legend
here I'll write
Revenue
by
countries
this is going to be my
chart title
okay
let's format this chart a little more
so I'll click on this option
and we'll select a new style let's say
I'll select
style 6 okay
and
let me now go under colors and we'll
select the color of the bars so
let's choose this color okay
so you have
a horizontal column chart ready
and at the bottom you can see the
different country names and we have the
Revenue
cool
now
let me go ahead and
rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue by
countries
and hit enter
okay
and finally we'll create another report
which is going to be part of our Revenue
dashboard and this is revenue by items
so we'll visualize
our revenue for different items present
in the table
so if you see this we have Cosmetics
vegetables cereal fruits this cloths
snacks households and other products as
well so let's check the revenue for each
of these items
so we'll continue the same drill I'll
create my pivot table on a new worksheet
and this time I am going to drag
item type under rows and
will have the total revenue under values
so here on the left of the table you can
see we have the different
item names and then we have the
total revenue
so let me just
sort this
total revenue
from largest to smallest so you can see
here office supplies meet the highest
amount of Revenue
followed by household then cosmetics and
fruits meet the lowest amount of Revenue
I'll click on this go to insert and
select recommended charts this time I am
going to create a bar chart so this is
how my bar chart is going to look like
I'll select OK all right now let's
format this chart a bit
I'll delete the field buttons and I'll
delete the legend as well
and
let's edit the chart title so this is
going to be
Revenue
by
items cool
we also want to change the
color of the bars so I've selected all
the bars I'll go to my home Tab and here
let's say I want to select green color
all right
I've edited my chart a bit now
let's
make it
and I'll remove the Bold
okay
here if you want you can change the font
Also let's keep it in blue color all
right
finally
let's rename this sheet so I'll write
Revenue by
items
cool
finally
now it's time for us to merge
all the charts that we have created
to our dashboard
so let me show you how you can create
the dashboard
I'll create a new sheet
and first thing I am going to do is
I'll click on The View Tab and uncheck
grid lines so this will remove
the grid lines present in the worksheet
next
I am going to insert an image so we'll
have a background image on our dashboard
so the way to do is I'll go to the
insert Tab and under illustrations I
have the option to select pictures or
insert pictures so I'm going to insert
picture
present on the device that is my
computer
I'll go to desktop and here I have a
folder called Excel dashboard files
and I'll select this dashboard
background and hit insert
so this is going to insert an image
now
let me just
drag this image so it covers a fair
enough portion
so I'll hit shift and I'll drag it
all right
so you can see I have successfully added
a background image if you want you can
still
expand this background image
a bit to the right
cool
now the next thing
is going to be
the title of the dashboard so I'll click
on insert and here
I have the option to select a text box
so
I'll click on a text box and
I'm going to place text box in the
middle
and I'm going to name this text box as
Excel
Revenue dashboard
on sales
I'll
Central init
let's do some more formatting so I'll
select this text box on the top you can
see ship format
here I'm going to expand this shape fill
and I'll select no fill
so my text box is transparent now and
I'll also remove the outline
all right
now let me just double click on the
title of my dashboard and I'm going to
select
a font you can select whichever font you
want
let me stick to Britannica bold
and I'll increase the size to let's say
30.
all right I'll just
drag the text box
I'll make the text as white instead of
black
all right so we have our
title of the dashboard ready
now if you want you can also insert some
icons to this dashboard so I'll go to
insert and I'll click on illustrations
again and select pictures
I am going to add
these two pictures which is of a store
and a cart
to make it look
visually appealing so I'll
place the icons
here and similarly let me just copy it
and I'll place the
card and the store
to the right as well
all right
next
the idea is to
bring in all the charts that we have
created and place it on the dashboard
so let me copy
each of the charts and
place it
on the dashboard so I'll hit
Ctrl V to paste it
and we'll resize this as well
all right
similarly let me bring in all the other
charts as well
all right so now you can see I have
added
all my charts and graphs to this
dashboard
so you can see here we have
our line charts are
column charts the combo charts the Spy
chart
and others
now let me go ahead and format these
charts a little more so you can see this
looks a bit cluttered so let's adjust
the labels let me bring this down
similarly I'll bring
190 million
a little below
all right this looks fine now
one more thing we are going to do is
we'll remove the white background from
each of the charts and make it
transparent so let me show you how to do
it so I'll select this chart
then I'll right click
and go to format chart area
here on the right you see we have an
option called No fill so if I select no
fill you can see the white background
it's gone now similarly let me also
remove the grid lines so I'll select the
grid lines and hit delete so I've also
removed the grid lines from here now
let's also remove the white outline that
we have so I'll select this chart go to
format and here
I'll go to shape outline and I'll select
no outline
you see this so we have our total
revenue by year which is a line chart
and this is completely transparent now
now what I'm going to do is
I'll place this chart over a box so I'll
go to insert and in insert we have the
option to create a shape
so I'll click on illustrations and here
I'll choose a shape and let me select a
rectangle
so I'll just
create a rectangle here
all right and now
what I'll do is
I'll select this and bring this to front
I'll right click
and choose
bring to front
and I'll place this shape
below it
all right now the next thing is to edit
the shape
so first I'll change the color of this
box so let me select this blue color
and and let me increase the transparency
so I'll
right click and go to format shape
here I'll increase the transparency
let's keep it to
25 percent
or let's say 20 percent all right
next thing
we'll just convert all the
font to white color
including the axis labels
the chart title
will also
convert all the
axis labels to white color so it looks
better now we'll just adjust our
chart over here
next thing let's just
remove the outline so I'll go to shape
outline and I'll select no outline you
see
we have now formatted our chart let's
just
pull this a little up
all right now we'll add this blue
background to all the other charts so
we'll first add the background make it
transparent and then we'll convert the
font text to white color to make it more
readable and visible so
for the time being I'll just pause the
video and come back again
all right so now you can see on your
screens we have nicely formatted our
dashboard so I've added a few logos for
each of the charts you can see the logos
here so for
Revenue by countries we have a globe
then if you see here this is kind of a
map or a location
similarly we have all formatted the
color of the bars
then we have also formatted the labels
in terms of Millions
if you look on the y-axis even the
revenue for year-end region are all
formatted in terms of Millions
if you want this you can also format the
total year by Revenue in terms of
millions so the way to do is you can
select this graph
right click and go to format access
here if I scroll down you have numbers
and under category I'll select custom
then I'll select my type as
this format which is in millions
and you see here we have successfully
formatted our
y-axis labels
all right
so the next thing
is to add slicers and timelines to a
dashboard now slicers are used to format
your data based on a particular column
suppose if you want to see Revenue by
certain items you can add item as a
slicer and you can view the entire
dashboard similarly
for timelines you can add date columns
so if you want to see what was the
amount of sales or revenue generated on
a particular year or a particular month
you can do that using a timeline and
here you can see under filters we have
slices and timeline or if you go to the
pivot chart analyze tab here also you
have insert slicer and timeline option
so I'll select insert slicer here first
now it's giving me the list of
Fields present in the data set so I'll
select
country region and let's say we want to
know by
item type and sales channel so these are
going to be my four
slicers I'll click on OK
you can see it here we have our
four slicers here and these are the list
of values under region we have Asia
this Europe North America and others
similarly we have the different country
names for Country slicers and then for
item type also we have all the items
that were present in our data set
now
moving ahead we need to connect
all the slicers to a dashboard so what
I'll do is
I'll right click
on this option
and I'll go to report connections
okay so under report connections you
have
all the pivot tables that we created
you currently see only one of the pivot
table is selected so we need to
select all the pivot tables so let me
check
all the pivot tables present in this
workbook and click on OK
all right now that we have connected one
of our slicers we'll now connect the
other remaining slicers
so I'll right click on this go to report
connections and I'll check
all the pivot tables present in this
worksheet
click on OK
similarly let's do it for the country
slicer
I'll go to report connections and let me
select
all the pivot tables
and finally we have the item type so
I'll right click
go to report connections and then I'll
select
all my Pivot tables
and let's hit OK
all right now let me just organize this
a bit so I'll
place my Pivot tables
to the right
I'll just reduce the size
let me scroll down
I'll add
my region slicer here
similarly
I'll add my final slicer that is sales
Channel
now in our next dashboard which is going
to be the profit dashboard I'll show you
how to add a timeline
all right
now I have arranged all my slicers
so let's see you want to find the
revenue that was generated for an item
type let's say
beverages so you can just select
beverages here
and
all your charts
show the respective revenues so you have
the total revenue by year for beverages
only
similarly here you can see the revenue
by year and region only for beverages
item type
if I scroll down
this chart represents the revenue that
was generated in each of the countries
only for item type beverages
let me just uncheck it
all right
let's say you want to see
the revenue generated for a country like
India
so I have selected India here
and now you can see
My Graph has changed only for
country India
you can see here it is showing only for
India now
similarly you can also filter your
revenues based on the different regions
let's say you want to know the revenue
generated based on sales channel so we
have two sales channel that is offline
and online suppose we want to know the
revenue generated offline so I'll just
select
offline you can see the values have
changed so these were the revenues
generated for each of the items only for
offline
if you
see here now these were all the offline
seals for the different regions
so
this is
our entire Excel Revenue dashboard on
sales
we created multiple charts and graphs
then we applied
different formatting we added different
icons then we formatted the labels also
next we added slicers and
finally we saw how we could filter our
data based on these slicers
likewise now we are going to create a
profit dashboard based on the same data
so before moving ahead let me rename
this sheet as
Revenue dashboard I'll write Rev
dashboard okay
now we move to our data sheet and
start creating a pivot tables and people
charts for the profit dashboard
all right so let me go ahead and create
my first pivot table so
I'll create a new worksheet
this time I am going to create a line
chart to visualize the profit for each
year
so I'll drag my
total profit column two values and my
order here to rows
so here you can see we have our
pivot table ready
now you can sort this data
to get an idea as to which
year had the highest profit and which
year had the lowest profit so from this
pivot table you can see since I've
sorted this data in descending order so
had the maximum amount of profit and
2017 had the least amount of profit
I'll just do Ctrl Z to undo it all right
now based on this pivot table let me go
ahead and create my PO chart so I'll go
to recommended charts and click on a
line chart so this is the preview of the
chart
I'll click on OK
let me close this
similarly
we are going to
edit this chart now so first I'll hide
all the field buttons present on the
chart and I'll
rename the chart title as total
profit
by year
next I am going to remove the legend so
I'll delete this
let's do some more formatting
so
I'll go to style
and
this time
I'm going to select
my style type okay
and if you want you can
choose the colors as well for the time
being let's have this yellow color
next let me add the data labels so again
if you see here this is not formatted
properly so let's go ahead and format
the
data labels so I'll click on number
and I'll select custom here
and the type I'm going to select is in
millions and I'll click on
close so here you can see we have our
line chart ready which shows total
profit by year
let's
rename this sheet as
profit
by
year
all right
now let's move back to our data sheet
again
next we are going to
show the total profit by countries for
this I am going to create a map so let
me first create my pivot table so I'll
go to insert and I'll click on pivot
table
let me click on OK
since I want the country name so I'll
select country under rows and then I
have
my total profit under values
the next thing I'm going to do is I'll
just rename the rule labels as
countries
and then
I am going to delete the
grand total which you can see at the
bottom so here we have the grand total
let me just delete the grand total so
I'm going to select this pivot table go
to the design tab here we have subtotals
in Grand totals I'll
switch off the grand total let me just
verify it again I'll scroll down you see
the grand total has gone now
all right now we want to create a map
out of this the way to do is
I'm going to
select my data
copy it
'll go on top
and I'll paste it here
using this data I can create my field
map now so I'll go to insert here we
have the option to create a field map
there you go
you can see we have our map ready
I can expand this
as you can see our map has a color scale
which comes from light gray color to
dark blue color
so the countries that are in Gray or you
can see light blue
have the lowest amount of profit while
the regions or the countries that have
been shaded in
dark color or dark blue color have
highest amount of profit
I will go ahead and delete this scale
okay
next we need to connect this map to the
original data source so what I do is
I'll right click on this map and I'll go
to select data here instead of the
previous range I'll give my new Range
now so my new range
will be my original pivot table that I
had created
I'll go on top and click on OK
so we have our
map ready now now if you want you can
change the color of the shade so I'll
just go to colors and let's see we'll
keep green color
so the countries that are shaded in dark
green have the highest amount of profit
while those which are highlighted in
light green color are
are the countries that made least amount
of profit
okay now moving on
next
we want to create a pivot table
that will show us the profit by
year and sales channel so for this we
are going to create another line chart
so I'll go to insert and click on pivot
table so I'll select new worksheet here
since I want to know the profit by year
first of all I'll drag my order here
column to rows
and then
I'll choose my total profit column under
values
next I'm going to select my sales
Channel under columns there you go so we
have our pivot table here based on this
pivot table let me create my PO chart so
I'll go to recommended charts and I'm
going to create a line chart
I close this
you see here
based on this chart you can tell
The Profit generated with
online sales were actually lower than
that of offline so here the Blue Line
represents offline profit and the Orange
Line represents Online Profit
if you Mark Clearly
in year 2012 the Online Profit was
actually higher than the offline profit
so let me go ahead and edit this chart a
bit so we'll delete the field buttons
I'll also delete the legend for now
let me go ahead and add
a chart title so I'll write
profit
by
year and
sales Channel
okay
so this is my
second report before moving ahead let me
just
rename this sheet so I'll write
profit
by
countries
similarly
let me rename this sheet as
profit
by
year and let's say SC for sales Channel
okay
moving ahead
now I want to create a pie chart
based on a pivot table that will show
The Profit by sales Channel only so this
is going to be a simple pie chart so
I'll first go to insert click on pivot
table and click on OK
so I'll drag my sales Channel under rows
and then we'll have the total profit
column under values
so this is my simple pivot table now
let's create our pivot chart which is
going to be a pie chart let me explore
the other types of pie charts we have
okay so I'm going to select a donut
chart here and click on OK
let's
edit this chart I'll remove the field
buttons let me now remove the legend as
well
I'll just resize it
and this is going to be
profit
by
sales Channel
okay
let's also add
data labels
and here again
I am going to
format this label
I'll select the category as custom and
my type
will be in millions okay
let me just
move this
to the left
and this to the right
okay
let's also delete the lines cool
now let me just rename this sheet so
I'll write
profit
by
let's say C which stands for sales
Channel
cool
finally I am going to create a report
that will show the revenue and profit by
items
so I'll go ahead and create my pivot
table first
this time I'll choose my
total profit under values
and will also have
the revenue column
so I'll put my Revenue at the top
then I am going to select
item type under rows
so here is my pivot table
based on this pivot table let me now
create a combo chart
so you can see the preview of the chart
the blue bars represent the total
revenue and the Orange Line represents
the total profit
I'll click on OK
let me close this
first
let's remove the field buttons
let's also remove
the legend here
then we'll add a chart title I'll name
it as
Revenue
and
profit
by
items
okay
if you want you can also go ahead and
change the color of the bars
so let me just select
one of these colors okay
all right
so we have our five reports ready that
we are going to use for our profit
dashboard
next let's create a new sheet and we'll
get started with building a dashboard
so I'll click on a new sheet let me just
rename this as
profit dashboard
all right
we'll continue with the previous drill
so
first of all let's go to the view Tab
and remove the grid lines
now
will insert a background image
like we did for our Revenue dashboard so
I'll go to insert under illustration so
I'll click on pictures and select this
device
I am going to have the same background
I'll click on insert
all right so you can see we have a
picture of a company or you can say an
organization let's just drag this
a bit to the right
will adjust the size also
all right
now let's copy the title of my profit
dashboard so here you can see I have
brought my Revenue dashboard
and I'll copy the title and the logos
that we used
for the revenue dashboard
I'll paste it on my new dashboard
let's just align it
in the center
all right the next step
let me now go ahead and edit the title
so this is actually going to be
Excel
profit dashboard instead of Revenue
now we'll copy each of the charts that
we just created for example
the revenue and profit by items then we
had
profit by sales Channel
all this we are going to copy one by one
and put it on the profit dashboard
so let me just copy a few now
we'll paste it here
and later on we can make the adjustment
and copy this as well
similarly I'll bring the other three
charts onto my sales dashboard
okay so here on my
profit dashboard I have added all the
charts
and have
aligned and reshaped it so that it looks
good
I have also made some formatting for
example I have reduced the size of the
chart title
now let me go ahead and
show you a few more formatting that we
also did for the revenue dashboard first
let's remove the white background from
all the charts so I'll
select the first chart I'll right click
and I'll
click on
format chart area
here under fill I'll select no fill
next I am going to remove the grid line
so I'll just delete it
let me close this
now we also have a
outline so I'll go to design
actually format and I'll remove the
outline
next I'm going to add
a blue box at the back like how we did
for the revenue dashboard so let me
select a blue box from here and I'm
going to paste it here
okay
let me just select
the chart and I'll bring this to front
and I'll move this
to the back
next I am going to change the font color
all to White
so that it's clearly visible and it's
more readable
I'll do it for the x-axis as well okay
so here I have my first
chart ready the same I'm going to do for
the rest of the charts
okay so now you can see here I have
formatted all my charts I have also
added a blue background
you see here I have also formatted the
y labels in terms of millions which is
actually the profit similarly here I
have added the data labels this is for
Revenue
some of the charts also have the data
Legend so here you can see the blue
color represents offline
and the red represents online similarly
here
you have the legends
have also formatted the map as well
okay now the next thing
is to make this dashboard more
interactive so we'll add our slicers as
well as timeline first let me show you
how to add a timeline
so I'll select one of the charts and
I'll go to insert under insert I have
the option to create a timeline
so I'll just
click on timelines
so timeline is actually based on date
columns so since in our data set we only
have two date columns one is order date
and one is ship date so Excel has only
shown us two columns so I'm going to
create my timeline based on order date
so I'll select my order date column and
I'll click on OK
you can see here this is called a
timeline I can expand this now this
timeline is based on months now and if I
scroll this timeline you can see here I
have my order year 2010 and I have all
the 12 months similarly we have for 2011
then we have for 2012 all the way till
2017. now you can filter this in terms
of years quarters months or days let me
just select year now so I have
years from 2010 till 2017 let me just
squeeze this and I'll place it somewhere
here on the right
now let me go ahead and create a few
slices for my profit dashboard so I've
selected one of the charts
under insert I'll click on slicer
you can see it gives me the list of
columns from which I want to create
slicers so I'll create region
let me also select country
let's say I want
the representatives name or the
customer's name
and I'll click on OK
so here I have created three slicers
let me
first resize it and
I'll place it
on the right
similarly I'll place the
country column also
then we have
the region slicer
I'll resize this and I'll bring it here
okay
the next thing we need to do is
I have to connect all the slicers and
the timeline
to
pivot tables
for the profit dashboard so I'm going to
click on
the multiple select option and go to
report connections here I'm going to
select
all the pivot tables that are related to
profit
so here I have selected four and I need
one more which is view table number 10
if I click on OK
similarly let's create or connect my
region filter to all the pivot tables so
I right click go to report connections
here I'll choose all my Pivot tables
which are based on profit
I'll click on OK
let's do it for the country slicer as
well
click on OK and similarly I'll connect
my timeline as well I'll go to report
connections
and I'll select
all the pivot tables related to profit
then I'll click on OK
let me now go ahead and create another
slicer based on sales channel so I am
selecting one of the pivot charts I'll
go to insert click on slicer and I'll
select sales Channel and hit OK
so I have my sales Channel
slicer now let me connect it to all the
respective pivot tables
that are based on profit
click on OK
now
let me just bring it here
all right
the next thing I want to show is
how are we going to use the timeline
first
so you see we have all the
years here from 2010 till 2017
suppose you want to know the profit that
was generated in the year 2012 so I'll
just click on this range and now you can
see our
charts only so information for 2012 so
this dot represents that was 51 million
profit in the year 2012. similarly you
can see here
The Profit by sales channel for 2012
from the map you can see the different
countries and the
profit each of these countries made in
if I scroll down you can see the revenue
and profit by items
now if I select
another year let's say 2013 I can just
drag this to the right and now you can
see
our profit by year and sales channel for
offline and online you can see the map
or the line chart for total profit by
year so in 2012 it was 51 million and
then it went up to 54 million in 2013.
similarly
our map has also changed now this is a
sort of an information that we have you
can click on this and
check the information that
Excel has prompted all right so this is
how you can use a timeline now as I said
we checked by
years you can also see it for months and
quarters as well
let me just
uncheck it
I'll
send it back to the place where it was
and I'll reduce the size
okay
now suppose you want to check the profit
made by different Representatives you
can select them one by one let's say
Adam Churchill
this is the
profit generated by Adam Churchill
similarly
you can select multiple persons as well
suppose you want to see the profit by
different countries so you can use the
country slicer let me just bring this to
the middle and let's expand our chart a
bit
okay so here you have the
profit by different countries chart I'll
just bring this to the front so that you
can see it clearly okay
now here suppose you want to see the
profit generated
in let's say United Kingdom you can
select United Kingdom so this is the map
of United Kingdom and it tells you the
total profit that was generated in
United Kingdom and
below you can see
the revenue and profit for all the items
that was sold in
United Kingdom so you had beverages
clothes household office supplies so you
can see clearly
office supplies item at the highest
amount of profit in
United Kingdom now you can also select
multiple countries let's say I want to
know for France as well
so my
map will change accordingly so now I
have
United Kingdom and France selected and
the other charts present in my dashboard
change accordingly now I have my
country selected as India you can see
the map of India here
and these were the respective profit
values now one thing to note here is
this is actually not millions that
should be in K that is Thousands so
please mark this as
1000 and not in millions
even for this this is actually K and
naught million
all right
so we have successfully
created our second dashboard that is
on
profit
let me just resize this a bit and we'll
place it
where it was earlier
cool
so we saw
how to create different pivot tables in
pivot charts and then we formatted our
po charge based on our requirement we
saw how to edit the colors now let me
show you one more thing you can also
change the
look and feel of the dashboard by going
to the page layout tab under page layout
you have themes so here you can select
different themes currently we are
with the office theme now let me just
select another theme let's say face it
you see the colors have changed and it
looks
really beautiful
similarly let me try out
another
theme let's say organic you see a chart
has changed let me just delete this okay
so now once you change the theme the
text also change a bit you can see
the slicers are in a different font
let me explore One More theme let's say
this time I'm going to choose
depth
and this is more
of a green type of color
you can play around and select
whatever theme suits the best
all right
now let me just move back to my Revenue
dashboard and see how it looks there you
go so since we changed our theme even
our Revenue dashboard is also impacted
so
this is how it looks now
you can always go ahead and play with
different themes colors fonts and
effects all right so in this demo we saw
how to create a revenue dashboard so we
created line charts this combo chart pie
chart
horizontal and vertical bar charts and
then we learned how to add slicers and
connect it to different pivot tables and
we filtered our data to see
Revenue as well as profit by items by
countries by different regions
sales Channel
we learned how to create
a map
and lots more and with that we have
reached the end of day 4 of our data
science week on day 5 we are going to
learn about machine learning for data
science thank you all for watching
today's live session I hope it was
useful and informative see you tomorrow
thanks again and keep learning